what's going on patrons how are you guys
doing this is Rob and as promised in at
the end of last week's parisher Max
story arc U that we would experiment
with the first issue of invincible to
see whether or not this is something
that you guys are interested in so
Invincible as you guys know is a story
or at least some of you guys may know is
a story written by Robert Kirkman and is
just kind of a a an alternate take on
superheroes right which is part for the
course when it comes to Indie Comics
just different takes on superheroes just
kind of seeing where they go uh but the
great thing about Invincible is that it
starts out as just kind of your pretty
basic comic book story but it gets
amazing as time goes on it gets really
really really really good but it's kind
of a slow build right it takes a little
while to get up to the point where
things pop off a lot of you guys
probably know that from reading
kirkman's The Walking Dead so uh so
initially this kind of picks up about
four months ago there is a small little
tidbit of a Prelude but it basically
shows Mark you know while you know once
he becomes Invincible but we can kind of
pass over that for a second and so it
jumps back about four months ago with
him basically reading a comic on the
toilet what a great way to start a story
I myself am guilty of that right 25
minute long toilet Ventures Mariah hates
it right cuz like I'll turn on the
shower and then like let it sit for
about 20 minutes so the water warms up
and then like you know be on the toilet
and then take a shower she'll be all
pissed off cuz she'll go to get in the
shower and the water will be
cold but uh but yeah so of course you
know he's kind of yelled at by his mom
and and the reality of of kind of the
opening of this first issue is really
just sort of setting the stage and and
Kirkman crafts this really really really
well where it's just kind of like hey
like you know this is kind of the
general introduction to the characters
right that Mark's getting ready for
school and he's you know he's like you
know did dad come home and she's like no
he's got a lot of trouble at work and
things like that and I wish I knew where
he was and and that kind of a thing only
for us to find out there's this just
crazy Dragon that's essentially
attacking Taiwan and that omn man quote
unquote is the one who is essentially
facing off against it and then of course
you know ultimately comes out on top and
then that's when we basically end up
learning that Mark's dad is omn man
right now omn man is by all standards of
measurement the Superman of this story
and that's one of the cool things about
this it's largely crafted not not really
focusing on omn man himself but focusing
on on Mark right the son of what is this
kind of Superman esque character and so
there are a few things that are
introduced here right in the sense that
once they get out of school that Mark
has a job you know kind of a job at a
pizza gig that he works at so of course
not really able to hang out with his
friends all the time but the reason why
this matters is that once he goes to
take out the trash he accidentally
throws this bag you know like way
far like pretty high into the air and
that's when he realizes it's about time
right and so once they sit down for
dinner his dad of course rushes back and
he basically reveals that he's
developing Powers right that he's
finally getting superpowers and so it's
kind of an interesting thing because in
this first issue we're not really told
exactly how superpowers work which is to
say how omn Man's powers work and how
Mark's Powers work the implication
because of the fact that they're popping
up when he's 17 years old the
implication is that they're inherited
but it's a it's a pretty cool thing now
if you guys any of you guys who have
read invincible and you know how all
this stuff works out with like omn man
and and Mark and all that kind of stuff
no spoilers please for the love of God
don't spoil anything but the the the
cool little tidbit is that Mark is
initially told off panel by his dad that
his powers are basically the result of a
reaction now what this reaction is you
know the it's not really done by Kirkman
in the sense of like X-Men where it's
like a reaction to like a high level of
stress or adrenaline or something like
that or like a pubescent Coming of Age
situation and so it's a little murky
when it gets to that but the truth about
this is that you know if he if he has
basically inherited his dad's Powers
then that means he has everything that
his dad has and so what he ends up doing
is basically jumping off the ground and
as a result of this he basically learns
that he can fly and so you get these
cool little moments right because you
jump forward by about two weeks there's
a couple of guys who engaged in this
Heist uh from the from from a a local
Diamond Place basically one of these
guys of course has powers and then as
they go through and as they're trying to
make their escape that you end up having
Mark show up and just Pummel these guys
right just start puming these guys and
then essentially knock them out and
leave them for the cops right now this
is a very important moment here because
what it reveals is that Mark and his dad
are not the only people out there with
powers right now there is like the
Justice Globe right what is basically
the Justice you know the the Justice
League of this story so we haven't quite
seen them yet but there are other people
out there with powers and so it's a
little bit more expansive and so for
first issue it is as you guys can tell
pretty tightly confined right you know
pretty pretty small in terms of how it
compares to everything else but the cool
thing about this is that you have Mark
who's BAS Bally taken by his dad to a
tailor shop which is kind of like a
secret layer where these different suits
and and so on are developed and the
initial belief by you know this guy Who
develops a suit for for Mark and
initially developed one for his dad is
that he believed his dad's Powers were
solar based and even his dad seems to
have seem to have thought that at some
point on the line the reality is that
they're not and so as a result of this
there's not really any need for these
energy discs that are attached to this
suit and so from that point it becomes a
pretty significant moment in this this
little bit of a story here and is one of
the things in superhero stories that you
don't really see that often and this is
one of the things that made Invincible
such a great story is because where you
have the the tailor talking directly to
Mark and saying hey so like you know
what do you what do you think about the
suit right give me your honest opinion
Mark's kind of like I mean it doesn't
really seem iconic right it just seems
like a general run-of-the-mill suit and
this isn't really said to be like a
slant you know like you're your your
design ability suck right I'm just going
to go find somebody on Fiverr who can
make a suit for me that's not really the
the point the idea is you know much like
getting a new pair of shoes right or
putting an outfit together or something
along those lines a superhero suit is a
significant thing because you're that
it's going to be your brand right it's
how you're identified you know the you
look at Superman for example you could
show that outfit to anybody you could
cut it off at the head right where you
never see Superman's face and and you
just show that outfit to anybody people
immediately know who it is the same
thing with Batman the same thing with
like Wonder Woman or if you look at like
the Iron Man suit or something along
those lines right unless you reveal to a
person the person inside the Iron Man
suit is not Iron Man they're going to
assume that it's Tony Stark Spider-Man
is the exact same way and so because of
the fact that the costume is part and
parcel to the heroes themselves it has
to be something that just pops you know
what I
mean like the Buddy Christ you know any
of you guys ever saw Dogma I don't know
if any of you guys ever saw Dogma but
like there's this amazing moment where
George Carlin is talking about how like
the Catholic church is viewed as like
old and archaic and behind the times and
so in order to make them look more
Progressive he came up with this idea
called Buddy Christ and so it's like
doesn't it just
pop it's literally Buddy Christ just
pointing to people he looks cool as hell
but uh but the cool thing here is that
of course you have Mark in school you
know and you know kind of switching over
to him in his class he's kind of left
with this bit of a homework assignment
for himself uh from this tailor which is
like create an identity for yourself and
once you create this identity then I can
tailor a suit around this idea of how
you identify yourself as a superhero and
so you know with the the teacher kind of
dismisses them of course he ends up
holding back Derek you know who's like
the the football star of The Jock and
then Mark kind of goes forward and does
his thing now this is when you get into
one of the Hallmark moments of comic
books and it's usually kind of a coming
of age thing for for you know younger
superhero stories Spider-Man had it and
it's one of these things you just sort
of see right the bully who's giving
everybody a tough time and the the young
kid who has newly realized Powers who
confronts the bully and so of course
this this guy is picking on this young
kid you know picking on this this this
young guy you know whose Locker is next
to Mark and Mark of course stands up the
way that you would expect him to like
hey man like back off right and this is
the moment that everybody loves right
the the cool moment where the bully
starts giving him crap because the bully
doesn't quite understand his place in
the bigger picture and so Mark helps him
to understand his place in the bigger
picture right you know that he's just
not as he's not as important as he
thinks he is right that he's not that
special Mark basically shoves him into
the lockers right I mean he doesn't like
Pummel him to death you know or like
Mark beats him to death and then becomes
a villain you know it'd be it'd be funny
if that
happened but that's not really what
happens here instead it's just you know
him shoving this guy into a locker and
then ultimately he sent to the
principal's office right now one of the
cool things is that Mark's kind of given
a bit of a pass here by the principal
not in so far as saying hey man like
that guy definitely had to come and you
know good on on you hint hint nudge
nudge you know more of that around here
and and you'll be going places instead
he takes the standard administrative
approach which is don't stand up for
yourself or other people in that way go
and get a teacher or go and get a
security guard right now we as as people
who live in the real world we know this
doesn't work right that like you know if
you rely on other people to fix your
problems then you're never going to be
able to develop the wherewithal to be
able to solve problems on your own right
so we know this kind of isolated
standard of of teaching kids problem
solving skills doesn't really work
because you're not actually teaching
them problem solving skills and so you
know it kind of gives him the the
standard explanation hey look you know
like you're a good kid I don't want you
to go down the same path as as that guy
you know keep your nose in the books you
know that kind of a thing and makes this
off-handed remark that like you know
it's not your responsibility to protect
all the other kids around here you're
not Invincible that's when the name
kicks in right that's that's when he's
like that's the name right that's the
name like that's the one that I have to
go with and so you end up having this
this you know this robbery that goes on
at a at a savings and loan and of course
these guys making off with a whole bunch
of money and and and taking off and as
soon as they turn a corner there's
Invincible right with their getaway car
lifted into the air and it's just and
and literally just kind of like throws
it and just says like if you guys are
looking for this then that's fine and
when one of the guys like pulls a gun on
him he's like you know I wouldn't try
that I'm Invincible right so like fully
coming into his own as a super hero it's
it's a really really really good first
issue and it only gets better from here
I mean like any kind of a story it's got
its LS you know it's it's slow moments
where it's you know a bit of a of a
dredge to try to get through you know
but it was like that with The Walking
Dead you know where it's just kind of
like all right you know
I whatever I'll read it because I'll
probably need to understand what's going
on later on but like you know Kirkman
you's let's beef it up a little
bit you guys know what I'm talking about
right like no comic book run is 100%
perfect the only exception to that is
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and New
Avengers all right what's going on
patrons this is Rob and we are
continuing part two of invincible uh God
this series is really really good okay
so this starts the really kind of gives
us this origin of omn man right this
origin of omn man and it's depicted here
and it's kind of this this opening
segment that's told to to his son when
he's really really young but omn man
basically says that like you know at at
kind of revealing his origin story here
he says he's basically from a planet
that's called VTR and the idea was that
vilum had kind of achieved this perfect
Utopia right there was no illness there
was no war no famine no nothing and so
the initial idea was to kind of keep
themselves contained in their world and
almost to kind of cut themselves off
from the rest of the universe but
ultimately it was decided that that was
a poor idea that because they had
achieved such a high level of
Enlightenment that they wanted to
basically spread that throughout the
rest of the universe to kind of come
across these worlds where they were
Advanced enough that the members of the
vam Community could actually help them
achieve a Utopia in and of themselves
because their future was not really
guaranteed right and so the results of
this is that what ended up happening is
the high Council had approved this idea
where was called the world betterment
community that would essentially send
individuals out into the universe for
the purpose of visiting these various
worlds and then helping them to achieve
higher states of Enlightenment and so
ultimately omn man was one of these
individuals who emerged and was old
enough to join it you know a few years
after it was created and had essentially
become interested in earth right after
observing Earth and looking at its
history and all that kind of stuff he
became wildly intrigued by the nature of
humanity the things that we've done the
things that we could do what our
potential is and ultimately wanted to
join the the problem with this is that
the better Community had determined that
the Earth was simply just too primitive
right too primitive to crude that we as
humans were too far of a Waring
community and that there was no real
interest in trying to make humans better
and so ultimately omn man basically
volunteered to go here on his own right
to go here by himself to visit the world
and then to potentially even become its
protector to kind of help move Humanity
into a higher stage and then potentially
at some future point in time the vilum
community would reconsider their offer
and then possibly you know kind of
fullon allow Earth to become part of the
uh of the the betterman community and so
ultimately he's basically told that if
he goes to Earth because it's so far and
so remote that there may may be no
chance of him coming back but he accepts
the mission anyway way and so when he
arrives here that his his work is
basically cut out for him right by by
virtue of the various threats that the
Earth faces and even you know with
earthlings themselves right the fact
that you know Humanity Wars and
conflicts consistently that it would be
a tough job to kind of lead Humanity
into becoming better when his son's
exceedingly young he tells him this
story because he's like a time will come
when you will develop Powers right you
will develop super abilities and when
that time comes it'll be my job to train
you and to teach you on how to use your
powers and to go forward accordingly and
so picking up in the modern day
Invincible is just kind of like you know
like I can fly man and so like he's kind
of laying in bed trying to figure out
what to do and he does what any of us
would do he just takes off and just like
I'm going to go fly I'm just going to go
do stuff with my powers and then comes
across a guy who's basically stealing
boxes of toys now on the surface it
seems pretty childish right facing off
against a guy who's stealing toys
there's a little more to this than that
but initial fight kind of breaks out
between the two and then while the two
of them are fighting suddenly there's a
bit of an explosion between them and
what we're met is by a guy named rode
who's very similar to Gambit in terms of
his ability ities right he's like you
know like I did that with a BB right
imagine what I can do with a golf ball
right I can take down this this whole
building imagine what he could do with
like a beach ball right he could take
down the whole city block but they're
basically called the teen team right
they are by all standards of measurement
like the Teen Titans kind of for for the
Invincible line of comics but what you
have here are individuals like robot Rex
Spode Adam Eve and duplicate and they've
all got their own individual Powers here
now of course this guy mer is basically
taken you know he's he's busted and
that's it you know his his scheme is
more or less over what Invincible finds
out is that Adam Eve is actually one of
the girls from his school like they go
to school together and he's kind of okay
so like please don't tell
anybody that I have powers I won't tell
anybody you have powers uh and it's one
of these things where the teenage
superhero community at least as is given
to us as the the teen team seems pretty
well organized and pretty well
structured and I dig that right I dig
the idea that like they're they kind of
have their thing together right and so
ultimately you know Invincible is kind
of taken to the base where the teen team
uh operates and robot basically reveals
that what he had done is he had
essentially wiped the mind of Mer of
that night's events and he'll just kind
of wake up outside that toy store he'll
be kind of confused and the hope is that
in his confusion he'll lead them to his
base of operations which is exactly what
he does right and we end up finding out
that like their leader right this guy
that's creating these robots is
intending to do so for some nefarious
purposes and the reason why they were
stealing these Video Game Machines is
because inside those are microchips that
this guy needs a little processors in
order to help him kind of activate his
robot army and then do whatever it is
that he intends on doing here now of
course the teen team busts in to the
whole place and it's just kind of like
we've heard enough right and literally
the fight is on right and and and
initially the the guys kind of show you
know these henchmen show to be a little
much for the teen team but not for
invincible right he's able to like take
these guys out right able to just
absolutely Pummel these guys and things
are over pretty quickly and so he has
this conversation with them right has
this bit of a conversation here and
they're like man like that ended pretty
fast and he's like yeah man like I mean
is it always this easy right because
they extend him an invitation to join
the group and he's like I mean is it
always this easy I mean I have to think
about it right cuz I got school and I've
got you know a home life and things like
that one thing to know they're not aware
of the fact that he's the son of omn man
and that's something to keep in the back
of your head right that's something to
to keep in mind there but they're kind
of like I mean you know like do you want
to join he's like I'll consider it you
know so it's our our first real chance
at seeing him become part of something
bigger the problem with all this and
actually a funny moment here you see
Charlie Brown there if you're uh if
you're if you're a little Keen with your
eyes some poor sap wakes up on a park
bench right and when he does like he's
just like where in the world am I only
to have a bomb stra to his chest with
one second left that thing goes off
blows up the entirety of twin Pine's
mall right the mall that has it all just
gets blown to
Smither hello patrons members of the Rob
Corp how are you guys doing today I am
doing good here's a crazy thing I just
recently started watching Invincible to
that show is amazing and dude I feel
like a majority of America's just
sleeping on that show dude it's it's so
good like nobody's really talking about
it and that's kind of disappointing
because I think so far it's better than
like Falcon and the Winter Soldier
don't tell anybody I told you guys that
but I feel like it is man like it's it's
really really really really good okay so
in the last video that we did uh we
basically ended it with like some poor
sap waking up on a park bench and a bomb
strapped to his chest so what we end up
doing is actually picking up before that
goes off right before that bomb goes off
and we essentially have the principal
kind of talking to the students and
really talking about how like a couple
of the kids from the high school are
basically missing right so quite off the
bat we know that like this guy who woke
up on the Park Bench is effectively one
of those and so from there it kind of
switches over to the conversation
between Mark or invincible and Eve we're
just going to call her Eve I think it's
just easier to to to call her that but
the funny thing is like they're they're
kind of talking back and forth and and
having this bit of a of a conversation
and initially it's you know one of the
kids that's missing is a guy named Todd
Jefferson right and he's just kind of
like well I mean you know it couldn't
happened to a nicer guy right I mean you
guy was kind of a dick and then she's
kind of like well I mean he was always
nice to me and it's like yeah imagine
that right a guy being like a guy who's
a jerk being nice to the hot girl in
school like who could possibly imagine a
situation like that you know how crazy
crazy is it but it's almost one of these
things where because of the conversation
that that's going on she almost kind of
takes the approach that like she feels
like he's kind of hitting on her and to
a degree he is right I mean he's not
really hitting on her but there's
definitely a romantic interest there and
she goes as far as to say like you know
I'm dating Rex right now if you guys are
current with the show well I mean you
know you guys know like
it's having said that I don't fault Rex
right I don't fault him one bit well
we'll talk we'll cross that bridge once
we get to it right the important thing
here is he's trying to maintain some
level of of friendliness here but let's
be honest with ourselves if you have
ever been a guy who's stuck in this
situation you kind of hang around for a
minute or two to see whether or not like
there's a chance you don't hang around
forever right that's just that's just
being a loser right you don't hang
around you just move on to the next one
but uh it's kind of like I mean we'll
kind of see what's going on but what you
end up getting here is him going back
going to his job at the Burger Mark and
then getting a whole bunch of flack from
the manager who's there right now here's
the important thing to understand I want
to talk about this for a second I think
every young person should have a job
working in the fast food industry once
in their life right preferably sometime
when you're working in like high school
or something like that but I think it's
an important thing right because what
this does is it helps to build
resilience you will never develop more
of a hatred for Humanity than you will
working in the service
industry you will learn to hate people
but not only that it builds character
right because when you're the guy who's
who's flipping burgers or making fries
people you know seemingly don't take you
seriously when you're that young right
and so you just kind of end up going
with the flow and it it teaches you to
appreciate good management styles it
teaches you to appreciate what it means
to actually put in some hard work right
when you're burning yourself from the
fry grease and all that kind of stuff it
teaches you the value of those things
right I was a Fred cook for about a year
or two right I mean I've done that time
I've I've done that and that's not even
when I was in high school like I did
that as my first job out of high school
but the important thing is is ultimately
he's just kind of like you know what I'm
tired of getting a whole bunch of flack
from you right so you know what like you
could take this job and you can shove it
but the problem with this is that he
initially got that job at the request of
his dad from omn man in order to help
him build character right to to build
resolve and understand you got to work
for the things that you get in this life
and so what you end up getting is dinner
time right the guy gets back home Mark
gets back home and he's like okay I got
to find out a way to tell my dad that I
basically quit my job which if you're if
you've ever been in that boat right you
ever been in high school you had a job
your parents made you get a job the last
thing you want to do is go home and quit
unless you have a really good reason
right you know your boss is cussing you
out or something like that you know
initially the topic changes super fast
right because they're they're doing the
dishes kind of put you know getting
everything cleaned up and he's like so
how was work today he's like it's fine
do you want to wash or do you want to
Rin and so the funny thing is omn man
kind of chimes in and says you know what
like I don't even you with you being a
superhero now having power is like you
should just kind of be a superhero
full-time you don't really need this job
anymore right so just kind of stay with
school and then go do superhero stuff so
you know I don't really think it's a
huge issue if you quit your job and it's
like perfect
timing perfect timing absolutely perfect
timing right and so from there you end
up getting uh Mark and his dad who go
out on a bit of a superhero adventure
now this is one of the big changes from
the TV show right if I remember
correctly on the TV show and I could be
wrong here that the first real outing
the two of them have he basically
basally goes with him and then like
punches him in the gut right it's just
kind of like bam you know like and and
basically teaches him how to take a hit
there's a reason for that and and well
there's a there's a lot more to omn
man's story than you think if all you're
watching is a TV show and you've never
read the comics while the two of them
are talking of course omn man doing his
things kind of whisking down saving
stuff and then jumping back and and kind
of going back and forth and back and
forth but one of the things is
established very early on here is that
despite having the same Powers as his
dad his powers are not on the same level
as his dad and so the implication here
from omn man is that the longer Mark is
alive the more his powers will begin to
expand and they'll begin to grow now
we're not given an indication here in
the outset if there's like an upper
limit right or if his powers will just
grow indefinitely the longer that he's
alive right we we do get an answer to
that but in the moment we're not
definitively getting one and so instead
what ends up happening is is omn man
basically get gets a beep right because
you know he's he's got a beeper 2003 is
at you and uh ultimately he ends up
racing off to this Alien Invasion now
this is another big moment the a big
differentiation between the TV TV show
and the comic book in the TV show if you
guys are watching that what basically
went down there is these aliens and
Alien Invaders showed up essentially in
downtown right and it was like it was
the forces of of Mark and those guys who
were showing up and facing off against
them time and time again right like they
showed up and then like they were
basically fought off then they ran into
their portals and disappeared and they
did it like two or three more times this
is one of the things to understand and
we saw the same thing play out with
kirkman's The Walking Dead is that
because we're dealing with essentially a
finite level of comics that what Amazon
wants to do is not necessarily drag it
out to the point that it's detrimental
to the show but basically not really
wrap things up in an instant right
because the truth about about you know
Invincible is if they fell in line with
the comic like literally just a
page-for-page remake they would run
through the whole series in one season
but it would just be that it'd be that
fast right I mean maybe two or three
seasons because technically there's 25
volumes but like we've seen them roll
through in the first three episodes
they' passed through the first story arc
like that right I mean it's it's it's
amazing how like i' say in the first
episode or two they blew through the
first story arc right and like they're
already into the second and the third
story arc and so it's just kind of like
okay they're going to have to definitely
find some way to kind of expand things
and beef things up a little bit so
because of that in the comic what ends
up happening is that as omn man and as
Mark and it's really just them as
they're facing off against these Alien
Invaders that you end up having this
realization from Mark that like they're
suddenly aging up super fast and that's
when the hypothesis is put out there
that they're from a dimension where
basically time just simply Works
differently right that like you know
time passes differently in their
mentioned and so when they're here they
age up a whole lot faster right time
seems to pass slower over there and so
what you end up getting here is them
basically retreating into their portal
just like you saw in the show the
difference here is that you end up
having omn man who looks and says okay
they're retreating back through that
portal and he basically ends up just
kind of racing off they Retreat back
into the portal and then like the portal
closes up and basically it's done right
it's like okay cool like these guys are
are effectively defeated but as the two
of them are essentially taking back off
again and continuing to go and and
basically Patrol you know they're super
superhero Antics that omn man
essentially takes off to to Lakeside
Mall and that's when we pick up in that
moment where this guy essentially wakes
up with a bomb strap to his chest and
omn man's just like who did this to you
right tell me as fast as you can who did
this to you and this kid's like like
what like did what and and that's when
you kind of realize this kid has no idea
like he he literally woke up Suddenly a
bomb was there he has no idea what it is
doesn't even have time to respond omn
man does the only thing he can do just
takes him and throws him out right and
the kid just explodes right he's
ultimately killed because there's no way
to really save that kid right there's no
conceivable way to like diffuse that
bomb and and save this kid's life in the
span of 3 seconds right it's just it's
not humanly possible and even for omn
man it's really not possible the big
difference here comes between the TV
show and the and the the comics when you
have omn man talking directly to Mark
when Mark says like that's one of the
kids from my school and omn man's like
well I mean that would mean and then
suddenly the portal opens and he gets
snatched through right that's how he
ends up in the other world where the
aliens are Mark ends up going back home
telling his mom hey look uh so dad was
taken by aliens and she's like like okay
well I guess it just means more pork
chops for us right I mean it's just
business as usual when it comes to omn
man and I guess when you're the wife of
a of a character like him you kind of
see stuff like that happen
regularly you know that kind of stuff
happens and and he usually always ends
up coming back right the cool thing
about this this is something that I want
you guys to keep in mind omn man has an
amazing story it's so good uh I'm
excited to get to like the big reveal
for omn man it's it's
mind-blowing what's going on guys this
is Rob and we are back and we are
settled or getting settled into our
place here in Colorado still unpacking a
few things but we are back on our normal
schedule with our videos regarding
invincible so I apologize for the delay
but uh you know can't really record
audio when I'm driving across the
country so uh in the last video that we
did here we basically had these kids who
were going missing at Invincible school
and then ultimately we're reappearing
with bomb strapped to their chest right
and so kind of the big mystery that was
going on here is who in the world is
doing that while all that happened you
had a kind of extradimensional Alien
Invasion that was taking place and then
omn man basically chased after those
guys and then disappeared right and so
at the moment we're largely just
focusing on invincible and what's going
on here now of course he ends up
traveling to meet with robot who's part
of like the kind of invincible Universe
style Teen Titans type guy kind of like
their own little version of Cyborg and
essentially he's kind of like okay so I
have no idea what's happening here all I
know is that like kids are missing and
like they're reappearing as bombs and I
I don't I don't know what to do now
ultimately he was basically trying to
get a hold of Eve and of course when he
hits like robot robot's like hey you
know she's with like she's da Rex right
and he's like yeah man like every time
he ask anybody where Eve is that's the
response they give and he's like hey I
don't know if you know this man but it's
it's okay for like a guy and a chick to
just be friends right doesn't
necessarily mean I'm trying to bang her
I mean he is you know I mean come on you
know that's exactly what's trying to
what what he's trying to do you know
he's trying to get her between the
sheets but at the moment he's kind of
pting it off right they you know they're
they're just friends which they kind of
are now ultimately Eve shows up with Rex
and one of the things that's kind of
given to us here and something that you
probably figured out from watching the
show already is that Rex is kind of a
borderline narcissist right he's just
kind of really cares about himself
doesn't really seem to care about much
else and so you have this thing where
when he shows up with Eve and and
Invincible is kind of like I think the
kids that are going missing in our
school um are the ones who are basically
being turned into bombs Rex's like man
that's awful okay I'll catch you guys
later and then leaves right as opposed
to sharing or or showing any real
measure of concern to what's actually
happening and so ultimately you end up
kind of picking up the next day and
there's this kind of idea between Eve
and Invincible which is to at the very
least keep their ears out now I love the
way that Kirkman does this because he
doesn't really treat Invincible Comics
the way that Marvel or DC treats their
characters which is you know Batman is
kind of walking down the street and he
finds a stick and when he finds that
stick he realizes it comes from a tree
and that tree belongs to a place that's
near a guy's house and he's like oh my
God it's that guy right it's just not
like you know uh just kind of spur the
moment because the plot needs it to
happen kind of thing right it's one of
these things where like they're young
kids and they don't really know what
they're doing and they they're trying to
be heroes as best they can but they
don't have all the answers right we're
not dealing with like super smart people
they just have abilities right and
they're just trying to do good in the
world and so all they could really do is
keep their ear to the ground and just
kind of keep a lookout for things that
seem a little suspicious with regards to
the kids that are missing in their
school potentially other kids going
missing so I don't know somebody throws
one into a back of a into the back of a
a van with no windows and drives off I
mean something like that right I mean
that's kind of what they end up having
to look out for and so it's a little bit
of a a cool thing because when that
happens you kind of pick up with uh with
Invincible in class alongside Eve and
once they you know by the time they get
to this class they're kind of like I
mean we haven't really seen anything
suspicious like I don't really know what
in the world is going on here now this
cues their teacher who basically just
starts yelling at him right just
literally just starts screaming at him
and it's just kind of like look like you
know just because you know I allows you
to switch seats does not mean that you
can just kind of talk to your boyfriend
anytime you want to during your lectures
and hey Mark just because of the fact
that like you don't really leave a lot
of time to talk to your girl you spend
most of your time just making out with
her or whatever and you want to make up
for that time here doesn't mean it's
okay right it just immediately jumps off
kind of kind of snaps at him right now
it's not like he's freaking out and
throwing stuff at him right it's not
like like the the teacher Mr Crab I had
in Middle School who would call us
stupid it's not really anything like
that and I really did have a teacher who
would do that um in reality he's just
you know he kind of jumps to the idea
that they're they're kind of together
and they're dating right now Mark's like
look she's not my girlfriend he's like
okay look I kind of apologized there I
was a little carried away but like don't
do it again right that kind of a thing
right and so this kind of leads to Mark
sort of walking with Eve and just kind
of musing over what's happening it's
like yeah man it's kind of weird now by
all standards of measurement they look
like they're dating right they look like
they're together and so ultim you have
Eve Who's contacted by robot who had
basically kind of been running
background checks right and comes to
this realization that their teacher had
essentially worked for a worked as a
weapons developer right and it's kind of
like okay like there's no real evidence
to link this guy to what's going on but
if anybody in your school has the
wherewithal to basically turn people
into bombs or strap bombs to their chest
then it's that guy right so like you
should at the very least go look into it
or investigate it and just kind of see
you know what kind of conclusion you can
come to and so ultimately they do right
they kind of end up you know showing up
at this guy's house and when they get
there he's like you know I never really
expected to get caught this early right
just right off the bat it's just like
yep I'm the one who did it right I'm I'm
the one who's been doing this and that's
what's kind of the crazy thing is
because when he explains his rationale
it's kind of cliche but it's kind of not
right and it's almost a little relatable
to a degree right so what this guy
basically reveals is that it's not as
though he just hates kids or anything
along those lines that in essence uh you
know the kids that they kind of seem to
represent right the kids that that just
kind of goof off they do you know drink
alcohol and they go party all the time
and that kind of stuff right what you
would Define as like quote unquote the
cool kids as far as Hollywood depicts
them um that that those those kids
basically drove his son to kill himself
and so as a result of that his wife left
him he lost his job and essentially his
whole life came crumbling down all
because as he blames it those kits and
so in essence he's kind of gone on this
bit of a crusade to basically take out
those kits now why it is he's trapping
them to bombs and that kind of stuff
really only makes sense to him but at
the end of the day like that's his
motivation and he's like what better way
to make an example and to get Society to
realize that like those kids like those
types of kids are a problem then to
basically kill a couple of superheroes
right to get the world to know what it
is that I've done here the reason why
I've done here and to get the world to
listen right to get the world to to pay
attention and so of course the
Invincible kind of sees this and is like
no that's not going to happen that's not
going to take place you know it's it's
kind of nuts right and so of course Marx
just like like grabs him and just flies
him into the air and really ends him the
same way as dad did which was grabbing
him and then just throwing him right and
just allowing the bomb to to explode now
that's a very important point mark
handling things the same way he sees his
dad handle things that's exceedingly
important and that's something that you
need to keep in mind right because it'll
become very very very important later on
down the line but at the end of the day
this is more or less solved right and so
he goes back to meet with Eve and uh
ultimately she's like you know Robots
coming to do a sweep and to make sure
everything's all clear and we're going
to kind of call it a day right so the
The Situation's been resolved quite
readily right so Mark comes back and
it's just you know he's like is Dad back
yet and she's like no not yet go
upstairs you know get yourself cleaned
up so we can eat you know uh you know I
have I have dinner you know for us and
then like omn man just appears out of
nowhere he like I need to shave and then
just leaves and his wife's like thank
God that's one of the things I love
about this is that like you know you do
have these moments like like like this
moment right here where you know omn
man's wife is and obviously you would
expect her to be legitimately concerned
but you see her Express Express emotion
in this way and it's not meant to say
that she's an emotionless person but it
is meant to highlight the idea that like
the various escapades that omn man gets
up to where like he almost dies or gets
the crap beat out of him or or some
crazy superhero antic that his business
is usual but the fact that like he
disappears and she doesn't know where he
is and doesn't know what's happening to
him while she does have hope that he'll
come back it's just it's good to see
that it's like thank God my husband
returned right it's a great concept it's
a great idea so she kind of she's kind
of okay so like did anything interesting
happen to either of you guys today and
Mark's like yeah um so it turned out
that my uh physics teacher was basically
turning kids in school into organic
bombs and then blowing them up in order
to get revenge on the kids that he felt
were the ones that drove his son to
commit suicide and his dad's like uh
well I mean I spent 8 months enslaved in
an other dimensional prison and I helped
to lead a Revolt got my power back and
the science team finally managed to find
a way to get me back here so uh yeah
that's kind of what we've been doing and
she's like who's ready for
dessert I love how it's just she's
everybody just so Cavalier about the
kind of things that happen right because
it makes sense right like when you have
a family of superheroes it's like y this
is the kind of stuff that happens when
you're a
superhero all right what's going on guys
this is Rob and uh I'm a little late to
the party here but it's been a super
busy day today uh but we are picking up
with more of invincible right now this
part that we pick up with here is a part
that already aired with regards to the
TV show um but we basically end up kind
of joining with Mark when he gets a call
from his dad right when Nolan calls him
up and says hey man you know I got to go
do a thing with the the Guardians of the
globe but there's going to be an alien
showing up here he's a pretty bad guy
make sure you deal with him and so Mark
ultimately ends up taking off in his
space now the funny thing is this is the
first time we learn that Nolan can
actually hold his breath for like two
weeks Mark could hold his breath for
like an hour or something along those
lines once uh Mark gets to space then
suddenly he's met by the arrival of
Allen the alien now here's the cool
thing Allen the alien alen is probably
one of the most important characters of
invincible uh but initially you don't
get that instead he's just kind of here
and there's a bit of a fight that breaks
out between the two of them now Allan
also uses telepathy which is how he and
Mark are able to communicate with each
other and for the most part Allan
demonstrates a pretty good amount of
proficiency in fighting right in
hand-to-hand combat certainly more so
than mark because Mark's still pretty
much brand new to the whole thing but
ultimately Mark takes him into the moon
right just like crashes them into the
moon and then they kind of start talking
things out and that's when Allan reveals
that he's part of a group called The
Coalition of plan right and the whole
idea behind this is basically when these
individuals are sent off into space for
the purpose of like safeguarding planets
that the Coalition sends what is
basically somebody like Allan to kind of
test them to see how capable they are in
terms of protecting various worlds so
he's he's what's called a champion
evaluation officer uh now the funny
thing about this is that he is actually
at the wrong
planet that that in essence uh he
basically says that he's here to visit a
planet called urath and in reality he's
actually at Earth now the crazy thing is
he's kind of like okay definitely the
wrong
world and that he kind of go they kind
of go through like these 50-year
rotations more or less and that he's up
for like a new rotation or an really an
evaluation in like 20 years and he's
been basically coming to the wrong world
for the last 15 years right so it's kind
of nuts he's basically been doing
terrible at his job and then ultimately
kind of takes off right once he realizes
that he's basically in the wrong place
and he and Mark more or less I wouldn't
say become friends but they're they have
kind of a familiar relationship right
where it's kind of like okay cool you're
a cool guy well you're a cool guy too
awesome you know let's kind of call it a
day from there when Mark gets back he
kind of tells his dad about you know
everything that had gone on and the fact
that this guy Allen the alien had been
showing up to the wrong planet for the
last 15 years and initially Nolan kind
of takes it in a funny way and then he's
like okay well I'm pretty impressed you
were able to handle it that way you know
that kind of a thing and so you know of
course Mark has homework and stuff to
take care of but from there things
actually get particularly interesting
here and the reason why is because
William of course as most of you guys
know a friend of Mark is coming to see
Mark the next day because they're
actually going to uh to Upstate
University to kind of check out you know
the college campus right where they're
where he's going to be going to school
at and so the funny thing is that while
they're doing that basically Nolan and
and and his wife are kind of like all
right I mean you know time to touch
naughty bits right it's just you know
kind of you know it's it's time to do
the damn thing because the kid's gone
while that's going on robot basically
calls together the remainder or really
the the other members of team team and
kind of says look I've been you know
kind of moved up to the the Guardians of
the globe right I've been like you know
promoted to their ranks but I'm also
disbanding this team because I cannot
efficiently be a part of both right and
so it's really kind of a last goodbye to
robot where they're kind of like cool
you know go on ahead and and do your
thing and and sort of call it a day and
then you also have a guy by the name of
Sanford now Sanford is a guy who had
powers at one point in time and by
whatever Manner and whatever means which
we won't reveal here basically lost them
and the result was that he was
essentially kicked off the guardian's
team right because he didn't have any
powers they didn't really have any use
for him and they're basically he's
basically waiting on like a replacement
suit right from the tailor a guy who can
kind of give him a new suit that'll
essentially give him his powers back or
at least some measure of powers and he
can regain his rightful place on the
Guardians right so that's where it's
kind of given to us that robot is
essentially taking the place of Sanford
on the team it's more or less what's
happening and it's going to be 2 days
until it happens which is really more
than just Sanford seems to be able to
wait now at this point he seems to be
seems to have been out of the team for a
little while so what's two days right in
comparison to all that and so kind of
jumping on with Mark and William William
kind of pisses a few people off just
because of the fact that you know
because his name is William Bill is a
sham name for that and a few people are
like hey man like do you prefer Bill and
that's one of those social social
etiquette things where it's a person
saying like can I call you Bill but not
really saying that and it's like it's
actually William right and it just seems
to kind of rub people the wrong way I
don't know why this is why I don't
really care about social norms right
they're they're really more annoying
than anything else it's not that I don't
understand them it's just that I I find
social norms to be a nuisance so more
often than not I usually just ignore
them and just kind of do my own thing it
does kind of rub people the wrong way
but at the end of the day I don't really
care uh you know they'll be fine they'll
get over it and it's one of the kind of
discussions that goes on and even
William kind of puts that idea forward
like man you know here's the thing he's
like you know it's kind of irritating
he's like you know if I tell them sure
you can call me Bill then they don't
call me by the name that I prefer preer
but if I say I prefer William then they
see me as kind of like rude or snoody
because I'm William instead of Bill you
know so he's like it's lose lose I'm
like you know what William who cares man
it doesn't really matter all that much
and they kind of run into this issue a
couple of different times but then
something amazing happens right it's one
of the funniest things ever so you
basically end up having this really like
a villain more or less that seemingly
shows up out of nowhere and then goes to
attack Mark while he's with William
right and the reality is he's actually
heading in a direction it's just
everybody else there is more or less
collateral damage but Mark's like oh my
god oh man like what was that you know
and he's like William get out of the way
and then Mark takes off changes into his
costume come comes back and then
basically destroys the robot and then
just kind of like disappears and returns
as Mark and he's like William man are
you okay you know I can't believe that
happened and William's like dude why
didn't you tell me you had
superpowers right off the bat William
figures out that Mark is Invincible
right and honestly it kind of makes
sense and I love that Robert Kirkman did
this because only an idiot would fall
for like the Superman thing you know
where like somebody's attacking the city
and and and Clark's like oh man I forgot
something in the office you know and
then he goes and you know changes into a
Superman costume or like takes off a
shirt and the Superman underneath and
then he defeats the villain then he
comes back and nobody's any the wiser
like man Clark you missed the whole
thing you know it's things like that
that never made any sense to me it's one
of the things we always kind of poke at
and it's kind of funny right when you're
when you're reading it but uh but
nonetheless you know it's a it's a
little weird there of course we also get
a little bit of a visit between Mark and
Nolan showing up to meet the Taylor only
for the Taylor to basically reveal that
he had been in the process of developing
a suit for Sanford that would basically
give him his powers back but the suit
has essentially been stolen now the
implication as it's given here by the
tailor is that it looks like a Sanford
he doesn't say that it is he's just kind
of like uh man it's a little weird right
like you know this guy was supposed to
get his powers back in a couple days he
indicated he couldn't wait suddenly the
suit goes missing right like he's the
only person that really knew that I was
working on the suit form that kind of a
thing and so that's that's you know it
kind of points to it kind of really
points to the idea that that he was the
reason why it happened right that the
sford was the reason why this this all
kind of went down and so from there what
we end up doing here is basically
picking up with with something pretty
interesting but it's it's really
something that you've already seen
before you do get kind of like the the
you know who are the guardians of the
globe the reality is the Guardians of
the globe are basically the Justice
League so there's really not anything
here of any significance that you didn't
probably catch in the TV show but
basically the Guardians have all kind of
been called together and then they're
all basically killed by nullen now
something that I do want to point out
here is the quickness in which they died
here was much faster than it was in the
show in the show the Guardians put up a
fight and the comic it happened like
within the span of seconds right and
that was really designed I imagine by
Kirkman to really show us just how
powerful Nolan is and you know in
relation to everybody else that like
none of them really have a chance on him
he's just that damn powerful but it's
also kind of this Revelation that
Nolan's a bad guy right like Nolan
killed the entire Guardians of the globe
and so it's kind of like okay like now
here's the crazy thing as nuts as this
Revelation is it only gets crazier right
like the the story of Nolan only gets
more and more insane but it's one of
these things where like as soon as this
dropped I remember reading this as soon
as this dropped it was mindblowing it
was like holy cow now of course
following that Nolan of course doesn't
doesn't tell anybody he killed the
Guardians of the globe and he kind of
lets everybody go on the operation that
like man the the Guardians have been
taken out by somebody and and it's kind
of nuts he sort of plays into it and
he's like you know I'm still kind of in
shock you know by by knowing that
happened that's absolutely Bonkers you
know and again it's a little bit of
detective work going on trying to figure
out how the Guardians die but one of the
things that I want you guys to notice
here is nobody suspects Nolan right and
that's something that we're going to
find later on but you end up picking up
with Mark when he gets back home and
finds Eve in his bedroom and I mean
she's crying right so obviously the
circumstances could be much much better
and that's when you basically finding
out that Rex had cheated on Eve as soon
as as Mark's mom shows up in the bedroom
and realizes Eve's there you know e like
is basically laying her head in Mark's
lap so like from behind it looks like
the worst case scenario right it looks
it looks like looks like Mark's getting
some Dome and so she calls him
downstairs and really kind of starts
reading the riot act and it's like look
you don't understand right like we're
not banging like we're not we're not
touching naughty boots but at the end of
the day like you know it's just one of
these things where I'm kind of helping
her get through a situation right that
kind of a thing now of course Nolan also
reveals the Guardians of the globe are
dead which is kind of a crazy thing
thing and that's what's also sort of
nuts is that it's really Eve in a lot of
ways kind of figuring out that like Mark
is the son of of omn man right which is
a pretty big deal right that's that's a
that's a huge thing to go down but
ultimately you kind of have Marin and
Nolan who are going to the funeral for
the Guardians and and again like one of
the things that you notice here you
actually don't see it in the TV show
you've got Savage dragon this is one of
those few instances when characters from
Image Comics will cross over with each
other doesn't happen very often but you
do get Savage dragon which is kind of
cool but again this is one of those
instances where like Nolan gets up there
and starts making a speech and then you
have the mer twins who show up now the
mer twins again are like these Evil
Geniuses one of them's a clone the
other's the original and and for the
most part they're always usually up to
some nefarious purposes but it's one of
these things where they kind of seem to
show up here for like literally offering
their genuine respect to a great team
right to a to a powerful team and so
ultimately no one again no one here
suspects Nolan like no one here looks at
Nolan is like dude I I bet Nolan did it
right I bet Nolan was the guy who killed
the Guardians of the globe nobody says
that right because Nolan is is
considered such a prodigious character
the sort of ambiance he puts off right
the kind of personality he puts off is
beyond reproach he's so respected nobody
thinks it would be him right so it's
like the perfect guys and so ultimately
like the whole funerals like literally
interrupted like somebody somebody
literally hits a funeral right it's it's
nuts like they hit a funeral and it
turns out to be like the butler to
Sanford right that's the crazy thing is
like the butler kind of went nuts and
was pissed off because of what happened
to Sanford right and so when that when
that whole thing goes down like
literally everybody moves right
everybody starts getting into getting
into action uh going after the butler
which for the most part they're able to
kind of take this guy out right like
Omni man just takes him out with a
swiftness and that's essentially it and
then from there it's kind of like okay
like the whole crowd kind of disperses
and that's that's it right there's there
not a whole lot going on there and so
from there you get a couple things that
happen one of them is pretty cool right
like William shows up to Mark's house
and it's like hey man look um so I know
you have powers and I know this seems
kind of weird but like can you fly me
into the
sky and so Mark flies his friend around
for a little while which is pretty
awesome and then the the kind of
conclusion here right the kind of finale
is again like you end up having one of
these guys who is basically you know
kind of converted into a bomb by David
Hiles right you guys remember him from
the last story that we did where he was
essentially a villain right he was a guy
who was turning kids into bombs and then
detonating him one of these kids of
course survived the whole experience but
the bomb stays attached to him right I
mean it's more or less neutralized but
like he has to have those components as
part of his body in order to survive and
he literally starts to take like he just
unzips his pants and just pisses on the
guy's grave but then you have a couple
kids who also show up here to basically
you know dig up or or to really kind of
well really dig up the graves of these
guys and part of this is is just
nonsense right like supposedly
if you drink from the immortal skull
you'll live forever right Immortal being
one of the members of the the Guardians
of the globe it's kind of nuts like you
know they they read about it on the
Internet it's a complete dick move right
to like go to go to the grave of
superheroes and like dig their graves up
but as they kind of get further down and
as they ultimately hit to where the
graves are suddenly they're met with the
arrival of the mer twins what's going on
guys this is Rob and I know we're a
little bit late here but we are covering
Invincible yet again you know I do have
a question for you guys do you guys care
if we put this on the main YouTube
channel I feel feel like most of you
guys won't but at the same time I kind
of also don't want to or if I do I'll do
it differently cuz I kind of like the
idea of having content that's on patreon
and just nowhere else right like nobody
else can find it anywhere on YouTube
right I kind of like the idea of you
guys having that exclusive stuff so let
me know I'm just kind of curious but uh
we are covering the the next little
installment here right so initially we
pick up with these handful of guys out
in space who are basically losing
control of their ship and it's careening
into the sun right and they're basically
about to crash into a star die
fortunately for them Allan the alien
basically steps in and helps these guys
right basically gets these guys back to
safety now the reality is he's a little
bit late here and he actually starts
talking about how he has to head back to
Earth which is kind of interesting
because as we know the conversation he
had with Mark previously was that he was
actually at the wrong planet now that's
one of these instances when I tell you
there's a lot more to the character of
Allen the alien than you initially think
right there's a whole lot happening
there but following that we kind of jump
forward to to Markin them when they
basically had a movie night which is
kind of cool and they were watching a
whole bunch of zombie movies and
different things like that and basically
it's a moment for Mark and his dad to
kind of sit down and watch Day of the
Dead now if I'm an honest man here if
I'm an honest man I never thought Day of
the Dead was very good technically it's
a Trilogy Right Night of the Living Dead
uh Dawn of the Dead and then Day of the
Dead but I never I never liked Day of
the Dead I always thought it was kind of
overrated I mean it was interesting but
the Dawn of the Dead remake by by what
was it Zack Snider I think he did that
or maybe it was James gun one of those I
think James gun did the screenplay for
it that movie was great right that movie
was really really good but it's a little
of a of a kind of comforting thing for
Mark's mom to sort of watch her husband
and her son just kind of sitting down
and enjoying movie night because it's a
bit of normaly I mean one of the crazy
things when your husband is like the
Superman of your world and your son's
not far behind him it's kind of cool to
see them just sort of sitting down and
just kind of watching a movie together
and so from there you switch over to
Cecil now Cecil of course kind of being
the the government liaison more or less
to the superhero Community having a
conversation with with robot and one of
the big talking points here is that the
intention was to have robot join the
guardians of the Globe but now that
they're all dead there's no team for for
robot to join so instead it's one of
these things where it's kind of like we
basically want you to launch a new team
right like we want you to to kind of
create a new team you know that can be
as effective if not more effective than
the Guardians of the globe were and
that's kind of the crazy thing because
you ultimately end up having Donald
who's basically going to be the the kind
of contact point between the the
Guardians of the globe and the US
Pentagon but it's kind of cool to see
things sort of continuing on and and and
picking up as they previously did before
and so what you end up doing is you end
up kind of joining up with Eve and Mark
now here's a big thing about this right
the idea of Eve and Mark we all kind of
knew that there was sort of a romance
blossoming there right we all kind of
knew that was going to happen but the
funny thing about this is that it wasn't
one of those situations that Kirkman
kind of throws out fast and loose
largely because it's too easy and
Kirkman and know I don't care what
anybody says Kirkman this guy knows how
to write Comics it's just the way it is
right kirkman's an amazing writer and
the whole thing behind this is he kind
of does the Slow Burn here and so one of
the funny things that you get especially
when it comes to the to the the age of
high school where we were all just like
super Ang we all knew how we felt but we
were terrible at communicating it right
just like Teenage
struggles um you end up having this
situation where you have Mark who's kind
of talking to Eve and and they're
they're kind of doing their thing and
once everything settles back down where
they're kind of talking and they're
they're doing their thing and it's and
it's one of these things where they're
kind of being a little flirty with each
other right you know and ultimately they
kind of get into their costumes and go
to do some Patrol work right nothing too
spectacular there but then you have this
moment where like you pick up with them
and you've got like What's called the
lizard League that'll strike again right
that's what they say like the lizard
League will strike again I love the
lizard League I'm not even going to lie
these guys were
amazing but of course the lizard league
is is done in pretty well this is one of
the things that I love the most about
Invincible is because the way that this
is done here it's it's kind of given to
us in this circumstance where it's kind
of like business is usual like if you go
and you read Marvel Comics or you go and
you read DC Comics there's like a whole
leadin to this conflict with the lizard
league right you get like the origin of
the lizard league and then somehow they
made their way to Earth and then like
now they're here and they're facing off
against the superheroes and there's like
what the superheroes were doing at the
time and then how it all led into this I
like how kirkman's just like meanwhile
with Mark and Eve they're fighting the
lizard League I dig that right I I kind
of dig that because the idea of like
these extradimensional forces these
beings out there who were hugely
powerful that's just not really the main
thing right that's not really the main
talking point the big talking point is
what's going on with Mark and what's
going on with Eve and how you know the
kind of bigger story that's unraveling
there everything's just kind of back
around an unnecessary fluff and that's
kind of how you see it go down right
they're like you've got you got Eve and
you got Mark who were kind of you know
flirting a little bit and I'll be honest
man Eve is kind of digging him right Eve
is like hey Mark what's going on oh hi
Mark for any of you guys who ever saw
what was it the room uh you're tearing
me apart Lisa uh Tommy weo please tell
me you guys know about the room but uh
but it's kind of a funny thing because
you have robot who shows up out of
nowhere and it's like hey guys I know
you're having kind of like a little bit
of a flirtatious moment here but we're
holding auditions for our new Guardians
of the globe and I would love for you
guys to show up and Mark being as
clueless as he is is like yeah I mean
that's cool Eve do you want to go of
course Eve is kind of pissed now she's
mad because they were having a moment
and Eve was kind of like let's let's
kind of continue having this moment I'm
not going to tell you what I'm thinking
I'm going to just kind of hope you
understand as time goes on and then get
frustrated when you don't instead of
using my words like an adult and uh and
of course Mark doesn't really understand
why she's so mad right so from here you
kind of jump up to the to the formation
or kind of the auditions for the new
Guardians of the globe now one of the
big differences between the show and the
comic is that the auditions are nowhere
nearest drawn out and again this is
something that I've noticed when it
comes to comic book shows especially
shows based off an existing comic book
run that with Invincible this is this is
not an endless comic right it's a finite
run the one of the things like with with
The Walking Dead for example when
Kirkman was doing that the comic was
still ongoing at the time the show was
being made and so there was no
definitive statement on when the comic
was going to end and literally Kirkman
just showed up one day and was like
we're done and just ended the comic like
I don't know how many of you guys
remember that but like it just ended
right and it was like damn the show
should have ended a long time ago the
thing about this is that the the whole
audition period happened so fast right
you get the moment where like Rexx
basically calls out a Monster Girl
Monster Girl starts freaking out right
she just like turns into her monster
form and just like one shots wreck or
really hits him a couple times like
that's it right I mean it's like a
little bit of a skirmish and that's it
right it's not great big huge it's not
drawn out you don't really see many of
the battles with anybody else or really
any of the battles with anybody else
it's a super short thing this happens at
least it happened the way it did in the
show if we're being honest partly
because of the fact that you know they
wanted to add a little bit more
entertainment but two because they
wanted to draw things out now one of the
things to understand about Kirk and this
is why you're going to see a lot of
differences between the show and the
comic is like with The Walking Dead for
example Kirkman wanted the show to
basically do things the way that he
would have done it with the comics in
hindsight right so basically the show
fixed a lot of the things that he wanted
to change with the comic book uh right
wrong or otherwise that's just kind of
the the intention there but they were
also drawing it out a little bit to make
sure they could they could kind of keep
the seasons going and and all that kind
of good stuff with Invincible is the
exact same thing right you know it's
just kind of drawing stuff out a little
bit for the purpose of keeping the show
uh going so they can get presumably as
many seasons as they can now one one of
the things that happens here of course
Mark has a little bit of a conversation
with Rex where Mark kind of got monster
girl off of uh off of Rex and the
monster girl's like yeah my bad I got a
little carried away anybody got a
cigarette you know but ultimately like
with with Rex because of the fact that
Rex cheated on Eve because he's an idiot
uh he's kind of like look man like I
don't like the way that you treated Eve
so make no mistake just because I Sav
monster girl from beating you to death
does not mean that like I like you or
that like we're friends right we're not
friends man I'm never going to be your
best friend like you're just a terrible
terrible person and I don't really want
have anything to do with you and so
following that you do have one guy one
lone guy who's there for the auditions
and is just doing
terrible he's literally just cowering in
fear and it's kind of a crazy little
thing there right just kind of cower
down and and that's basically it robot
kind of tells Mark man come with me and
Donald right we're going to kind of go
through and basically announce the
people who were on the team right so you
get duplicate which of course we kind of
knew she was going to be there you get
shrinking Ray who's a really cool
character monster girl who's just really
Op Black Samson and then Rex Spode uh
one of the funny things is like an
invitation is extended to Mark if he
wants to be a part of the team but
ultimately again Mark kind of turns it
down just because of the fact that he's
just got a little bit too much going on
and so what you end up switching to is
Mark later on that night kind of meeting
with his mom you know having dinner and
then she he's like she's like I don't
know where your dad is right he's all
saving the world or doing whatever in
the heck it is that he's doing and so
where where she kind of asked him what
he has going on he's like well you know
Amber's coming over right you know Amber
you know we're coming out coming over
and and uh you know we're just friends
right she's just coming over to study
right that's never true anytime a guy
has a girl over to study it's like yeah
we're going to study we're going to
study each other's
lips but that's exactly what happens
right like him and him and Amber start
making out now of course Eve shows up
and Eve is of course you know kind of
sees the two of them getting together
which Eve if you'd been a little
intelligent and actually told Mark how
you feel you'd be amazing what you'd be
amazed what happens when you use your
words but of course she flies away
realizing that that Mark is kind of with
another girl and that's kind of it right
you know and so ultimately we kind of
pick up with the mer twins here and this
is a really cool moment with the mer
Twins and it's really significant when
it comes to the character of The
Immortal right right so the mer twins
again this is the body that they
basically took out of the Grave when it
was dug up by a couple of those crazy
kids but the mer has a great big huge
harness around his neck and the reason
why is because while we don't really
know anything about the immortal's
origins like really we don't really know
much of anything about his Origins we
just know like at some point along the
line something happened and he's
effectively Immortal he's the closest
you get to like an eternal in the
Invincible Comics the eternals from
Marvel he's basically like that or or an
external rather from uh from Marvel
Comics is the closest you get to that
but the overall gist here is that so
long in his head and his body remain in
contact with each other that he'll
always survive the issue with this is
that he does have a healing factor and
the the idea behind the the mer twins
was to basically use this harness to
essentially keep his head attached to
his body and then install like obedience
controls so that over time his head
would basically heal and reattach to his
body and then using The Obedience
controls they could essentially control
the immortal right the problem with this
is it doesn't work the immortal wakes up
right just snaps up and it's just like
just starts freaking out and then just
immediately flies off presumably with
the intention of taking out omn
man okay uh so the the second video that
we did on uh on Invincible actually did
pretty well or relatively well
relatively speaking right like I usually
use 100,000 views as a litmus test to or
really is kind of like a benchmark to
determine whether or not a video
performs well right if like if it breaks
100,000 views we do it again right if it
doesn't well we maybe try a different
version of it or we just kind of drop it
right it sort of depends I know it's a
high number but if you're a YouTuber
that's how you grow your channel would
you guys believe me if I told you that
with this video it'll be the end of
season 1 in the TV show right like that
it's it happens so fast right that's one
of the crazy things like the the TV show
was what something like eight or nine
episodes in the first season and like
we're already caught up 12 or 13 issues
in and like you're caught up with the
end of the show right it's it's it's
kind of crazy but one of the things that
happens here is you pick up with Mark
during his birthday right like all his
friends are out kind of you know they're
like hey man it was a cool party and all
that kind of stuff and they basically
leave and Mark sits down and watches
movies with his dad now the reality is
that Debbie absolutely loves this right
and the reason why is because it's one
of the first real instances or at least
one of those kind of reminders of
normaly right one of the things to kind
of keep in mind when you're looking at
this from Debbie's perspective is that
she's dealing with a husband who is by
all standards of measurement what would
equate to like a Superman esque
character and a son who's almost as
strong as his father is right so
literally it's just superhero Antics all
the time right they're always here and
there and they're always off and they're
always doing things and so on and so
forth and so the notion of having like a
normal family has is long gone right
that was gone before they even had their
family in the first place right as soon
as she started banging omn man and they
popped out a kid like that normaly went
right out the window right and so
because of that to kind of see this
small little moment where like a father
and son are watching uh watching Day of
the Dead is kind of cool I will say this
I said the same thing on patreon I think
Day of the Dead is overrated Night of
the Living Dead honestly I think the
1990s version of Night of the Living
Dead with Tony Todd is much better than
like the The Day of the Dead or even
like the original Night of the Living
Dead but uh but nonetheless one of the
other things that comes out of this is
that because the Guardians of the globe
were destroyed by uh by omn man that you
have Cecil who meets with robot and
basically says we need you to form a new
team now one of the big things that goes
on here and this is one of the most
important things that I think you got a
glimpse of in the TV show and I would
like to have seen them do a little more
Justice with this is Nolan trying to
figure out how to talk to his son right
one of the things that was so great
about the comic the way that Kirkman did
it is in so many ways it humanized Nolan
right that like Nolan as he's presented
in the show is almost this guy who's
just disconnected from morality and the
idea like he's a guy who's like a
sociopath and like the things he does
where he looks like he's being a good
dad or he looks like he's being a being
a good husband because we know his true
nature now that it looks like he was
just going through the motions and in
some ways he was right like he's
pretending to be a good person so that
he can fit in quote unquote with Society
the way a sociopath would actually do
but the reality is in the comics and and
one of the things again I feel like they
only touched on in the show is he's
trying to figure out how to tell his son
the truth truth and he's genuinely
struggling with it right he's genuinely
just not really sure how to do it you
know again it's it's it's only for a
moment and so I guess maybe it was
around the same time spent but it's one
of those things that kind of becomes
recurring over the course of the show
right one of those things that you see a
few times here and there now one of the
other funny moments that goes on here is
that you do have Adam Eve Who's digging
Mark right like she's kind of like I
mean here's here's the thing man right
like she's about Mark right I mean we
all kind of know you know she's kind of
like hey you know like I'm going to do
the girl thing and play hard to get
right which is which is kind of a hassle
but like you know she's like I'm going
to do that that stuff where I'm not
going to make it easy for you so on and
so forth I'm not going to tell you what
I'm thinking right I'm just going to
hope you get it right when you assume
like that's that's it's it's one of
those weird things but when you have
this kind of shared moment between the
two of them where they destroy like this
crazy lizard Group which is kind of
funny but when you have this shared
moment where they're kind of talking
about superhero escapades and how they
worked well together as a team robot
comes by and he's like hey guys I'm
doing auditions for a new Guardians of
the globe uh Mark I'd love it if you did
it and he was like yeah man I'll be
right there and he's like Adam Eve what
do you think right and then she just
gets pissed and flies off right now the
whole reason why that happened is
because she was kind of enjoying the
moment right and instead of saying
actually I think it'd be kind of cool if
we stayed here and talk some more
instead she just kind of runs off in a
huff right with nobody knowing why she's
upset so it's one of those those funny
things now the funny thing about the TV
show is they went a lot more in depth
into the audition ceremony than Kirkman
did in the comics now again I think a
lot of this is kind of kirkman's
philosophy coming out of The Walking
Dead that if you guys ever saw any of
the interviews that he did when he was
talking about the TV show versus The
Walking Dead Comics is he wanted the
show to fix a lot of the things or to
expand on a lot of the things that he
didn't really like or didn't really care
for the way he originally did it in the
comics and that kind of seems to be the
theme Here Right the auditions don't
really happen you don't really see much
going on there the only thing you really
see is Rex and monster girl get into a
fight with each other when he starts
mouthing off and she helps him to
understand his place in the bigger
picture which is exactly what he needed
cuz Rex is a dick but like like when all
you really get is that right that's the
only thing you really get Mark steps in
like pummels monster girl because
seemingly she's losing control and she's
going to she's going to kill Rex and
that's it right that's literally all you
get right now one of the things that
kind of goes on is Mark has given the
offer to join the team if he wants to
but this is kind of an important aspect
of Mark's character is he turns it down
one of the big differences between Mark
and and Nolan is that Nolan took on the
role of becoming the world's superhero
because it was the easiest way to gain
the trust of humanity right to make it
easier and more malleable for him to
basically invade the world right to to
actually conquer the world or at least
to at the stage for the vulture mites to
invade the world and Conquer it that's
one of the reasons why he kind of took
that role unto himself I imagine there
also might be a little bit of narcissism
involved in there but for Mark he's a
far more humble person than than his
father is Right partially seemingly
because of his upbringing but also
because of the people that he spends
time with and the friends that he has
and so that's why he kind of prioritizes
everything else that he has going on
over the notion of like being a super
herero and part of the Guardians of the
globe so ultimately you end up getting
duplicate shrinking Ray monster girl
black Samson and Rex explode as the
official roster of the team with Mark
kind of having an open slot to join up
whenever he's ready now one of the other
things that kind of happens here and
this is kind of a an important moment
that'll become significant much much
much later on in the comics is when Adam
Eve shows up and then sees Mark kissing
Amber right it's not a super significant
moment it's a relatively small moment
but it's kind of important nonetheless
right and so what you end up doing here
is basically transitioning to
essentially the arrival of the immortal
now the immortal had basically been
brought back by the mer twins of course
the idea was that he'd been dug up by a
couple of kids and then the merer twins
essentially stepped in with the purpose
of bringing the immortal back and that's
kind of the nature of his character that
so long as the immortal's head is
reattached to his body that he can be
reanimated right he can come back we
don't really know much about his history
beyond that we don't know the exact way
in which he gained his powers we simply
just know that he has them but it is
kind of an important little tidbit here
because what you end up having is the
immortal kind of initially the mer twins
looking to use the immortal for their
own ends and planting like a mind
control device it doesn't work right
Immortal wakes up seemingly you know as
far as he's concerned the moment that he
died right so kind of basically
experiencing this Rush of memories and
watching all the other Guardians die
only to find out in these final moments
that it was Nolan who did it and then
dying himself and then immediately goes
after Nolan right now this is incredibly
important here because the fight that
takes place between the two is one where
you could easily misconstrue it and see
as it being something that's evenly
matched and to a degree it is but one of
the reasons why it looks like it's
evenly matched is because it's Nolan
trying to figure out what's going on if
Nolan's desire was To Kill The Immortal
he'd be dead right we saw him do it
before we saw him kill him in an instant
and it wasn't one of those things where
he caught him off guard I mean I guess
at the time that he did but what'll
happen here in a minute will basically
lay that to rest and the sense that the
immortal is exceedingly pissed off now
understand it's not just rage here it's
hurt right it's betrayal it's the
feeling that like he had this guy who he
thought was a friend that turned against
him and then killed him along with the
rest of his allies the problem with this
is that once the immortal is killed by
Nolan that Mark is right there right
Mark sees the whole thing happen when
he's kind of hearing about his father
being caught in a fight and that's when
his dad's like we need to talk right we
need to have a conversation here and
that's the important thing is because
what you get is this fullon origin of
the viltrumites right or at least most
of the origin of the vites now most of
this you guys already know just from
watching the TV show right that the
vites themselves essentially turned into
like a planet conquering race and so it
wasn't one of these things where they
would go to a planet wholesale Slaughter
it and then they would call it conquered
instead they would go there and then
they would basically expand their empire
and they would give people a choice
right either you serve us or we will
destroy you those individuals who
rebelled and who refused to B the knee
to the viltrumites were eradicated right
they were wiped out those individuals
who chose to bend the knee would be
brought into the VTR Empire right and so
ultimately what you ended up having is
Nolan who ended up becoming a part of
the group that would actually go out and
Conquer these various worlds right now a
lot of this was based was was really
predicated on the lifespan of the Vite
race right because they lived for so
incredibly long why not use that
lifespan to start conquering worlds
right in a more efficient way to
infiltrate those worlds as opposed to
like sending the entirety of the Vite
race into a world and then forcing that
world to bend the knee or eradicating
everybody who doesn't then why not just
go there and infiltrate those worlds now
it also made a lot more sense because
there aren't that many viltrumites left
and so why put all your eggs in one
basket right diversify your stocks
that's basically what this was it was in
a lot of ways them hedging their bets
that if they sent a viltrumite to a
world and the the super population on
that world was of such a degree to where
they either fought the Vite off or they
even killed them then it would give the
other vites uh uh a better understanding
of what that world's capable of and to
be able to plan accordingly maybe it
meant sending sending the entirety of
the vmite race there whatever the case
happens to be now one thing that I do
also want to specify here that this is
only a part of the origin of the vmite
race there's a lot more that goes on
here right there's a lot more that takes
place here but essentially the entire
origin story that Nolan is spilling out
to his son is one of deception and
subterfuge one of Espionage trickery
manipulation that he's basically saying
I'm a villain I was sent here as a bad
guy and I was supposed to basically lead
the way for your world to be conquered
but then ultimately I saved your mom and
uh and because your mom was pretty hot
you know I ended up basically you know
getting with her right you know we we
banged a bunch of times and then you
came out right so like that's and then
over time other superheroes began to
manifest for any number of reasons and
they ultimately ended up forming the
guardians of the globe but regardless of
how it was sliced no matter how this
origin is told here the entire thing was
predicated on the idea on the notion
that Nolan was sent to infiltrate the
world and to basically set the stage for
it to be conquered but something changed
right things switched and what ended up
switching here is Nolan fell in love and
Nolan began to realize that you know
what it means to have a meaningful life
I mean up to this point he was a hammer
right so everything was a nail but then
suddenly he was kind of woken up to this
idea that there's something something
bigger out there than just arbitrarily
conquering various worlds in the name of
some Empire and not giving it any real
credible thought by having a child by
having a wife having a family he found a
greater meaning in his life he found
value in his life and that's one of the
things that he kind of hit on is that
even when he was serving as part of the
vure might race he always kind of felt
like something was missing something was
off there was a kind of hole in him that
he couldn't quite fill but despite what
he's gained and despite the life that he
has now and the love that he feels for
his wife and the love that he feels for
his son at the end of the day he still
holds true to his vmite convictions and
the one thing that really keeps him
separated from being able to truly
connect to with his with his wife and
turn coat against the Vite Empire in
favor of his family is his longevity
that because of how old he is and
because of how long his life will be at
the end of the day no relationship that
he believes he has will ever truly be
meaningful because in the end he will
always outlive everything now if I'm a
betting man here I think this is just a
defense mechanism right and it's one of
the things that I think will prove to be
true as you get further and further into
the story that in this bit of a thing
here his whole stance is like well I
mean I'm going to outlive everybody Mark
so there's no point in having any kind
of a meaningful relationship but that's
the nature of life right I mean in his
in his situation it is for the most part
guaranteed but the fact that we don't
really know what the future holds is
what makes the relationships that we
have so significant you and a friend
could be walking across the street
tomorrow and they get hit by a bus and
die and the only thing that's going to
be able to kind of get you through that
pain and that anguish are the times you
shared and what Nolan is basically doing
is cutting him himself off to all of
that right he's cutting himself off to
all that valuable human interaction so
when the time comes when he does outlive
Debbie and Debbie dies of old age that
he won't really allow himself to Relish
in those beautiful moments that they had
instead it'll be and this is why I never
have any real meaningful relationships
right it's approaching it from a place
of negativity it's focusing on the loss
instead of focusing on the gain and
that's what makes Nolan really puts him
in this mindset and that's why when he
tells Mark instead of saying you're my
son I love you and therefore to help
hell with the vmite race right you and I
will stand against them when the time
comes that they arrive on this world
instead he says now I need you to stand
along with me I destroy the Guardians of
the globe to weaken the Earth's defenses
and so now I need you to join me and to
prepare this world for conquering at the
hands of the Vite race what follows is
Mark of course standing up to his father
and basically saying no right I don't
want to have anything to do with that
and and for Mark it's a massive betrayal
right because this this comes from a
variety of places right under normal
circumstances you and I and anybody out
here in the real world assuming that we
have a positive relationship with our
fathers we look up to them right we look
to our fathers as kind of the standard
on what a man should be and in a lot of
ways they're the guiding force on how we
operate as men through the world we've
talked about that in a multitude of
different videos right that we're born
into the world that we are taught by our
parents the moral compass that they that
they use to see the world and then
eventually we graduate out into the
greater tribe and the moral compass they
gave us comes into conflict with the
moral compasses of the people around us
and that inter turn we adopt and we take
on different moral viewpoints from other
people and combine it with our own it's
what keeps us from being stagnant right
it's what keeps us or allows us to grow
as human beings to grow beyond what our
parents originally taught us for Mark
his experiences over the course of his
life have taught him his father is an
admirable man that his father is a great
man his father is a champion of the
world his his father is a great man even
just on a personal level and now he's
being confronted with the fact that
secretly all of it is a lie right his
father's a terrible person his father is
a villain he was sitting here for the
you know to conquer the world and now he
wants his son to conquer the world too
that he's telling him none of his
relationships matter that none of
Nolan's relationships with his with his
friends with his allies even with his
own wife none of them are relevant that
that his that that Debbie is some kind
of a pet right she's just a thing that's
there and a time will come when she will
die and Nolan will not really care all
that much because again he focuses on
the loss instead of on the gain Mark
refuses to accept that right that in the
end he sees himself as a human he sees
himself as a champion a true champion of
the people and ultimately in the end he
says like this is my world right this is
my home these are my friends and I'm not
going to let you destroy any of it and
ultimately Mark gets into a conflict
with his father now here's the thing
what follows is probably one of the most
spectacular ass whoopings in the history
of comic books and I don't think that
the TV show did it justice it really
really really did it was amazing because
literally like his father sends him
pummeling into the building this entire
building collapses and all the people
inside of it die and he's like this is
like like do you not understand now this
is not your world right one punch from
from one of our people and thousands of
people lose their lives it's one of
these things where it's kind of like we
are on a much higher level of power than
they are right if anything it's pride
and it's huous just because you've
achieved a certain station in life does
not mean that you're better than those
individuals who are below your station
in life at the end of the day you still
put your pants on the same way you still
need water you still need food I guess
in Nolan's case is a little bit
different here and again it's kind of
reaffirming this betrayal in the eyes of
Mark how could you on on one hand claim
to be a champion of the people and then
on the other hand seek to stab them in
the back right like you're shaking your
hand shaking their hand with your right
hand and then stabbing him in the back
with your left right like that's a
terrible thing more so than that in a
lot of ways it does kind of flip the
traditional superhero Mythos on its head
and an interesting way right because if
you were to take this principle that one
punch can destroy thousands of people
that applies to Superman the difference
between Superman and Nolan is that
Superman chose to be a good guy Nolan
chose to be a bad guy but what happens
when a person with that level of power
uses it for nefarious purposes and
that's what you get here the power of
Nolan and Mark even with Mark being as
young and as weak as he is and his
strength of course will increase over
time even being in that in that state
he's powerful enough to level cities and
there's really nothing anybody can do
here to stop him and that's what's kind
of nuts about this is because one of the
things to notice here is the fight
between Mark and the fight between Nolan
is a lot more drawn out here in the
comic than it is in the show and the
show it's it's a huge conflict right and
you've got Debbie watching everything
unfold when she was taken to taken to a
command center by Cecil hearing
everything it is that that Nolan's
saying and all that kind of stuff but
the fight's pretty intense right Mark is
just getting wrecked now one of the big
differences here and this is this is a
huge thing to focus on here it's a huge
thing to understand despite all the
experience Mark has in being a super
hero he is still woefully unprepared and
the reason why is because Nolan if you
notice is not really fighting with
emotion he's not fighting out of anger
he's not fighting out of Wrath Mark is
his emotions are getting the better of
him and when you fight in an emotional
state you're almost guaranteed to lose
unless you're just that much better than
your opponent but Mark is not Mark is
not that much better than omn man
instead he's getting absolutely
decimated because he's letting his
emotions get the better of it and so
again like that's when Nolan even
himself starts to become emotional
screaming at his son like why do you
resist right like why do you fight on
behalf of these people whose lives don't
matter right like these people's lives
will be a a blink of an eye in
comparison to your life most of these
people that you know you will not even
know that they were alive in the first
place you will for have forgotten about
them like there'll be some name on the
tip of your tongue that you can vaguely
remember in 200 years right like
there'll be there'll be a thought that
might creep up in the back of your head
and dismissed just as quickly in 300
years right no one in 500 years no one
here is going to have any significance
to you so why do you stay here and fight
what are you fighting for why does any
of this matter to you and at the end of
the day when he says like what are you
going to have after 500 years Mark's
response is you I would still have you
when it's all said and done I would
still have you Dad and ultimately
because of the emotional toll because of
everything that's gone on here and
because of the fact that Mark was just
kind of so open with his with Nolan and
really treats him as a dad it opens
Nolan up in a way that he hasn't really
experienced before right it makes him
feel vulnerable in a way that he hasn't
really experienced so ultimately Nolan
baales now the big question everybody
has to ask here which of course is this
is the end of the of of basically season
1 what happens to Nolan where does Nolan
go where does where does all this end up
taking off to like how does all this
come together what's going on guys this
is Rob and um we're picking back up with
invincible and this one kind of answers
the question that I think a lot of
people have which is what happened to
omn man at the end of the series right I
know we're like super late on this right
you know it's just kind of the way it
gets played so honestly I don't really
expect any of the Invincible videos that
I make to get any real traction or to be
successful probably until the second
season of the show right so for about a
year or so which I don't really mind but
here's the thing right there are a
couple volumes that take place a couple
story ARS takes place Place between the
one that we left off on and the one that
we're in right now that's why we went
from volume 3 and just jump to six um we
can cover like we are going to cover
those on patreon we can cover them here
if you guys are super interested but by
and large there really isn't anything
that happens in those volumes that you
have not seen on the TV show in the
comics there's a huge difference in
terms of the timeline right between when
certain things happen for example robot
having his Consciousness put in like the
body of a kid right like that happens
after omn man leaves Earth in the uh in
the comics but it happens before he does
in the TV show right so it's just little
things like that the reality is that in
those volumes there's two main things
that happen that are kind of specific to
this so the first thing that we have to
kind of talk about here is the state of
Mark's mom right so in the TV show you
guys saw the ending episode where you
had uh Mark's mom who was watching the
whole conflict between Mark and omn man
and heard everything that he said right
that he loved loved his wife like she
like he loves a pet or something like
that because he'll outlive them all so
the idea of of having like a meaningful
attachment to a person is really kind of
nonsensical in his eyes and the comic
Mark's mom never saw any of that all she
really knew initially is that omn man
kind of seemed to be a bad guy and that
was basically it what ended up happening
is a couple different things one she
started falling into the realm of
alcoholism because of the fact that omn
man had essentially taken off and even
to a degree kind of blamed Mark right
there's a moment in the comics where she
asked Mark why did you drive your father
away right that kind of a thing now she
does it when she's in a drunken stuper
but she does it nonetheless right and
it's like they say drunk actions are
sober thoughts and so because of that
the the next big thing that happened and
the way she found out the truth is that
while there wasn't really a broadcast of
everything happening with regards to
Mark and omn man that it was more or
less being recorded by like Cecil and
those guys and the government and so
what ended up happening is the entire
recording was leaked to the press and
that's how Mark's mom found out that omn
man never really cared about her that he
loved her quote unquote like a pet that
kind of thing that sent her further down
into alcoholism and so that's kind of
the big thing about Mark's mom is she
becomes like a full-blown alcoholic like
literally Mark comes home pretty
consistently and she's drunk like all
the time right that kind of thing uh but
the the other big thing here is that
Mark revealed his identity to Amber and
so ultimately that's where things get a
get a little crazy is because there
comes a point where she's kind of like
okay she' more or less kind of figured
it out but uh but nonetheless right
those are the the two big things that we
kind of need to discuss going into this
little tidbit here going into this this
story here so what ends up happening
here is he's basically met by the
arrival of a character named science dog
now this right off the bat seems
ridiculous because science dog is a
comic book character that Mark reads
right so like he knows right off the bat
science dog isn't real and that's why
like a fight immediately breaks out
between the two of them because he
refuses to believe that science dog is
an actual person right that that it's an
actual character that somebody somewhere
is more or less messing with his mind
now one of the things to could to
understand here is under normal
circumstances Mark wouldn't react this
way but coming off the heels of
everything that happened with his dad
he's kind of on edge right so like he
immediately freaks out and goes after
science dog and then of course things
more or less calm down and then science
dog reveals that he's not actually
science dog right then instead he's an
alien called axen now they he put on the
guys of the science St because it seemed
like it would make the most sense to
approach Mark and to be able to talk to
him but in effect the idea is like you
know we essentially need you right to
basically help us save our life and the
leader of our planet has requested your
presence on our world right and so it
takes something like like 2 weeks or
some automa of time to get there but
when Mark arrives the thrin are
basically like these these grasshopper
looking people right and it's and it's
kind of wild but the idea is that like
you know again like the leader of our
world needs you and as soon as Mark gets
to the throne room his dad is standing
there omn man is is essentially on this
world now right and that's kind of the
big question is where has omn man been
all this time right like what happened
here uh and why is omn man on this world
so the way this explanation goes down
and this is pretty cool is initially
they're pissed off and they go to attack
each other but they ultimately don't
instead they Embrace right which is a a
pretty cool and interesting moment here
now at that point it turns into okay uh
where have you
been that kind of thing and so we get
this really really cool explanation from
from omn man basically saying that like
when he was a vilter right when he was
initially brought in or really kind of
Born Into the Vite race that he really
fulfilled the purpose the way he was
supposed to right that for the most part
they were all about expanding their
empire that's all they really really
ever cared about but when he was on
Earth and particularly when he had a son
that his perspective of the world began
to change that Earth began to change him
and so ultimately when the choice came
down or when the chance came down for
him to kill mark he couldn't do it
especially when Mark said like no matter
what happens here I'll always have you
show that Mark cared so much about his
father and it revealed to omn man how
much he actually cared about his son and
really the life that he had back there
and so ultimately it's one of these
things where he kind of you know where
where Mark tells him like come back home
right like come back home come see Mom
she's in a wreck and ultimately he's
like no like I can't go back even if I
wanted to there's no way humanity and
Earth would accept me now knowing what
I've done right like that that Pandora's
Box has been open there's no letting the
cat out of the bag right they're not
going to let some World Conqueror back
into their ranks with open arms because
he just apologized right that's that's
not going to happen and so ultimately he
says that kind of on this world that he
that he transitioned to that because of
the fact that he abandoned his post the
vites are going to be coming for him and
one of the big concerns that he has here
is that when he settled on this world
the reason why he's the leader is
because they determine who the leader is
going to be based on the oldest member
of their society but these guys only
live for like N9 months at a time right
these fraction have a a super short
lifespan but because omn man's been been
around for thousands of years they're
kind of like okay cool you get to be our
leader now just right off the bat right
just like that I mean it is kind of
implied that he had to do a few things
to earn their trust that he saved their
world from different threats and things
like that right it wasn't just how old
are you he like well I'm a few thousand
years old cool you're our leader right
they didn't just appoint him side unseen
right it didn't really really happen but
he's also basically formed a family here
right he's got a wife which is a weird
alien thing that he's kissing a giant
grasshopper he's married to a praying
mantis and then uh and then he's got a
son right now the caveat about his son
is that he basically has purple skin and
this is really the big concern that omn
man has here is that the vites basically
stand against to anybody that they
consider to be quote unquote genetically
impure right and so if a viltrumite has
a child with somebody else that's not
considered to be a a you know pure
looking person then the vure mites will
kill him right they they'll kill that
kid and an unnormal circumstances Omni
man never would have done this in the
first place or if he did it would have
been part of the process of infiltrating
the world and then he wouldn't have
cared if his kid was killed right all
that would have mattered was the success
of the mission But ultimately he's just
kind of like no right like you know I
need my son to survive right like I I
like I cannot let the vites destroy my
kid so it's only a matter of time before
they get here and I need you to help me
get my son to safety right the big
problem with this is that that where the
idea is to have Mark essentially be here
and help his father defend this world
against the vilm mites when they arrive
the vites are already here now there's
only a few of them right but this is
really kind of Robert Kirkman speaking
to the power of this race that there's
like three of them here and that's
really it right that's really all you
need there's only a handful here when
the Vite War kicks off that's when
things get crazy and let me tell you
something man with all the power you've
seen from omn man and all that kind of
stuff it's nothing in comparison to
Freddy Mercury right to thrag you guys
call thrag Freddy Mercury so I'm going
to call him Freddy Mercury but it's
nothing in comparison to the power of
thrag right like Freddy's just he's got
a whole different level of power now
when this all kicks off immediately omn
man tells Mark get my family to safety
there's a couple reasons why he does
this the first is because of the fact
that one Mark is not experience facing
off against the vites all he knows is
facing off against his dad two is imply
that his dad is more or less on the same
level as the other vites so if Mark
couldn't topple his dad what chance does
he have against two or three right I
mean he would just get decimated so fast
it wouldn't even be a contest and two
Mark's the other he's he's the second
most powerful person on this world
outside of omn man right so he's the
most capable person of being able to
keep this family safe and get them to
what are called the caves right now the
caves are kind of this hidden location
that's out there somewhere and this is
the segment where I kind of talk about
how it's it's more or less implied or
stated that omn man was not arbitrarily
chosen that he had performed various
Deeds to to more or less keep this world
safe the problem here is that Mark was
followed by a v Vite by the name of
Lucan now lukan's a cool character man
you don't really get to see a whole lot
of him here but like later on you do and
he's cool I like him man like I like
this I like this guy he's interesting
but ultimately it's one of these things
where he shows up and he's like okay
this kid's got to go right the that's
kind of the funny thing about Mark is
Mark could be passed off as a vure mine
because there's no real differentiation
between the appearance of Mark and the
appearance of a standard vure mine and
unless they scan his DNA they would
never really know that he was part human
and had the plan of omn man come to
fruition right so like the bom between
himself and Mark was was strong and say
for example that Mark decided to side
with omn man and say okay fine I will
help you conquer Earth at the end of the
really the the fight between the two of
them then like it would have like the
Earth would have been would have been
prepared and that would have been it and
maybe there would have been some
questions asked like how did this guy
sire a kid like if he didn't really bang
a Vite or anything like that but at the
end of the day they would have just kind
of you know turned a blind eye and and
more or less that's that seems to kind
of kind of be what would happen in this
instance with omn man's new son who's
basically Omni kid is more or less the
name he that doesn't happen he's got
purple skin right how do you avoid that
so ultimately uh Mark is able to kind of
get the upper hand on Lucan for a moment
right just kind of Sucker Punch him and
then just like take off right and that's
that's kind of like okay cool uh you
know like like Lucan kind of calms
himself down for a second and it's like
all right let's get to this kid
ultimately Lucan catches up with him
super fast right and that's one of the
big things here again like these guys
are no joke man like these vites are on
a whole different level from anything
that Mark's used to fighting outside of
his dad lukan catches up omn man Saves
the Day right like just snatch like like
literally crashes into the sky and then
just goes to Pummel him now one of the
things that happens you don't really see
exactly what takes place all you see is
omn man coming back with blood all over
him right so presumably he's either Beat
lukan to Death Or incapacitated him to
the point where Lucan can't really do
anything right he's more or less out of
the picture and that's kind of what he
says right like it's not my blood and
when they're like so what happened to
the vure m he's like dead right and
that's it right you know just left him
for dead by the caves and there's and
that's it right you know so ultimately
when they end up getting back to the
city which seemingly omn man had to
abandon in order to make sure that
family was was taken to safety once he
realized that Lucan had followed Mark
once he gets back there a huge portion
of these thrx are destroyed right the
city's totally trashed and a huge number
of these guys are all killed and that's
kind of the crazy thing right under any
other circumstance omn man would have
been like well I mean I guess it's just
part and partiel to the nature of the
thing and that's it right you wouldn't
have seen a great big huge stink about
it but omn man's trying to reform
himself he's trying to become a good guy
right he's trying to be a hero you know
it's one of the things that he says he
says I should not care that they're all
dead I've had blood on my hands before
far more than in this and yet I care I
am enraged right now the thing about
this is because of the fact that omn man
this is kind of a this is one of those
aspects of the character that's easy to
overlook uh omn man has never been a
person who's had to deal with his
emotions in this capacity before when
you spend your life as a sociopath right
that like people and the world around
you are bobles to be used for your own
individual goals and you don't really
have any emotional attachment to those
people then suddenly when you start
developing emotional attachments to
people you don't know how to handle it
right it's like seeing color for the
first time what do you do right like you
start to into a panic but emotions are
far stronger than seeing a color right
and so because of that omn man doesn't
really know how to process this feeling
of grief that he's experiencing and so
he lashes out and in this instance he
lashes out at Mark and actually starts
like goes to start pummeling mark But
then suddenly the two vites who
basically destroyed everything they
essentially appear and that's when omn
man targets them and that's kind of the
crazy thing right is that under normal
circumstances when these when these
vites are fighting and it seems to be a
major focal point of their characters
they fight cleanly right meaning they
don't let their emotions get the better
better of them they stay focused on the
target at hand right they are they're
they're precise right it's just
Precision combat skills and it's cool to
see right the problem with this is that
omn man's fighting full of emotion and
so ultimately Mark kind of jumps in to
do what he can and Mark's being wildly
overwhelmed by these guys right just
being wildly overwhelmed omn man more or
less steps in and then Saves the Day
right crushes both of these guys smashes
their heads together and that's more or
less the end of them right and then from
there it's like okay you know like
they're going to be on their way back
right so like calm down uh like we need
to relax we need to focus right like up
to this point in your life as a
superhero like I get you're young you're
a teenager you're full of hormones and
emotion that's fine but you need to get
that under control right like facing off
against these guys you need you need to
be precise you need to be focused you
need to make sure that you are
essentially at peace with yourself it's
going to be the only way that you can
come out on top because these guys have
been fighting for thousands of years
right it's not like they've been
fighting for a few years or so they're
not they're not fresh off the assembly
line right they've been doing this for a
long long time and they have their
skills honed down to a te you need to
get as close to that level as you
possibly can despite the fact that it's
not a tried andrue teaching lesson in
the sense of you know omn man sitting
down with Mark and like hey here's a
couple of Spar buddies that I know who
are going to help you hone your skills
it's about as as real of a lesson as
Mark is ever going to get and so
ultimately you end up having like Mark
who's totally overwhelmed right omn man
gets the upper hand on his and then Mark
starts calling out for help and
literally just like crushes this guy
right and it's like you're going to die
for this right like that's it and just
just kills this guy literally headbutts
him to death he headbutts him so hard
his eye pops out of his head it's kind
of nuts right but Mark is just
absolutely decimated now at that point
omn man goes to kind of help Mark tend
to his wounds and then Here Comes Lucan
out of nowhere right like literally the
guy that omn man left for dead impaled
this guy right like dismal this guy
lucan's holding his intestines in right
he's got his pants held up and keeping
his intestines held in place man this is
what we're talking about and yet none of
these vites have anything on frag that's
the craziness about it man but the guy
basically incapacitates omn man knocks
him out and leaves Mark for dead because
at the end of the day the target's not
Mark the target is Nolan right that's
the whole thing behind this and so
ultimately the vites end up you know a
whole another group of vites show up
they end up rounding up like they kind
of tend to mark because to a degree if
I'm being honest there's probably you
know Mark probably earned a little bit
of respect here right because it's one
of the things that I've kind of said the
vites are very much like Spartans and so
even if Mark wasn't strong enough to
overpower the vites the fact that he was
able to do some damage and he fought
with a lot of heart kind of earned the
respect a little bit not enough they're
like hey you know you're one of us now
come hang out with us right he can't sit
at the cool kids table but they're not
going to throw paper wads at him you
know what I mean like you guys
understand what I'm saying like it's
it's that kind of a thing you know and
so at the end of the day where omn man's
taken away the thing he tells Mark is
read my books right my books make sure
you read those and so that that's kind
of the cool thing is because again like
one of these vites kind of shows up to
Markus says we tended to your wounds and
when he ask why he's like why all it
counts you've you've proven yourself
worthy a member of the Vite Empire and
they almost kind of say like you are
going to be designated V my you know
agent of Earth like you are basically
going to serve our Empire on Earth
that's kind of the role that we're going
to give you now the caveat to this is
that if with with Mark more or less
being assigned this role even
unwillingly by the vites if he doesn't
follow through with it they'll kill him
right that's that's kind of the crazy
thing about this and they know they can
right I mean the amount of time it would
take for him to become strong enough to
stop any of them from killing him is
lengthy right far longer than the amount
of time they would give him to like
conquer earth right to prepare Earth for
for the for the end of things and so
that's kind of the crazy thing is cuz
Mark gets back to uh to Nolan's you know
his his his grasshopper wife you know
she's like where's my husband he's like
he's basically gone right you know like
they took him right that kind of a thing
and so Mark kind of helps them rebuild
and all that kind of stuff and then
essentially ends up kind of taking his
brother back to the world you know back
to Earth and for no other reason than to
kind of of you know help him experience
what his family life could be like now
something to know Mark did not initially
want to do this right he did not
initially want to like take this kid
back to Earth and you know now that he's
doing it it's kind of a cool opportunity
but the reality is that because of the
lifespan of these through actions is so
incredibly short his mom doesn't have
like she's not long for this world right
she's basically almost done with all her
living and the kind of question is
what's going to happen when I die right
I mean the vter mites are going to try
to come back for him eventually and so
at the end of the day like at the very
least if he's with you he's with
somebody that has the potential to keep
him safe even if it's getting him
somewhere else and so ultimately Mark
kind of becomes the caretaker for his uh
for his his younger brother the problem
with this is that when he gets home back
to Earth he's like hey Mom she's like oh
my God Mark you're back that's awesome
he's like yeah I brought a little gift
it's the gift that keeps on giving a
couple things one uh dad sent for me and
that's why I went to that world and
she's like wait a minut what was your
father doing and he's like okay so like
you know he's more he more or less
conquered that is kind of what he did
and he kind of like reiterates
everything that's going on and it kind
of sucks right because she's she's kind
of like you know like did he did he say
anything about me I mean I know he said
he was wrong and that that Earth changed
him and that kind of stuff so you know
obviously he's trying to turn over a new
leaf and and she's like did he say
anything about me and and honestly if
we're being honest with ourselves one of
the things to say here is like yeah he
said he misses you right and that would
go a long way towards making her feel
better there is such a thing as H as
being honest to a fault this is one of
those instances when he's like no he
didn't say anything about you right
you're going to tell an alcoholic woman
who misses her husband that he didn't
say anything about her and so she's like
I need a drink and that's kind of the
crazy thing is cuz at that point mark
piles on even more and then he's like uh
we need to talk about like your we need
to talk about my brother right and
that's when she learns not only did he
go to a different world and not say
anything about her indicating he doesn't
really seemed to miss her at all but
then he popped out another kid man so
like literally just moved on like that
right and it's kind of crushing but the
cool little thing about this is that
when she's able to kind of grasp the
reality of the situation that she's in
right and she's kind of like okay you
know like it's weird that my son was
summoned to a different world by his
father who tried to conquer this world
who I miss but I also have kind of
conflicted feelings about once she gets
past all that stuff then she's kind of
like I mean he's he's kind of cute right
and so it's this this little kid
represents hope for Debbie I think it's
probably the best way to say it right
that whenever you're dealing with a
person who's struggling with alcoholism
that often times it's not enough to
simply just pull themselves up right I
mean you can't really pull yourself up
by your bootstraps when it comes to
alcoholism you can right it's possible
but it's much easier if you have a
reason to not want to be an alcoholic
anymore and in the reality is even if
she can't necessarily be with Nolan then
at the very least the son that like
needs to be taken care of because
Nolan's currently incapacitated kind of
gives her a second chance right gives
her a kind of second win right somebody
else to care for besides her self and I
know it seems a little strange and it
seems a little odd but in a lot of ways
it really helps her right because it's
kind of like taking care of the legacy
of her husband it's as close as she can
get to Nolan even if she's struggling
with him because a time will come when
they will meet again and will it will
not go the way you think it does it's
one of the coolest moments in the whole
Comics it's one of the coolest moments
in Invincible but then you also end up
having Mark who shows back up to Amber
now the crazy thing about this is that
when he finally shows up again uh
initially he kind of gave her like a
quick little explanation but not a whole
lot right he didn't really tell her a
whole lot it was kind of like one of
those you got to trust me me everything
will be okay I'll be back that kind of
situation and the biggest issue is that
he was gone 2 months she initially
thought he was going to go going to be
gone for a much shorter amount of time
but ultimately Mark told her like I
don't know exactly how long I'm going to
be gone for and so in this in this
situation Amber is as much a victim of
her own expectation as she is the fact
that Mark is a superhero and is often
times kind of flaky and so the result of
this is that she's kind of like you were
gone for 2 months man you know and and
it really kind of sits her on a on a big
issue because what this did is it almost
kind of sent her into an existential
crisis on the relationship if Mark is
going to be a superhero and Mark is
going to be engaged in superhero Antics
and superhero activities but at the same
time he's going to be going on missions
where without any real definitive end
date you know in terms of when he's
going to be back is that something she
can live with is that something she can
cope with and that's a question she kind
of has to ask herself right like if my
man's going to be gone for two or three
months at a time or possibly even years
if we're really being honest with
ourselves no definitive end dat on when
he might return can I really put my my
my life in my my romantic happiness on
hold in the hopes that he will come back
uh there are people who would say yes
right like at this point like if the two
of you guys ever end up slapping rings
on each other's fingers then yeah that's
part of the bargain right like you knew
what you were getting into that's just
part of it right you can't change your
mind all of a sudden but at the same
time you can right because people change
people grow right it's just the nature
of things and what was acceptable and
okay at the beginning of things or at
some point along the line may not be
acceptable later on and this is
exceedingly important because if we're
being honest the relationship is
becoming serious they're at that college
age now right and College age is one
either you're partying or you're finding
the person that you're most likely going
to start settling down with at some
point along the line while you build
your career they build their career you
kind of build a family together right
and and if that's the case then Amber is
most likely looking to the Future right
she's not looking at this as like a
fling she's looking at this like hey
this could be something serious right I
mean sure I'm not in a position right
now where I want to marry the guy but
like if the relationship becomes serious
enough then maybe we can consider that
if nothing else it's a fleeting thought
in the back of her head and if the idea
of slapping a ring on it is a fleeting
thought then if she's ever considering
more of a serious life that becomes a
thought as well can you really Bank on a
person who's going to vanish for months
months at a time without giving you real
you know any real definitive answer
because they don't even know why they're
going right can you rely on that and
ultimately Amber has mixed feelings
about it she's like look I don't know
how I feel about this I don't know if
I'm okay with it if I'm not okay with it
I'm not really sure if I can if I can
handle that so at the end of the day
she's just kind of like I I'll figure it
out right but at the moment the
relationship's on the Rocks right it's
one of these things where it's kind of
teetering whether or not their
relationship survives it's dependent on
whether or not this is something she can
handle what's going on guys this is Rob
and we are back with Invincible yes we
are okay cool sup here's the thing right
like if you guys remember the last video
that we did you ended up having Mark who
basically brought his step brother back
home and I'll have the playlist for
invincible down in the description but
uh but Mark brought his step brother
back home right so basically the the son
of omn man on a different planet right
and and what this does is it kind of
picks up with this idea of like Mark's
mom raising him right now initially when
Mark brought him back it was really kind
of a shock for Mark's mom right just
because of the fact fact that one like
everything had seemingly happened so
fast and she never really had a chance
to cope we talked about that in the last
video that was the biggest issue that
Mark's mom had is I guess she coped but
her method of coping was alcohol right
she just kind of delved into alcoholism
now that's one of the things that I
loved about Invincible for us as regular
people we all have our own coping
mechanisms right some of us work out
some of us make Comic Book YouTube
videos others end up kind of jumping
into less productive things and alcohol
is a very easy thing to fall into the
Trap of alcoholism is all too easy right
I've got mem of my family who have
fallen prey to that because it's very
easy to kind of numb the pain right to
just sort of succumb to that drunken
stuper and then you just don't feel
anything right you don't feel any real
sadness you don't really feel any real
remorse you just kind of don't really
feel a whole lot and the result is that
it makes the pain go away and that
really I think is a testament more to
what Deborah was going through than
anything else because seemingly her
entire world came crashing down like
that right in the blink of an eye your
husband turns out to be a villain from a
different planet who openly admits that
he never really cared about you at all
right your son is a this walking talking
reminder of the man that you that you
loved you know that you essentially lost
right I mean that that's that's kind of
the crazy thing and so for Mark's mom
having a little kid to take care of here
is a great thing for her because it kind
of gives her a chance to sort of start
fresh right to kind of start over to a
degree and it sort of gives her
something to live for Beyond herself
right a chance to to look at something
and to say like I can work for this
thing right I can build on this thing
you know I can raise this child into
somebody productive and admittedly hold
on to a portion of her husband the part
of her husband that she loved so much
and so from there you switch over to a
villain named Mastermind not a whole lot
doing here this guy's kind of a dick and
he does exactly what a man with a name
Mastermind would do he controls the
minds of other
people and so ultimately Mark and and
and the Guardians basically get the
upper hand on him and that's that's more
or less it but then you basically end up
jumping to Mark meeting with Amber but
the whole conversation with Amber is
kind of this funny moment right because
Mark has a tendency to kind of get
caught up in the moment right not really
caught up in himself Mark's pretty far
from being a a person who's full of of
arrogance and huus but but it's one of
these things where he's kind of like
okay so she's like he's like you know
what's you know you look pretty tired
she's like yeah I was I was up really
late and you know I've got like a big
test in an hour he's like okay well do
you want to ditch class and go with me
to Africa and she's like what did I just
say I got a test in an hour
Mark Mark doesn't listen but then she's
kind of like Africa it's Africa you know
like how often do people get to go to
Africa now here's one of the things that
I want to draw your attention to because
we actually kind of skipped over this in
the previous videos that we've done but
here's one of the things that I want to
draw your attention to if you guys
remember probably from the TV show
assuming that you never read the comics
which I don't know why you wouldn't be
reading the comics but in the in the TV
show you had that mission of Mars right
you had those weird little aliens that
had the capability of like taking over
and conquering whole Worlds by
possessing people things like that right
so one of the astronauts a guy by the
name of Russ Livingston is basically a
guy who was left behind right that guy
you saw with like the really dark eyes
and he's like he looks like he would
have like the the kind of laugh a man
would have if he had like a handlebar
mustache and he was a villain like you
know like that kind of a thing what one
of the Martians actually made it back to
earth right and so the result of this is
that you do kind of get a little bit of
of of discussion there but this guy kind
of realizes like given the powers that
he has the ability to shape shift
because he's more or less Invincible
version of Martian Manhunter that he can
in turn become a superhero and so that
kind of gives you this answer of what
happened with this this alien that ended
up taking on the form of of Russ
Livingston and then showing up on earth
now there are caveats here right the way
the the explanation is given to us he
can't necessarily hold the position for
an exceedingly long amount of time and
even then like with him being on Earth
he still is concerned about his race
back on Mars now when I say that he's
concerned about his people it's more of
like more like just the rebels right
because like in the end he's just kind
of like I mean I hated our Monarch right
our Monarch was like super corrupt I'm
kind of glad that I got away from them
you know I I I hate this uh it is kind
of interesting in terms of how he sees
his own people so I imagine he probably
only really Longs for the rebels and he
kind of goes as far as to say that right
like himself and the other Rebels hated
the enslavement of the squids and and so
on and so forth but when you basically
transition to Africa it's kind of this
funny moment right because Mark was
basically invited here by Eve that
Mark's mom had given him you know Eve's
number when she was out in in Africa and
then he had called her and she was like
yeah you know come hang out so Mark
brings Amber all right here's the thing
gentlemen gentlemen fellas guys out
there who are not very good at picking
up on Clues right one of the most
frustrating things with the nature of
the game when it comes to the lady folk
to the to the women folk is that they
never really tell you when they're
digging you right sometimes they do but
it's usually dropping subtle hints and I
guess part of the game is if you can
pick up on it and kind of build up that
tension right other times it's a pain in
the ass you know it's just like all
right whatever man I got more important
things to do but this is one of those
times man when a girl that you know digs
you is in another part of the world and
says hey come hang out you do one of two
things right either you're with like
you're Mark and you're with a girl and
you say look I'd love to but like you
know I'm with a girl right now so let's
let's table this right now or if you're
single you're like let's go
man that's all that is and she's
dropping all the hints man like she's
just literally telling him that she digs
him and it's kind of funny cuz Mark just
seems oblivious to it right like like
that guy like Mark is that guy and so
it's just like okay any more come on man
this is one of the cool things about
Adam Eve's character too though Robert
Kirkman and he he does it so subtly Adam
Eve I would argue is probably the most
powerful of all the characters that
exist out there because she can alter
matter on an atomic level now if this
was a Marvel comic Mark would be like
man like how advanced can this be and
she's like I can conquer the universe
and then she would just Ascend and
become a cosmic entity and then she
would just hover in the Stars forever
more and then appear every once in a
while because she's a plot device now
like that's what Marvel Comics would do
I love what Kirkman does right this is a
girl that can control matter on the
molecular level and it's just kind of
like yeah man like it's a thing that she
can do right she can just kind of will
things into existence but it's also a
little bit of of a learning curve here
because not even Adam Eve is fully aware
of everything that she can do and she
even says that right like she's learning
to use her powers in a more complex way
it's one of the reasons why she came out
here one to kind of get away from
everything but two to explore her full
capabilities when Adam Eve reaches like
her full potential which she will she is
a demon it's insane how powerful she is
right like she just gets to this
ridiculously OP level but Mark also does
like a little bit of catching up with
her right because like he basically
tells her like I've got a little brother
and it's like what you talk to your dad
what like your dad's married to like a
bug what like what is going on here and
so he does like the the the whole kind
of spill in the beans right and more or
less everything that we've kind of
caught up with here you everything that
we we've sort of discussed here and then
while the two of them are talking they
realize Amber is over there now this is
a funny depiction of her character
because one of the things that Kirkman
kind of hits on here when it comes to
the the various parts of invincible is
he almost kind of portrays people who
are superheroes as kind of a higher cast
or a higher order not in so far as how
they conduct themselves right I mean you
don't have marks for you know flying
around I look down on you that's not
really what he the the kind of
philosophy he has but uh but that's not
really how he operates it's really more
of the depiction of Amber like one of
the things that uh that that Adam Eve
really picks up on here is like Amber
never looks up right she almost never
ever looks up to the sky she's always
just kind of looking forward or just
kind of looking around right just you
know just kind of mining your own
business but it's one of these things
where Amber's kind of depicted here as a
person that in the grand scheme of
things isn't really striving for much in
this life right she's just kind of
striving for just good enough and and I
say just good enough in relation to
people like Mark or people like Adam Eve
I mean granted they have abilities that
Amber simply just doesn't have but with
having enhanced capabilities not just
Powers but with enhanced capabilities
enhanced access to things comes enhanced
abilities to achieve more in this world
right it's really kind of establishing
this idea that Amber is just not for
Mark right I mean they're just it's just
not really supposed to be that way but
it also kind of reflects itself in the
conversation that like Adam Eve and Mark
had had and the sense that that Mark was
kind of talking to her about how her and
Amber have kind of gotten into a few
fights here and there and that's part
for the course when you're in a
relationship you do get into arguments
you do get into fights you do get into
disagreements right because what's a
relationship if you're not taking two
people who don't know anything about
each other slapping them together and
saying now make it work basically what
it is so of course you're going to have
some disagreements and so on and so
forth but the various issues that Amber
and Mark have been dealing with a lot of
it came from Mark deception right in the
sense that Mark didn't really tell her
he was a superhero initially he would
just disappear for huge amounts of time
and then return home and she'll just be
there with open arms that in effect she
would kind of put her life on hold to a
degree and so far as like what it means
to have a significant other because of a
superhero escapades we don't know if
that's something that she can cope with
Adam Eve is far more of a compatible
person for Mark than Amber is at least
on that level but Mark kind of counters
that and he says yeah but like we have a
lot in common there's a lot of things
that we like but one of the things to
know about relationships that 1% makes
all the difference you can find somebody
who's
99.9% compatible with you but depending
on what that 0.1% makes up it could be a
deal breaker right like it's like that
like that 0.1% could be I don't want to
have kids and that right there totally
tortures the relationship right you're
your deal breakers and so it's kind of
an interesting thing there because you
end up having uh Mark who really kind of
gets a phone call here uh while he and
Adam Eve and and Amber are hanging out
and it's just kind of like Mark help
right she's in trouble Mark how fast can
you get home like it's his mom and then
somebody somebody basically answers
alongside his mom and Mark bolts he's
just like Eve can you get Amber home and
she's like yeah he's like okay cool got
to go bam and then just bolts right just
like immediately takes off when he gets
back home he's met with angstrom Levy
now angstrom Levy is a character that we
haven't really talked about yet right
and he was kind of covered a little bit
in the previous stories that we did and
all honesty I didn't cover him at the
time because I didn't want to mess up
the pacing of the story to kind of have
this this cohesive discussion about what
happened to omn man after he left Earth
and then suddenly sidetracked to
angstrom Levy but the behind this is
that at a previous point in time
angstrom Levy had actually come into
contact with an alternate reality
version of himself and the reason why is
because angstrom can make portals to
different dimensions and so what he
wanted to do or at least kind of look to
to bolster his abilities and so on and
so forth that he ended up having himself
hooked to a kind of machine of sorts by
the merer twins the problem with this is
that when Invincible showed up that
angstrom Levy started summoning all
these mer twins from other dimensions
and then Mark was actually on the verge
of being killed right being Beat to
Death and so angstrom took the harness
off his head and it created a kind of
feedback where it basically turned him
into the version of himself that you see
now but angstrom is a wildly powerful
character it's one of these things where
his powers are kind of unique in that
way right I mean it's not as always
powerful because he can just look at
Mark and disintegrate him or like beat
him to death because of his astronomical
strength it's just one of these things
where he can just kind of open portals
and that's what he tells Mark right you
know ultimately the whole reason why he
comes after Mark for this is because one
the whole experiment or the whole you
know kind of situation that led him to
becoming who he was It ultimately kind
of erased portions of the entire
incident so he doesn't really remember
things as they happened instead all he
really remembers are kind of is kind of
like the big picture of the big picture
the big chunks but missing the nuance
and so it's you know I was a regular guy
and then Invincible showed up and then
Invincible face off against the merer
twins that I brought from other
dimensions and then like something
happened and then now I'm like this
right so Invincible cause this when Mark
goes to attack him he opens a portal and
then sends Mark to a different dimension
where dinosaurs have more or less become
sentient where they can actually talk
and he escapes by the skin of his teeth
and then comes back through the portal
again again and then goes to attack him
uh yet again and then like another
Portal's opened up and he ends up in the
Marvel Universe and then he actually
encounters Dr Octopus and like crashes
him into a building and he's like oh
dude man I'm so sorry about that and
then bailed right like for one page he
meets he meets Dr Octopus right so then
he comes back to the portal again only
this time the webbing of Spider-Man
follows him right so hence the title
Invincible meets Spider-Man for like 2
seconds like it's it's kind of nuts but
it's small little stuff like this one
thing that I do want to point out here
this concept of like alternate
dimensions that's something that I want
you guys to keep in the back of your
head but it's kind of this cat and mouse
game right Mark is fighting out of
emotion he's not fighting out of logic
and remember that's one of the lessons
that his dad was trying to teach him you
cannot fight emotionally you have to
fight logically whenever you fight
emotionally you're going to make just
ridiculous decisions and it's one of the
things that angstrom Lev is counting on
right I remember Mark is Young right
he's a college Age kid but at the same
time he doesn't really have the
experience to know what kind of rational
decisions he should be making and so
it's one of these things where he goes
to attack yet again because angstrom
knows like the more that the the the
angrier that Mark gets the more Reckless
he gets and the more Reckless he gets
the less he thinks and so it's one of
these things where he just kind of
playing games with him and so he sends
him into a dimension where there was a
Zombie Breakout right and like everybody
in that world was essentially infected
by zombies and it happens like that over
and over and over again every time he
goes to attack he's sent to a different
dimension now he's he's he's beaten he's
not necessarily broken he's kind of
tattered he comes across Batman like
literally he's like he's like I mean you
dress like a bat and your name's what
like isn't that kind of lazy
isn't it lazy to dress as a bat and call
yourself Batman like kind of a lazy name
and so it's one of these these sort of
weird things where like he finally just
kind of sits and waits and then
eventually a portal opens up and
angstrom scks his head through and then
he immediately goes to the portal right
and then goes to attack angstrom Levy
again and then yet again angstrom Levy
opens a portal and the two of them
actually end up fighting through these
kind of like dimensional waves right
like like literally fighting throughout
the Multiverse that's basically what's
happening here they're jumping from
Universe to universe and and the fight's
just the two of them until it gets to a
point where Mark basically gets the
upper hand and gets so mad that anman
threatened his family that he actually
beats him to death this is really the
first big moment where the actions of
Mark just cost a person their life in
Extreme Rage right where he remembers
himself he he kind of thinks about his
dad right like he he like literally
reminds himself of his dad and so in
that moment there's a huge kind of
crushing sensation here because it's
like oh my God I'm like my dad I've
basically become my dad like this is
this is the person that I've turned into
and so what you end up having is a
portal that opens up and essentially the
Guardians of the globe end up popping
out but it's a future version of their
characters including Adam Eve now the
conversation here is not overly lengthy
instead what it happened is that in the
the main Universe right the main
dimension of invincible that Mark had
just vanished right so as far as he's
concerned it's it's been virtually no
time at all right within within like a
few hours right all this stuff's gone on
for him for these Guardians of the globe
they've been hunting for Mark for 15
years they've been trying to find him
for 15 years and they were finally able
to Lo locate him right like they were
finally able to pick him up now it's one
of these things where Adam Eve goes
running to Mark and says okay here's
what you have to do go talk to the
younger version of me and tell her
anything right tell her you love her
tell her you don't love her tell her you
just want to be good friends whatever
but if you never ever tell her how you
potentially feel about her she's going
to forever hold on to this this
possibility that the two of you will end
up being together she'll never have
anybody else she'll never really be able
to live a meaningful life because she
will always hope that the two of you are
going to get together so tell her
whatever it is you need to tell her like
tell tell her whether whether you love
her or not it doesn't matter but tell
her something and so that's kind of the
crazy thing is because this sort of sets
the stage on what we saw in this issue
that Amber is not the best fit for Mark
that Adam Eve is and it's going to
seemingly at least it kind of appears to
go in that direction of Mark possibly
saying something to Adam Eve whether he
does or not is something that I'm not
going to reveal to you at least not now
anyway following that you end up having
essentially a person associated with
Cecil who actually shows up to the house
of Deborah to kind of get things
organized and so far as like the the
little boy the little little kid that
kind of was brought here by Mark and so
when the question is asked like have you
decided on a name the response is Oliver
right like I'm going to name this kid
Oliver it's my father's name like Mark's
mom is effectively adopting the the step
brother of Mark and the son of omn man
right he's officially going to be kind
of brought into the family there and so
following this what you do is you
actually pick up with Mark going and
visiting the Taylor right you guys like
you guys know him Arthur rosenbom but
it's one of these things where the two
of them are kind of talking and and
having a conversation and Mark's
actually coming to terms with this this
idea of the fact that he had basically a
man to death right and he's coming to
terms with a look on on Adam Eve's face
from the future when she said she loved
him right just desperation and sorrow as
he describes it he's kind of like I mean
Adam Eve is my friend you know and and I
like her you know I'm attracted to her
but like at the end of the day if I did
that it wouldn't really be fair to Amber
and he says he loves Amber but here's
the important thing to understand the
heart wants what the heart wants and no
apologies need to be made for it right
that's just the way that it is I mean in
the in the Game of Love somebody's bound
to get their heart broken right it's
just it's the nature of things if
everybody returns turn the affections of
everybody who made advances towards them
then monogamy just couldn't exist right
so in order to fall in love hearts have
to be broken it's just the way that goes
it sucks and it's not fair but honestly
the world's not necessarily a fair place
and so the so ultimately it's kind of
like what are you going to do and so
he's just kind of like I'm going to stay
with Amber at the moment right like
Amber's the one that I'm going to stay
with because she's just been so
supportive of me right I mean like all
these superhero Antics disappearing for
days or even months or weeks at a time
you know like all the stuff that comes
with this package of what it means to be
with somebody like me she been through
it right she's been you know I wouldn't
say thick and thin they haven't been
been together long enough to really know
but he's just kind of like you know
she's been there for me and I feel like
it' be wrong to betray that to destroy
that and then to go with somebody else
because a future version of herself said
hey like I really love you right you
know just because a person says they
love you doesn't mean you have to love
them back and so ultimately the Taylor
kind of goes to a back room and then
comes back and presents Mark with these
books now these books are ridiculously
important and the reason why is because
when they're presented to Mark Mark's
just kind of like I mean what like what
is this and and you know the Taylor's
like well your father was a would like
try to be a science fiction writer when
he first got here and he wrote a little
bit and he made a little bit of money
but after that they were all just
basically huge failures right so he just
started writing like travel books and
different things like that and so
ultimately these are all handed over to
Mark and Mark starts looking at him and
says like I mean like look at the names
these names are terrible right hate
tribes on the planet wreck right this
one the man with the Invincible gun and
so he kind of starts coming through it
and reading it and as Mark begins to
read it he begins to realize his
father's books right when the last video
when his dad said find my books and read
my books it wasn't because he just
wanted his son to know that he tried to
write science fiction at some point he's
actually going through and Mark realizes
he's writing himself that literally he's
just writing his own stories about
tracking down individuals and hunting
people who were basically enemies of the
vure Empire but each one of these books
deals with like an artifact or a weapon
or a person with extraordinary skills
and that's when Mark starts to realize
all these things they're basically
instructions on how to destroy the vter
it's literally a blueprint on how to
win what's going on guys this is Rob and
we are back with Invincible now here's
the thing I am trying my best to avoid
spoilers in the
titles I'm absolutely doing the best
that I can to avoid spoilers granted
having spoilers is part of the super
clickbait title scheme but I'm avoiding
it for invincible because I don't want
to ruin anything for you guys uh so this
story does technically kick off with
Sinclair a lot of you guys remember him
from the TV show where he was basically
uh making killer Rob out of people the
way it plays out in the comics is almost
identical to the way it plays out in the
show it just happens at a different
point in time right like this point
where where all the robot show up and
people are being transformed all that
kind of stuff that was a plot thread
that was kind of being built on over the
course of the comics in the time that
omn man was on earth when like the great
big huge event happens and like
Invincible learns that like these guys
are being turned into robots that
happens after omn man lead so again just
kind of a little bit of a difference
between the show and the comics it
doesn't screw up the continuity because
one of the cool things about Invincible
is you do have like the main story and
then you have like little smaller plot
thread stories that kind of go kind of
take place over the course of the the
comic itself right but what we end up
doing here you know once Sinclair's
caught thrown in prison he's met by uh
Cecil right and Cecil's kind of like
okay like if you accept our our offer
that we're going to give you you will
not go to jail right you won't face any
kind of a Char any charges you won't
have a criminal record or anything like
that like you'll work for us right so a
lot of you guys are kind of familiar
with that already but what you're not
familiar with is when we switch over to
Allen the alien now here's the cool
thing Allen the alien is on the planet
this referred to as Tesa which is the
home of the Coalition of planets we'll
talk a little bit more about them as we
kind of get further into the comic book
story but what you end up doing here is
picking up with thus right now thus of
course meets with Allen and then kind of
has this conversation with him about how
Allen's kind of growing and becoming
stronger and again that's the nature of
the character of Allen right we talked
about that before that the way his
character was portrayed is that
initially he was like an experiment an
attempt to create a race or to
genetically modify a race that would
basically put them on par with the vites
in terms of strength and durability the
issue with this is that while Allen was
super strong there was nothing to
indicate he was on the same level as the
vites but what we're learning here is
that as time progresses specifically in
the aftermath of a battle and when he
heals that Allen's strength level right
now is close to that of a vmite if it's
not directly on par with the vro now
we're not really given an absolute
answer here the explanation that we're
given is that they're actually doing
more tests and they're kind of exploring
a little bit more to see where he's at
but by all standards of measurement he's
equal to the vites and so while it's not
necessarily a full Army it is certainly
a winning move the funny thing about
this is the the question that Allan has
is how could you possibly know all this
information about the vites were you
getting all this information from and a
lot of it's just kind of chocked up to
the fact that that it's the Coalition of
Worlds right it's the Coalition of
planets they have just information all
over the place instead what thus reveals
is that he's actually a viltrumite right
the thus was essentially the first of
the vites to rebel against the empire to
turn against them and to defect now
there is a much more significant story
to thus than what we're given here but
essentially he just kind of establishes
that he founded the Coalition of planets
to defend the universe against the evils
of his own people right to basically
face off against the vites and to to
really kind of slow them down as best he
could and a lot of that's rooted in the
fact that he realized given the strength
of the vites you can't really kill them
per se or at least there was nobody else
in the universe that seem to be on the
the same level in capabilities as being
able to kill the vites right they're
just far too strong and far too capable
but for the longest time thus thought he
was the only person that was really able
to stand against the vites outside of
those individuals who were executed
right because he wasn't the only one
there were individuals who rebelled
along with him but in the end they were
all more or less killed and so the
question is was there anybody else
capable of doing that and then Allen the
alien showed up with the story of
invincible and that's what he realizes
even if omn man is kind of defected and
more or less taken up his role on a
different world in the end both omn man
and Invincible can be swayed to the side
of the Coalition of Worlds and
essentially they can have a few vites on
their side is it enough to win the war
well honestly we'll have to wait until
we get to the Vite War Story in order to
find out but one of the cool things that
goes on here is you get this cool moment
when you have Amber talking to her
friends now one of the things we've kind
of discussed here is the relationship
between Amber and Mark has largely been
on the Rocks mostly because of the fact
and and really only because of the fact
that with Mark being invincible and
effectively being a guy who's a
superhero and he's really the the first
line of defense in protecting the world
from the various threats that are there
that there's not really a whole lot of
time for a relationship and this really
comes into fruition of the fact that
he's always blowing her off they're
always out on dates and stuff like that
then he just gets up and leaves in the
middle of it all the reality is despite
the role that Mark plays and while his
role as a superhero is in truth more
important than the relationship he has
with Amber she's feeling that lack of
importance and unlike Debbie who of
course Mark's mom and the the wife of
omn man that Amber can't really cope
with it right she one of these things
where she's just kind of like I mean
yeah like talking to her friends like
I'm in love with Mark I care about Mark
but the reality is she's been spending
time with a friend of hers named Gary
now Gary is is a guy that she just kind
of throws away right she's like she's
just he's a guy that I know yeah he's
funny but like at the end of the day
like I'm in love with Mark right I'm not
going to cheat on Mark I'm not stepping
out on him you know just to kind of get
with this guy Gary because you guys see
twinkles in my eyes and you guys have
never met Mark and you guys don't really
understand why that kind of a thing but
the reality of this and this is what's
kind of ironic is you have this kind of
situation where you kind of have to look
at Mark for what he is right you have to
look at him for for the role that he
plays and the sense that you know the
when the two when Mark kind of shows up
out of nowhere and even when her friends
are kind of talking to her about that
the reality is you kind of always have
to ask yourself the question like what
does this person bring to my life that
makes them worthwhile and at the same
time like what would my life look like
if I didn't have have them and it's an
important thing to understand with Mark
because of the role that he plays and
because of the power he has and his
place in society the reality is his life
would not be bad without Amber right
it's just kind of one of these things
where it's look you look around it's
like what would I lose if I didn't have
you I would wouldn't lose anything so I
mean you can stay if you want to or go
if you want to in all honesty I don't
really care and and that lack of concern
I mean Mark does care about her but that
lack of concern which is really
evidenced by the fact that he just takes
off because he has some mission to go on
or something like that is enough to kill
the relationship the real question to
ask is doesn't matter if it dies and
that's that's really the ultimate
question when it comes to any
relationship that you're in If this
relationship dies doesn't matter and if
the answer to that question is no well
then that's only a reflection of one of
two things either it means that you've
more or less got your life sorted out
and relationships are just not a
necessity for you which is perfectly
fine there are people that find a
measure of happiness in their life by
just traveling around and just doing
things on their own or it may be that
you just don't need to be in a
relationship because you just don't care
about people so it really kind of
depends on the situation it is a little
more nuanced than that but it really
kind of depends on the situation but one
of the other big things that kind of
goes on here is we actually transition
to Mars and this is one of the big
talking points here one of the big
moments which was the squids a lot of
you guys remember them just kind of
these little squid looking things with
brains they basically conquered Mars or
or kind of escaped and took over Mars
but we basically had this situation
where in effect the SE quids have more
or less kind of taken over everything
right they just sort of spread all
throughout all over the place and are
kind of forcing the uh martians to their
will right now there is a a way in which
this works and the the whole idea behind
this squids is pretty cool here but one
of the things that happens is you
basically switch over to the Martian
himself now for those you guys who don't
really recall this the way it played out
is the the astronaut that you see who's
basically covered in the the sequence
that's actually Russ Russ Livingston the
guy you see who initially was portraying
Russ Livingston on Earth that's the
Martian he's basically a shape shifter
he calls himself the shapes Smith which
is a pretty cool name if I'm being
honest with you guys it's a pretty
badass name but the reality of this is
he's kind of made a little bit of a home
for himself among the Guardians of the
globe right and that's one of the funny
things about the Guardians is they are
they seem to be far less Discerning than
traditional superhero teams if this was
the Justice League they would be like
dude we don't know you right we're just
not going to let you on the team like
that's ridiculous now some of this also
has to do with the fact that the
Guardians of the globe are kind of
desperate they need as much help as they
can get right because they're kind of
reforming you also get a cool moment
where like the immortal is mer duplicate
kind of a little bit of a side plot that
was going on is the two of them were
just kind of together for a little while
it pissed off Rex Spode when he walked
in and found duplicate banging The
Immortal and it's like what did you
expect man right this guy is like he's
got experience he's been around for a
while you're like an immature prick what
did you think was going to happen man
but the cool thing is that you kind of
end up having shap Smith who who who's
kind of here and everybody's sort of
talking and then ultimately he just sort
of reveals himself to Cecil right
because cil's basically talking about
how like long range sensors and things
like that are indicating that like a
ship or some kind of a vehicle is headed
straight for them and is coming from
Mars now while that's going on you
actually have Mark after his
conversation with Amber who takes over
takes off to Africa meets with Adam Eve
and then while the two of them are kind
of talking bow he kisses her right so
it's just like he doesn't quite know how
to interpret that right like how do I
interpret the fact that I just basically
made out with like this smoking hot
redheaded girl who I basically kind of
like but not am not really willing to
admit it and so it's kind of cool to see
that little bit of a romance blossoming
there kind of coming off the heels of
Mark's previous experience when he was
jumping through the future and talking
to these these various iterations of Eve
but then you basically have you know
again kind of jumping back to Cecil and
them shapes Smith is just kind of like
okay so like I really need to be honest
with you guys um I didn't get these
powers that I have from like an
unauthorized NASA experiment uh
basically I have these these Powers
because everybody on my planet has them
I'm from Mars and cil's like what but
how can Cecil be mad Cecil's probably
the most inept government official ever
right Cecil sucks at his job and I feel
like a simple phone call would have like
confirmed this guy was lying through his
teeth you know like Cecil's terrible at
his job he's
awful but nonetheless he's pissed
because he's like okay and I think more
of it's like he's pissed at himself but
nonetheless we basically end up getting
this explanation from shape Smith where
he talks about the nature of the sequit
and what he basically says is that at
some point along the line at least a
story that's been told year over year
among the Martians especially for the
younger kids so they're kind of aware of
that history and Legacy is that you
ended up having this race that kind of
Crash landed on Mars and that a massive
war broke out that lasted you know
nearly a century ultimately the Martians
came out on top only for them to realize
you know as the battle sort of went on
that the conflict was not really with
this alien race but it was actually with
the seids that the squids themselves are
really more of just like you know the
this this kind of hive mind but not
really capable of anything beyond just
simple movements and simple chores and
and and you know different things like
that right simple tasks but when they
bond to a host they're capable of so
much more and that's when they realize
like the main enemies is the sequins
like these aliens these blue aliens that
showed up they were just the host for
the sequence now the desire is to expand
themselves Across the Universe and to
conquer world after world so not that
different from the vites just going
about it by a different means but
because of the nature of the Martians
the sequence couldn't bond to them and
so what the Martians did in is they
actually used them as more or less a
slave Force the problem with this is
that the powers that be right the the
more or less government of the Martian
group was actually going through and
experimenting on them performing these
heinous acts experimenting on the seids
different things like that which in turn
the kind of rebels out there who had a
sort of disdain for this realized it
would lead to nothing but animosity
because if the seids after all this
experimentation and all these kind of
heinous uh things that were done to them
if they successfully bonded themselves
to a host it would be Revenge time and
that's exactly what happened the NASA
Mission came to Mars and anybody out
there who basically arrives on Mars and
is a potential host of the seids is
immediately executed hence the reason
why the the astronauts were going to be
killed But ultimately what ended up
happening is the rebels realized the
astronauts were there and they basically
forced or took Russ and exposed him to
the seids and then in turn uh shapes
Smith took the place of Russ and then
came back to Earth and the idea behind
this is that the seids would basically
allow the rebels to kind of cast off the
government and the hopes is not
necessarily they would live in unity but
that the the seids would realize what
the rebels had done and then in turn say
okay fine we'll spare your world and
then just sort of move on that's not
what's going to happen and in fact
Cecil's pissed he's like wait a minute
so you left an American citizen to be
attacked by parasites on Mars like
that's what you did here really man like
that's that's that's your whole thing
okay like I'll do with you later I need
to make some phone calls and so
ultimately you end up having Mark and
Adam Eve who show up to the Guardians of
the globe base of operations being
summoned there by Cecil and C's like
okay so like we're all basically going
to get together right like we're going
to like we're going to go to Mars the
only ones who are basically going to
stay behind are going to be reow
duplicate and shrinking Ray which is
kind of funny cuz shrinking Ray is like
man I get sidelined but it's like look
man I mean all you can do is shrink
right I mean they'll find you anyway
right they'll seek you out I mean
there's not a whole lot you can do but
basically you get robot monster girl The
Immortal bulletproof and black Samson
who all end up going out there for this
mission right and of course you end up
having uh Immortal and and Adam Eve who
go there as well now while this goes on
you have Mark who leaves a message for
Amber and it's just being like super
super ambiguous right like you know
there's nothing I can do Amber I have to
go Amber Amber right there's there's you
know they need me and like ultimately
she's pissed off because she got a call
yet again from Mark that like he's going
to blow her off I mean the reality is
even if Mark really is a superhero he's
kind of being a dick and so ultimately
Amber does exactly what you would expect
in the most predictable way ever and she
calls Gary as quote unquote a shoulder
to cry on now let me tell you something
guys any woman out there who's having
struggles with her boyfriend and then
calls up another guy and says like I
just need a shoulder to cry on they're
probably going to end up banging that's
just the way it goes right that's just
that's just the way it is is and so
ultimately you end up having this this
kind of crazy thing where once they're
on their way to Mars the questions kind
of asked like what weapons do we have on
this ship because we are getting ready
to fly towards like a like literally a
giant spaceship that's making its way to
Earth with the intention of conquering
it and it's like dude this is a space
shuttle man this thing is literally the
equivalent of like a space version of a
city bus there's no weapons here man
when was the last time that you saw like
laser beams on the side of a city bus
although admittedly that'd be cool as
hell man like imagine if like kilder had
laser beams on it that would be nuts
nonetheless like rockets get fired the
ship blows up Kate saves everybody right
like literally just creates a forest
field and saves everybody this is kind
of a cool moment but you also get a
little realism here one of the big
questions you always had to ask whenever
like the Green Lanterns were like okay
guys we're going to fly to the other
side of the known universe let's all
make our green bubbles and just go there
is like what do they do for oxygen and
like literally you literally people in
there are like we can't breathe we're
running out of
air so I love that little bit of realism
that goes on there because it's like I
mean this is a great idea but like we
need air to breathe and there's no air
in space and we're running out of air
here so uh we need to do something now
of course they end up getting aboard the
ship but as soon as they do you kind of
have the rebels who are in the engine
room trying to find some way to overcome
this whole situation now ultimately one
of the guys are just kind of like hey I
found a squid like they smash it and
it's like no they have a hive mind
they're all going to know you're here
now right like if you'd left it alone it
wouldn't have known but now that you've
done something they're all like they're
all going to know and literally they all
just come po in in and so at that point
there's a few things that go on that I
kind of want to talk about here the
first is that back on Earth you ended up
having this kind of crazy lizard
organization right just these crazy guys
they're more or less modeled after the
serpent Society from the Captain America
comics but they've more or less taken
control of like a nuclear base with the
intent of just unleashing absolute hell
and just kind of showing that like
they're they're a force to be reckoned
with and so you end up having like those
who are left behind right so like recode
duplicate shrinking Ray who all
basically you know kind of jump into the
attack and and take these guys out
duplicate is just totally obliterated
right like duplicates killed and she's
she's just like smashed and ripped to
pieces right like all the versions of
her are just like ripped apart just
killed and so duplicates gone right
after that like Rex Spode gets shot in
the head he survives but he gets shot in
the head and it's just kind of like damn
right now more or less the the days kind
of Saved after that minus a death of
duplicate which you know I guess maybe
it's kind of you know crappy of me to
kind of skim over her death but I mean
you know come on a girl that can make
copies of herself not the most
impressive character ever in the history
of comic books I'm just saying she's
hardly relevant to the story but
nonetheless as far as everybody else
goes right back in space that while Adam
Eve is doing everything she can to hold
this force field and you've got robot
who essentially managed to find a way to
temporarily disrupt the hive mind of the
uh of the sequence it only lasted for a
minute or two and so what he's more or
less doing is trying to work on a way to
actually amplify it and to make it more
powerful so we can shut them all down
for quite some time right just knock
them out as opposed to just kind of Da
them and just kind of shocked them like
man what was that right that kind of a
thing the problem is that Adam Eve can't
quite hold her power in the way that she
needs to in order to keep everybody
protected now this is simply just the
learning process right this is one of
the ways in which for those you guys who
are unfamiliar with Comics this is how
you see characters grow right that their
powers are usually pushed in extreme
situations whether it's agility or
something like that or in the case of
Adam Eve trying to hold up a I guess a
molecularly structured force field as
long as you possibly can her powers just
aren't quite on that level yet to do it
for a lengthy meaningful amount of time
and so what you end up getting here is
kind of Russ Livingston just kind of
going nuts and rambling about how like
they can't be stopped you know and
they're Ultra powerful and they're going
to conquer all of known existence and so
on you know so on and so forth like you
end up having Immortal who sort of jumps
into The Fray and starts you know
literally going against this guy as best
he can as well as like all the different
SE quids who were there and then shap
Smith has this genius idea right where
he's like okay if we have to protect
this guy then I'll just cover everybody
and that's what he does he basically
covers the covers robot literally as
best he can because he cannot be
infected by the by the sequence right he
can't be turned he can't be forced into
one of their own and so he literally
just forms a giant ball around this guy
while everybody else fights the squids
off and then suddenly he hears robot
basically saying like I've done it I've
fixed it and so initially Immortal takes
it to go and use it but the biggest
problem Immortal has and it's one of the
things that Invincible seems to hit up
on his ego seems to come into play that
Immortal is an exceedingly proud
character a lot of it's because he sees
himself as somebody who's been around
for a very long time the guy who is the
leader of the Guardians of the globe in
his previous form therefore he should be
the leader now but the truth about this
and Mark makes a good point he's like
I'm faster than you I'm stronger than
you this is too important for your ego
to get in the way the reality is that if
anybody should be doing this it should
be me and so ultimately because of the
fact that that Invincible can move
faster than the squids can counter which
Immortal doesn't seem to be on that
level he just runs up on Russ Livingston
and activates the beacon and all the
seids get knocked out from there he
basically snatches up Russ and it's just
kind of like okay cool we've basically
saved the day these guys are knocked out
there's no more host so they're just
going to go back to doing you know uh
regular meaningless tasks according to
you know the the Martian Empire and
that'll more or less be it but the
problem is the Martians don't want to
let shape Smith go because at the end of
the day he more or less is the one that
caused all this right he's the reason
why all this happened when he body
swapped with Russ Livingston and allowed
Russ Livingston to be taken over by the
sequit the problem is that they're going
to execute him and so like the Guardians
are just like no that ain't going to
happen so they basically snatch him up
and just fly into space as fast as they
can they take off as quick as they
possibly can now one of the other things
that kind of goes on here you kind of
get a little bit of followup to some of
the things that we've seen over the
course of the story so far and so one of
the first things that happens here is
you basically have Mark and everybody
getting back to Earth and you have a
little bit of a discussion between Adam
Eve and Mark and they don't really know
where this is going in so far as the
fact that they kiss do they have
feelings for each other Mark isn't
really sure he's just kind of like I
don't know if I really have feelings for
at all and even if he does there's a few
things he needs to resolve and then he
gets to Amber's place and Gary's in
there right like Gary's in her room and
and like he's overhearing this
conversation they're having where he's
like I mean you know it was it was a
good movie Amber you know I had a great
time you know and that's the thing she's
like well I mean it was cool but like I
have a boyfriend and then Gary plays a
smart move right I hear about your
boyfriend a lot like where you know
where is he where EXA exactly is your
boyfriend at and she's like well I don't
really know and he's like and where am I
and she's like you're here right like
you're right here now under normal
circumstances that never would have
worked right she like she would have she
would have been like man come on and
like probably would have kicked him out
but giving the vulnerable position that
she's in it works right like he's able
to pull it off Gary read her like a book
and was just kind of like bam right like
like as as soon as as soon as like she
says like you're here and he touches her
hand boom he's in right like that door
it's it's not a foot in the door anymore
right that door's that door's blown wide
open blown off the hinges right like
guess that guy is going to be nailing
Amber in no time and so so Marx just
kind of like okay right seeing this
whole thing unfold he actually does
really what he should do here right
which is going to her and saying look
like it's over right like I mean there
there's no reason for us to date anymore
now he kind of falls on his sword here
which I don't really agree with where
he's kind of like you know I mean you
know I really haven't been the best
boyfriend which is true he hasn't really
been a been a great boyfriend or
anything like that but the reality is
people date according to their station
in life and the truth about this is that
Mark dating Amber that ain't going to
work because Amber just is she's not on
Mark's level right I mean mark literally
a protector of the world he's he's got
all these capabilities going for him
Adam Eve is a much better match for Mark
than Amber is right because Adam Eve is
on Mark's level actually she's a little
higher than him because she's more
powerful than he is but nonetheless
right I mean like she is she's more or
less equal to him on a societal level
and so that's why that's why it's going
to work right that's why like it's kind
of like those two need to be the ones
who get together Amber you know
ultimately when he tells her everything
that it's just kind of like I mean it
was cool when we first got together and
I first told you I was invincible and
then you were like yeah I'm banging a
superhero right like it was kind of cool
and everything but now that we're really
in the thick of it right and we're kind
of at that point where it's like where's
this really going right you know
ultimately it's like I can't be the kind
of boyfriend that you need honestly cuz
I got more important things to worry
about and so ultimately you know that
like he breaks up with her and she's
kind of like yeah I mean I was going to
break up with you but I'm glad you did
it first you know so like ultimately
they just kind of stay friends and they
go their separate ways and you kind of
have this little bit of a of a Mourning
moment with the immortal where he loses
duplicate now this is a big thing like
after they've had the whole funeral for
duplicate with the immortal it sucks
right and this is actually a great
moment for his character because the
immortal has been around for a long long
time and it's one of these things where
he and it almost kind of contrasts
what's going on with Mark right in the
sense that with the immortal having this
conversation and just kind of like yeah
you know like it's nothing that I
haven't been through before you know
it's it's it's nothing that I'm not used
to at the end it's just like you know
she was she was so young right and and I
didn't know that I'd lose her so soon
and that's kind of the crazy thing is an
expectation The Immortal has lived for a
pretty lengthy amount of time and he's
been in love and he's lost them often
times he's had to outlive them different
things like that but at the end of the
day duplicate was young and and despite
the fact that he's been through this
time and time again he was genuinely in
love with her and he was hoping that
even though he would ultimately outlive
her presumably outlive her assuming that
her power kept her for didn't keep her
from aging that at the end of the day
they'd have a pretty long and healthy
life together likely having kids
different things like that and then
suddenly she was gone Not only was she
gone he wasn't there he wasn't there to
protect her he wasn't there to to keep
her safe and so it's kind of a crazy
situation because it's like you know
there's a lot of regret there a lot of
things that he wish he'd done with
regards to to do replicate now the truth
is they hadn't been together for all
that long and so there wasn't really a
whole lot of time for for him to have
been able to do those things in the
first place so the reality is it's more
or less him just kind of Desiring and
mourning the future they could have had
as opposed to the time they had which
the future they could have had could
have been SP could have been fantastic
as so following that you basically pick
up with Russ Livingston returning home
and his life is more or less going back
to normal to a degree in the sense that
he was offered his old job back at Nasa
different things along those lines after
going through some testing and and so on
and so forth he's kind of able to turn
back to return back to normal but as
soon as he gets home he starts coughing
like crazy and the reason for this is he
starts coughing up squids they literally
embedded themselves inside of his body
they bond themselves to to Russ and
they're like it's only a matter of time
before we conquer the
world certainly the most cing in Corny
ending ever to a comic but amazing
nonetheless what's going on guys this is
Rob we're back with Invincible yes we
are and where the last video that we did
was kind of it was okay for what it was
this one's a lot more interesting right
this is a lot more intriguing as one of
the funny things about Invincible is
once it kind of starts to build and then
you get in like the post omn man era
there's like one or two stories where
things are a little murky and then it
just takes off right like I've been
saying especially when you get to the
vmite war that's when things are super
cool right but there's a couple things
that go on here and one of the things
that I want to talk about is kind of the
aftermath of everything that happened
with omn man and one of the things that
plays out here is that with Mark
continuing its role as a superhero that
that's kind of out there doing his thing
and because the whole surveillance
footage of Mark and omn man was leaked
basically the world being aware of the
fact that Mark is the son of omn man
then in turn it's kind of like this
press conference that's that that's
basically done here and as one of the
things where one part of it is
information gathering right the Public's
just curious but the other part is the
Public's a little bit scared right
because like a man tried to conquer the
world and his son is still here they
don't know what the deal is they don't
really know what's going on and so Mark
kind of being out here and in talking
about what his dad did the fact that omn
man was really here for the purpose of
Conquering the world the power he
possessed things like like that it's
really more of just trying to kind of
trying to reassure the public and simply
saying like I'm doing this because I
believe I'm doing the right thing now
while the public is coming at it from
two directions so is Mark the first part
is really Mark just kind of being a good
guy here and just saying look like this
is really where I'm coming from but the
second is because as most of you guys
know fear gives way to terrible things
and human beings are nothing if not a
fearful race and so the response to the
fear of omn man and the threat he
represented would then turn into other
superheroes well can we trust them are
they inherently good people we have to
worry about them trying to conquer the
world and things along those lines so
Mark whether he knows it or not is kind
of doing double duty here and is really
kind of standing out in the front of the
general public and saying look like I'm
doing what I'm doing because I genuinely
believe it's the right thing and the
hope is that because of who he chooses
to associate himself with they're in the
same train of thought as well now we as
the reader know they are I mean the
Guardians of the globe really kind of
solidify that like not every hero out
there is there to attack people but like
the first thing a hysterical person says
is I'm not hysterical meaning people are
not inherently logical right we are
emotional first logical second and so
because of that it's one of these things
where you kind of have to approach it
from that perspective and it's smart for
Mark to do that the second thing that
goes on here and this is kind of a
little bit of a subplot in the sense
that Kirkman was kind of building up to
it and it's going to become something
more significant later on down the line
Mark's younger brothers developing
Powers which is awesome I we we kind of
knew it was only a matter of time the
insectoid race that his mother comes
from does not inherently have powers the
powers he's getting he inherited from
omn man right which is kind of a cool
thing to see and it's really Mark's
first time in seeing him being able to
fly the big concern here is that once
this Revelation is presented to Deborah
right at Mark's mom how is she going to
respond to it and when she learns that
essentially Omni kid is what we can kind
of call him because he basically learns
how to fly or at least demonstrates the
ability to fly then it turns into a kind
of conversation where it's this is
dangerous now this is kind of a funny
thing about this it it be very easy for
us to approach this from the perspective
that Mark's mom is just being
overprotective and she doesn't want her
son to become like omn man and because
she still struggles with him she's
basically projecting that onto her kid
that's not necessarily the the case here
one of the things that she kind of talks
about it's one of the things that's kind
of nied in the bud right off the bat
when Mark brings it up is she kind of
talks about how this this whole thing is
he's so young and while he is aging
pretty fast and he is intelligent at the
end of the day he's still a kid and what
kid who has powers or even what kid in
general under you know really really
grasps and understands what it means to
be in danger right like a kid running
out in the street to chase a ball that's
a perfect example of that and so because
kids usually just kind of ACT first and
then think second it's one of these
things where she kind of has to
safeguard it this is important because
it's really Deborah kind of looking at
this kid very much as her own child but
at the same time because Mark was older
and because Mark had his father to guide
him this kid doesn't necessarily have
that while Mark could offer some sort of
guidance here and in fact he will over
time the important thing is Mark is
still learning about himself and Mark's
still figuring his powers out Mark's not
nearly as confident or even as old and
experienced as his father was and so
because of that he can't quite bring
that kind of wisdom to the table and so
quite literally Mark and this kid are
essentially flying by the seat of their
pants now in the midst of all this as
you have a kind of conversation taking
place between the immortal and Cecil
Cecil essentially picks up on a kind of
projectile that's headed towards Earth
and appears to be sentient and that it
might be some kind of an attack now this
is really more of just kind of Cil sort
of figuring out or talking out loud as
he's learning about this but the
immortal takes it as gospel truth and
immediately goes and attacks only for us
to find out as Allen the alien now the
funny thing about this is we know Allen
the alien would crush the immortal and
not even by a little bit right it would
be an absolute devastating situation and
so in resp response to the immortal
taking off Mark's contacted and Mark
goes and tries to intervene which he
successfully does right he kind of gets
between the immortal and Allen the alien
and it's one of these things where marks
is kind of like okay look like I know
this whole telepathy thing only works
both ways so it's not as though like I'm
a conduit and you can talk to the
immortal through me or anything along
those lines it's one of these things
where Allen the alien seems to be able
to have the ability to pick and choose
who can hear his telepathic thoughts
which makes sense that's that's kind of
part for the course when it comes to
telepathy but he kind of talks to Mark
about hey here like I'm here to see you
I'm not really here to see the immortal
this guy just kind of freaked out and
attacked me and and Mark's like yeah man
he's kind of been through a lot and that
kind of a thing and so it's kind of
funny because when everything kind of
starts to calm down the immortal
apologizes and he's like I didn't hurt
you did I and Allan's like no not one
bit not even a little
bit don't worry man I'm not worried
about you hurting me like I promise I'll
be okay he doesn't really say it in so
many words but I mean come on right like
the immortal's cool and everything but
you know he's just not on the same level
right it's just it's just not there in
terms of the ability to take on even or
Allen the alien and so once they get
back to Mark's dorm room Mark kind of
spills the beans and so does Allen the
alien and that's one of the things where
Mark's basically told like I was
basically asked by by Thaddius the
leader of the Coalition of planets to
bring you back to Tesa right because you
and your father present the only real
known instances that we're aware of
outside of thus himself where a Vite has
defected from the Empire now with Mark
it's a little bit different of a
situation just because he was raised
along earthlings and so he wasn't really
indoctrinated full on into the Vite
ideology like his father was but it was
really kind of Kirkman sort of hitting
at the nature of people that yeah we
screw stuff up more than we get things
right but at the end of the day like
humanity is kind of infectious right
empathy different things like that and
it changed omn man and so really omn
man's a big talking point here right omn
man was a full-blown viline who lived
among the empire for decades and decades
and decades and hundreds and thousands
of years and so because of that the fact
that he defected the fact that he left
the Vite Empire and sided with with
earthlings and ultimately took on you
know took on a different planet instead
of just like setting Earth up to be
conquered was kind of mind-blowing and
it's something that we just didn't
really expect it's something that not
even the vites expected or even like
thus expected it's just it's one of
those things it's just unheard of when
you're a Vite you're a Vite right like
you follow the ideology and so Mark
actually presents uh Allen with the
books that his father Left Behind for
now in the last video we did we talked
about how these books were written by
omn man written by Nolan for the purpose
of basically lining out how to defeat
the vites right they were written under
the guise of like science fiction but
they were basically artifacts and
weapons that exist and while Allan's
experience in space and in escapades
across the universe is not is probably
not on the same level as thus and in
fact it actually is not he has enough
experience to know the things that are
written in this book they they're real
they exist right they're actual things
that exist out there now when the offer
is extended to Mark to join Allen on on
tesara Mark's like no that's not going
to happen right I've got too much going
on like I'm failing my classes I just
woke up with my girlfriend like my my
younger brother just developed Powers I
got things I need to focus on here and
it's one of these things where there's
not a whole lot of anim right it's not
as though alen the alien is like oh
you're coming to to Lea you know whether
I have to bring you conscious or
unconscious it's not necessarily like
that it's just one of those things where
it's kind of like okay you know like
I'll you it would be disappointing you
could make it but you know I'll let uh
I'll let Fus know that you didn't show
up here the other thing that happens is
that while Mark's hanging out with
William suddenly Eve comes busting in
and she's like so I heard that you're
single now are we going to bang or what
and like that's the woman you want man
that's the kind of girl you
want that's the kind of woman you want
man one who speaks her mind like that's
that's the kind you want right who tells
you what she's thinking you don't want
the kind of girls who like play games
and they expect you to figure stuff out
and things like that I don't have the
time or the energy for that that's the
kind of girl you want that's why I love
Mar one of the reasons why I love Mariah
so much but that's the thing you want
right like a girl who just tells you
what she's thinking but one of the
things that kind of goes on is like Adam
Eve just fullon reveals everything and
it really kind of talks about how her
interest in Mark went back quite some
way but at the time she was with Rex so
it was kind of one of those hey look I'm
not going to make a move on you while
I'm with somebody else and then
ultimately once Rex cheated on her then
like all bets were off right and she was
like okay like we're done and then she
started gunning for Mark but the crazy
thing was Mark ended up with Amber it
almost at exact same time and so they it
was one of those things where it was
just kind of like you know he was tied
up then she was tied up and then he was
tied up and so on and they just couldn't
quite get the Mark at the same time the
funny thing about this is Mark knew all
this right like Amber spilled the beans
on it all and and Adam Eve is just kind
of like I mean you already you already
knew all this and he's like yeah we know
Mark knew all this because he saw the
future version of Adam Eve and she
revealed the whole thing to him and so
he's kind of like yeah like I saw a
future version of of yourself you know
and and she'd been obsessed with me
right all these years because I never
really gave her an answer I never really
told her whether or not we were going to
get together I always kind of beat
around the bush never quite made time
for her or anything like that and that's
kind of how he knows and it's kind of a
funny thing you know because it's it's
almost like they treat that version of
Adam Eve as a totally different person
and so one of the things like with that
kind of big Revelation coming out she
sort of asked like are you are you ENT
are we entertaining this conversation
because you feel sorry for me because
you don't want me to become that old
lonely bitter version of myself is that
why all this is happening and Mark
doesn't I mean I guess he says no he's
like you know I don't I don't think I'm
doing that doing it for that reason and
that right there that lack of certainty
is enough to put Adam Eve on the path of
believing that's actually the case right
Mark's like this he's having this
conversation with her because he feels
bad for her and that's not what anybody
wants to hear right nobody wants to be
to to have like a pity party thrown for
them by somebody else right especially
when it comes to matters of the heart
and so because of that you kind of
switch over to Mark the next day
spending time with his mom right he was
kind of told that he's guaranteed to
fail his classes and honestly Mark just
considering dropping out of school
because he gets paid more working for
Cecil than he would ever have working a
real job and the reality is doesn't
really see a necessity for it the thing
that ends up happening though is he's
basically met by the arrival of a female
vilter now she will become very
important later on down the line for
reasons that are pretty screwed up and
people who are read Invincible are just
like yeah it's it was very screwed up it
was very messed up but like she becomes
important later on down the line right
the important thing that goes on here is
she basically threatens Mark with
killing his mom if Mark doesn't go with
her right so he ends up meeting her
about 2 miles up in about a minute and
they kind of have this bit of a
conversation and one of the things that
goes on here is is it's really her as a
Vite almost appealing to Mark's better
sense right in the in the idea of saying
like vites we as a race are not
inherently Desiring to destroy people
right we're looking to expand our Empire
but we're not inherently looking for
violence right we're not arbitrarily
violent we invoke violence when we need
to right violence is not always the
answer but it is a answer and it's a
very effective answer right violence
gets things done and so because of that
one of the things she kind of hits on
here is this world that you live in here
right this world you live on this this
world Earth home of humanity is plagued
by like illness and disease and violence
and like inequality and all that kind of
stuff like this world sucks and there's
literally no reason anybody of your
caliber should be here what are you
protecting right like what do you what
what are you saving these people from
right I mean you're not saving them from
anything tangible I mean sure there's a
few villains here and there but in the
grand scheme of your racist history
these villains won't really amount for
anything so you're saving Humanity for a
day and you're dooming it for a lifetime
so what what are you what are you
looking to save here like we as the vmes
from the other hand sure we'll conquer
this world but we'll also bring a level
of peace and prosperity it's never
experienced before we'll make it a
Utopia sure they'll lose their freedom
in the process but how valuable could
the freedom of humanity possibly be if
this is where their freedom brought them
to right to a world of inequality and
disease War violence like sure they have
freedom and they've used it to screw the
world up so we're going to take that
away right and and it's one of these
things where Mark is kind of like No And
this is the argument that we've had so
many times before on this YouTube
channel and it's one of those debates
that I love to have right like I mean I
guess the the benefit of freedom is that
it gives Humanity the ability to look at
its past mistakes and correct those
without the the Yoke of Oppression I
guess but Humanity in his current form
has been around for something like
200,000 years right I guess the age of
industrialization didn't really begin
until the 1800s the point that I'm
making here is we've had time so if we
were going to fix ourselves we would
have basically people don't want to and
so it's one of these things where it's
kind of like yeah like she's not NE
necessarily wrong right I mean you know
and that's that's what that's what makes
it so interesting is because Mark kind
of responds say so like the whole point
is you would be making slaves complacent
until you basically suck this planet
drive and the response of of her is I
mean yeah we're going to kind of destroy
the world but your Humanity will have a
few hundred years of peace and
prosperity on a level that they've never
experienced before and in turn maybe
they can make something out of
themselves maybe over the course of that
couple hundred years they can achieve
Interstellar travel who really knows but
whatever the case is yeah and so that's
that's why he's kind of interesting here
right because it's like on one hand you
have a free Society who has used that
freedom to make the world into a
cesspool and then on the other hand you
have somebody showing up who's saying
we're going to strip Freedom away from
society so they're going to live under
our authoritarian rule but you're also
going to have peace and prosperity in a
way that you've never had it before and
I know people will say well no Freedom's
most important but like I mean what are
you really getting out of it right like
I mean what like how is your life better
now and so it's it's it's kind of
interesting in that way right the
philosophical argument that goes into
that is pretty fantastic and it's and
it's really really cool and so
ultimately it's one of these things
where Mark's like okay fine then let's
see what you're about like if you tell
me that you really are compassionate
towards Humanity that you're not going
to be some abusive dictating race then
show me then show me what kind of a
person you are right like come with me
on superhero escapades now the the
reality of this is on one hand while
Mark doesn't necessarily say it it looks
like he's kind of done from the desire
to actually turn her to his cause right
to actually you know have the same
effect on her that Earth had on his
father the big difference is that Nolan
lived on Earth for years and it took
quite some time for it to get to that
point and even then by the time he got
to the final battle between Mark and
Nolan he still wasn't necessarily swayed
by Humanity as a whole it was his
relationship with his son that swayed
him towards basically abandoning Earth
and taking up residents on a different
planet instead one of the things to
understand here when it comes to Nolan
sure he left Earth and he didn't pave
the way for the vites to conquer it but
there was nothing about the conversation
he had with his son in that final battle
where it was Humanity has changed my
view I believe the Earth is a place to
save I'm going to stay here I'm going to
do everything I can to show that I'm
actually a good guy and when the vites
come which they will I'm going to fight
side by side with you and protect the
world no no no he was like leave this
world and come with me or help me
conquer this world right like it was
only because Mark loved his father so
much and vocalized that and the the the
relationship between Mark and his dad
that Nolan left earth right so that's an
important distinction to understand the
point that I'm making when I say that is
this girl's been here for 15 minutes
there's no way Mark's going to change
her
mind and that's exactly what happens
when she's just like so what do you say
are you going to work with us and he's
like no I'm still not convinced and
she's like fine this is not a
negotiation and just starts like starts
pummeling him right just absolutely
thrashes this guy and it's really kind
of designed to show again where Mark
resides with regards to the other vites
who are out there and so she essentially
tells him here's the deal right like you
have been deemed a failure of a
protector of this world in the name of
the Vite Empire you're part Vite which
means you operate under the service of
us and because of the fact that you have
essentially abandoned your post among
the vites and you're remaining on this
world standing against the empire a
replacement will be sent and when that
time comes either you can agree to stand
beside us and the replacement will be
recalled or you can continue to stand
against us and the replacement will kill
you and then get the world ready for
conquering for the vure might Empire
either way you got some period of time
and she doesn't give him a definitive
time frame she says it could be like 5
months or 5 years right it could be any
number of things but like a replacement
will be sent and so the the reality of
this is Mark kind of responds by like
okay I like I have to get ready for this
right I have to prep for this if this is
just one vomite and they're going to
send some kind of replacement after me
who may very well be as strong or
stronger than her that I have to be
ready for that right Mark is kind of
shown time and time again that while
he's got the fortitude and the desire to
face off against the vites at the end of
the day he doesn't have the same kind of
experience or the same strength level
they have and so he's got to beef
himself up right now while that goes on
Allen the alien after having left you
know Mark behind on Earth kind of starts
traveling back to telesa and is passed
by a Vite ship and in hoping that they
had noticed him they ended up doing that
and so he ends up facing off against
this same Vite woman that had
interrogated Mark or had met mark on
earth now the funny thing about this is
that as the two of them are fighting she
kind of talks about this idea that
because of the power he possesses and so
on because he refused to stand for the
vmite Empire that like so many other
people they've come across who refuse to
bend the knee that he'll be executed and
first and foremost he'll be taken to a
vmite prison and that's when he recalls
a conversation he had with Mark where
Mark had revealed his father had been
taken and he was going to be executed
and that's when Allen's like that's my
ticket right that's my ticket to get a
hold of noan and so ultimately he kind
of goes in a fight and then plays posum
right she goes in for a punch and then
he's like oh my God you got right and it
just kind of makes it look like he's
knocked out she snatches him up takes
him aboard the ship and he's basically
going to be taken to the same place that
Mark is and that's kind of a great thing
there is because what you end up doing
is actually transitioning to the Vite
prison planet or really prison asteroid
uh where you have Nolan and Nolan kind
of struggling and dealing with all this
internal these internal emotional issues
that he's had to cope with comes to this
kind of realization that he misses his
wife on Earth that Nolan at least on an
emotional level is becoming human more
and more with each passing day right
with each passing experience as he
thinks back on his life on Earth it's
really Nostalgia that kind of gets the
gets the better of him right this idea
of looking back to the life that he
lived looking back to his time in that
world raising mark his time with his
wife all the experiences he had what it
meant to live among Humanity to be so
perfect among imperfect beings has
really just sort of of brought him to a
place where he misses that companionship
he misses the connection that he had
with his wife and so the result of this
is a couple things go on one of the
first things that happens is you have
Mark who actually meets with Cecil and
basically all the government guys who
have more or less constructed this
gigantic hydraulic press right and
Mark's essentially using it to try to
bench press and increase his weights now
like most vites as he gets into conflict
and as he pushes himself in the most
extreme he recovers at seemingly an
exponential rate right we don't really
get a kind of mathematical comparison so
it's not as though for every one battle
and and every beating and so it's not as
though if on a scale of like 1 to 10 the
beating he received is on is is like a
nine and so his strength increases
proportionally to that particular
beating that he got but we're not really
given any kind of of explanation in that
way it's simply enough that he his
strength increases exceedingly fast
right and he's exceedingly capable in
that way and so following that what you
have here is Nolan who almost tries to
instigate this kind of prison break
right tries to break out of this Vite
prison and in doing so of course he's
ultimately captured by General Craig and
general Craig basically beats him within
an inch of his life and they drag him
back to his cell but when that happens
Allen is also brought on board the ship
right and that's when Allan tells him
telepathically we'll have a conversation
later you and I will talk later and
that's one of the things where basically
it's setting the Sage for this idea that
Allen the alien and Nolan are going to
end up teaming up and then ultimately
we're going to see what road that takes
for Nolan and I'm going to tell you
right now The Story of omn Man following
the time he leaves Earth is
amazing what's going on guys this is Rob
and I'm actually recording in a
different audio space so let me know if
you guys hear a difference at all I'm
kind of curious but uh we're picking
back up with invincible and this one
basically deal this is kind of
interesting this deals with a huge
change to the Invincible Mythos based on
what we've known so far right so what
this initially does or what I want to do
here is I want to start out where you
end up having Cecil having a
conversation with Invincible mom and the
funny thing about this is that Deborah
had largely kept the existence of omni
kid or kid omn man whatever you want to
call him had largely kept him a secret
from Cecil and this was done for a
couple different reasons the first is
because of the fact that one she just
doesn't trust him right that's pretty
straightforward based on her experiences
dealing with with Nolan and so on and so
forth and the fact that he's just he's a
government agent and the second thing is
because she's taking this kid to great
so in a lot of ways she looks at him as
this young boy that she needs to take
care of on her own and keep him as safe
as she possibly can and that's why when
Cecil shows up here and starts talking
about a kind of disappointment about the
fact that she didn't tell him what was
going on and all that kind of stuff at
the end of the day her response is
you're not taking my kid and that's the
thing about Cecil is this kind of
response in turn is well we're not
really looking to take him but it's
important you understand that after
everything that happened with your
husband we are a little weary about him
having a child outside of Mark and then
in turn that child's showing up here we
have no idea what this kid is capable of
now from there he kind of gets a call
where things are basically popping off
and going belly up and then you switch
over to Mark meeting with Eve now one of
the things we talked about in the
previous videos is that Mark's whole
romantic interest in Eve is predicated
on a couple different things one she's
hot and they're young right need I say
more
two when Mark had his escapades where he
was kind of running around and and
dealing with really kind of being thrown
through time and so on that when he
encountered the future version of Eve
she begged him tell me something right
like tell my past self what's going on
whether we're going to date or not going
to date whether you love me you don't
love me but tell me something which
really showed this idea that Eve was
very much interested in Mark but because
she never got a definitive answer she
never moved on she just stayed hung up
on him forever so the important thing
here is that Mark had a kind of
conversation with her where he told her
that he seemed to be interested but when
she asked where it was coming from he
revealed the truth and eve took that
personally because it didn't really feel
like he was confessing feelings to her
because he actually had feelings for her
it seemed like he was doing it because
he didn't want her to become the future
version that he saw which really kind of
equates to like a Pity date that's
really kind of what it came across as
and of course nobody wants to be a Pity
date and so ultimately she kind of took
it personally now the fact that she's
receptive to having conversations with
him and talking to him and the fact that
she's like flying with him you know
they're they're kind of going off on
superhero stuff really indicates that
okay sure like at the very least she
wants to spend time with him otherwise
she would just fly there on her own
right so obviously there's there's some
kind of interest there and so once they
get to this location whereby Cecil had
sent them the revelation of basically
all the Guardians of the globe who had
essentially gone missing are down about
3 mil below and so once Mark gets down
there what we end up learning is that
doc seismic had basically kidnapped all
of them now the important thing about
doc seismic here's the thing about this
guy this guy is basically a standin for
the molean right for those you guys who
don't know who the mle man is in Marvel
Comics he leads the mids he's not
important never really
was he was kind of a throwaway character
in a lot of different ways and that's
one of the things that kind of gets
tossed out here right is that nobody
really seems to take him ser seriously
but the fact that he was able to
essentially capture all the superheroes
from around the world is a pretty big
achievement right it's no small thing
now of course Mark comes into the rescue
and that basically offers a momentary
distraction which in turn allows all you
know all the the various Heroes to
escape but then like giant lava monsters
things like that start pupping up so not
really anything crazy and out of the
ordinary the big important thing here
this is a significant thing is that in
this moment when Mark is seemingly
defeated by the forces of Doc seismic
that you end up having having Cecil who
basically sends in what he calls a
secondary team and this secondary team
comes in a couple of different forms the
first bit here comes in the form of the
ranan which pretty much all of you guys
know by by the TV show right like the
people who were essentially turned into
like robotic kind of cyborg things by da
Sinclair and the second one comes in the
form of Darkwing too now here's the
thing as We Know da Sinclair is working
with Cecil right that's one of the
things that we saw in the previous video
that we did that in the aftermath of Da
Sinclair doing what done he was supposed
to stand trial and so on and so forth
and instead had been offered a deal by
Cecil we knew that Mark does not but
Darkwing 2 is a little more interesting
so as you guys know Darkwing was part of
the original Guardians of the globe who
were basically killed by Nolan by omn
man before he fled Earth this is
essentially his Robin more or less the
big difference here is that Midnight
City is large they where they operate
right so kirkman's not even trying to
hide the Illusions between Darkwing and
Batman right they're more or less the
same thing the big issue here though is
that dark wi snapped because of how
extreme Midnight City was and because
there was so much incredible crime there
and so what he ended up doing was
basically killing anybody who committed
any crime it didn't matter what that
crime was from small things all the way
to big things so the fact that he's here
is kind of a crazy situation because
Mark not a huge fan of this guy and in
fact one of the things that actually
goes on is that where Dr seismic is
doing all these crazy things and so on
and so forth that Darkwing actually ends
up leading him or at least pulling him
down into a Kass which more or less
seems to kill him and the response of is
he immediately freaks out right calls
him a murderer and starts pummeling this
guy now the big thing about this is that
Mark was the only one who witnessed what
it was that dark wi was doing in
Midnight City and so for everybody here
who's watching Mark doing what he's
doing at the end of the day they see it
as one of these things where he's
basically losing his mind but from
Mark's perspective this guy's crazy he's
psychotic he has no business being any
kind of a superhero whatsoever he will
always engage in extremely violent
actions if he can get away with it now
the experience was or really everything
that was kind of happening was
technically documented and Mark actually
goes as far as to say that like you guys
had to have seen it it was on the news
and recorded and all that kind of stuff
but there's actually a little more you
know craziness going a foot instead what
ends up happening is Cecil steps in
tells Mark to stand down things kind of
pop off he tells Mark we'll talk about
this later and in turn Mark has a bit of
a conversation with Eve not a whole lot
going on there really just kind of
talking about how like he knows the
whole thing with him and and Darkwing
was essentially recorded it should have
been on the news all that kind of stuff
but it wasn't people don't know about it
which means that it seems to have been
hidden and he really seems to believe
that Cecil was the one who did it and so
flying directly off to encounter Cecil
directly as the two of them are talking
da Sinclair walks out and that's when
Mark comes to the realization this guy's
working with da Sinclair in a pretty
quick situation we're basically given
this Revelation on behalf of Mark that
nothing Cecil's telling him has really
been true that Cecil's basically been
lying all this time and so one of the
things that happens is that Cil
basically leads him into the white room
now as you guys know that white room is
basically designed in such a way to
where it hes with or really messes with
eyesight so that those people who are in
it can't actually see what's in there
right all they see is basically white
and that's one of the things Mark kind
of let lets loose into Cecil right and
it's just like how could you have
possibly worked with somebody like da
Sinclair knowing the kind of things that
he's done and something has to be going
on here like you had to have gotten rid
of that footage you had to have done
something like you had to have known
what was going on with dark WIS so that
now I'm led to believe that you have a
hand and the reason why no one's aware
of what's going on with dark wi and all
these Rihanna men who had basically been
built for Cecil by da Sinclair now one
of the things that goes on here Mark
just crushes these guys I mean with in
and in no uncertain terms it's quite
readily these guys are defeated and it's
one of these things where Cecil almost
kind of looks at Mark and talks about
like angstrom Levy right how Mark had
seemingly killed a guy but the response
of Mark is that was unintentional it was
not my goal to murder a person but this
guy Darkwing does the same thing this
guy DA cleair they do the same thing
like they experimented on people killed
people different things like like that
like they're dark and twisted people you
can't take what is basically an accident
and then in turn apply it to the concept
that like it was an intentional killing
of someone that's not really what was
going on and so that's kind of the crazy
thing is because at the end of the day
the stance of Cecil is it doesn't matter
right like I've got my hands in
everything and I believe I'm genuinely
doing the right thing if you're not with
me you're against me and that's kind of
the crazy thing here is because Cil
seems to be taking on this exceedingly
dark and and really absolute standpoint
so much so that once Mark overcomes all
these Reanna men and then starts going
after Cecil Cecil panics takes off and
then there's like maybe like 500 Reanna
men who all kind of exist here and
that's when Mark's kind of like okay
look like are you going to arrest me
like what's going to happen here and
basically the reanim start turning on
Mark and then ultimately Cecil activates
this kind of Sonic Beacon device and
what we end up finding out is that at
some point when Mark was given the kind
the kind of earpiece by Cecil that it
also had a device inside his body that
basically threw off his equilibrium and
would emit a Sonic pulse and the reason
why this was done is because in his time
having and having dealt with and engaged
with omn man Even though they'd worked
together for so long the reality of seou
is and kind of looking at this guy was
like equilibrium is a necessary thing
because unlike a person where you gave
them vertigo they would get a little
dizzy and probably have to sit down but
for somebody like Mark or somebody like
omn man being able to screw with
equilibrium in their head is a huge deal
because it's necessary to fly the Sonic
pulse is almost just crushing in terms
of the sound that it emits so much so
that Mark is large the incapacitated
here and that's kind of the crazy thing
because following that Mark actually
speeds off right he kind of asks like
like you know how strong how capable is
this pulse and then speeds off where he
actually starts to outrace it like
literally Cecil's teleporting trying to
keep up with him and then ultimately
catches him and then Mark basically
lands inside the headquarters of the new
Guardians of the globe right Rex and and
all those guys monster girl and so on
and basically brings to their attention
Cecil's the one that's doing all this
and so it's really the first time that
you see people in the superhero
Community who are learning that's Cecil
is Cecil's always been sus man there's
always been something up with this guy
and that's kind of the crazy thing is
because when he kind of makes this case
that when Mark makes this case that
Cecil is employing people who are serial
killers or murderers people who are
experimenting on other individuals
somebody like da Sinclair at the end of
the day it's kind of like like yeah like
the whole thing with with like Darkwing
that was recorded that should have been
on the news but because of the
connections that that Cecil had he had
it suppressed he had it he basically
made sure that nobody would know that
Darkwing was doing that stuff and he
basically blackmailed him and said that
if you don't work for me directly I'll
release this to the public and the whole
world will know that you're basically a
crazy psychopath and that's how he seems
to basically get people to work for him
and that leads to the rest of the
Guardians of the globe basically going
on and and confronting Cecil directly
and that's where things get kind of nuts
because in this process and this is
incredibly important in this process
Mark begins to lose his control and this
is kind of a dangerous thing here
because as that happens he starts to
become somewhat bloodlusted now the
crazy thing about that is is this this
is in in a lot of ways kind of where omn
man was but the big difference between
omn man and Mark is that Nolan was a guy
who' lived for so long that this idea of
him just kind of giving into his
emotions was very rare but Mark does not
have the experience and does not have
the same kind of training uh that that
omn man had and so it's much much easier
for him to get into his emotions and so
that's one of the things that kind of
happens is that with everything going on
with Mark and this kind of Sonic pulse
that's ringing through his head it's on
the verge of killing him and that's when
everybody like everybody's like you have
to shut that thing down you're going to
kill mark you're going to kill
invincible and that's not something that
ceca wants on his on his conscience
ultimately he tells da to basically shut
off the uh the Sonic emitter and then
when Mark gets that chance to kind of
recoup he almost kills Cecil of course
he doesn't and then Cecil basically
fires him on the spot and you would
think that you know when when it looks
like Mark is just kind of like okay fine
we're going to go ahead and let that go
Mark immediately charges Cecil and then
basically says if we're done then that
means we're done that means you and I
have no contact whatsoever so if you
come near my family my mom my brother or
or whoever I will kill you if you send
anybody to my family that I know works
on your behalf or I even get a whiff of
the idea that they work on your behalf
I'll come back and I'll kill you and
that's one of the important things is
because what Mark's kind of demonstrated
here is that at the end of the day
despite Cecil's best efforts especially
Mark knowing this device is in his brain
that was the Ace in the Hole right that
was the only thing that Cecil really had
to overcome Mark now that that's not
there anymore Mark has the ability to
get rid of that or seems to have the
ability to get rid of it then now Cecil
has nothing over Mark and so if he
really does piss him off Mark will kill
him and there'll be nothing Cecil can do
about it absolutely nothing at all he's
an old man right what could he possibly
hope to do against somebody like Mark
having said that this is a this is kind
of a crazy thing because Mark has this
conversation with Eve right where she
kind of hung around the house you know
just to kind of keep an eye and and make
sure that Mark was going to be okay when
he got back and different things like
that and Mark kind of spills the beans
and says you know for a moment there I
thought I was going to die I guess that
was really the test right for a moment I
thought I was going to die and in that
moment the only person that I could
think of was you that was you were the
only person I could think think of in
the whole wide world and so because of
that I love you like I'm I'm I'm with
you like you and me like that's it now
of course you know Omni kid sees it and
he's like
gross but it's a it's a funny little
thing there right but following this
there's there's a couple big things that
happened one of the biggest and most
notable things that take place is that
Mark takes his younger brother under his
wing to train him now as most of you
guys can probably guess just from having
seen things like Star Wars and so on
this is not going to end well Mark was
as effective of a hero as he is for a
bunch of different reasons the least of
which has anything to do with the
training that he got from Nolan we know
that just because of the experience the
two of them had and didn't really get
any measure of training until his powers
developed the reason why Mark is the way
he is is because of the time he spent
among Humanity right the the time that
he spent among people who when almost
every conceivable way were weaker than
he was even before he knew that he had
powers he spent all this time among
people and adopted a lot of human
Tendencies both good and bad for
somebody like his younger brother he
doesn't have that right so it's
literally a rush job on training taking
this kid that has these incredible
abilities who basically gained them you
know over a decade before Mark did in
terms of age relation and then in turn
taking him under his wing to be his
trainer the other thing about this is
that because of everything that played
out with Mark and Cecil that essentially
the Guardians of the globe have split
the the team teams roster as we know it
for the most part it's kind of back to
its old self right in the sense that
you've got monster girl you've got robot
who's now in a boy's body and and so on
and so forth Adam Eve and and those
characters and of course Mark as well
and then you have the actual Guardians
of the globe so you've got duplicate
you've got the immortal and and so on
but it's one of these things where it's
kind of like okay like as far as Cecil's
concerned they're the official team
right the teen team is really more of
like a standin team right so it's almost
kind of an unspoken statement or an
unspoken phrase that like they're
essentially enemies right like if the
teen team steps in to confront some
enemy that the Guardians of the globe
are going to kill and tries to stop them
then now they're enemies right they kind
of work in that that kind of weird
capacity there the other thing that goes
on here is of course Mark takes his
younger brother to meet the Taylor right
and then in turn the Taylor also gives
Mark a new costume which you know it
looks kind of cool you know that's
that's one of those little interesting
tidbits there but the cool thing about
this is that you get to this interesting
situation where you basically have this
kind of nuclear Silo that were basically
taken over by the lizard league and of
course the lizard League was kind of a
laughable team but the mer twins have
basically arrived here to kind of do the
same thing not the exact same thing but
to kind of launch their own plant now
this is going to be one of the most
important parts of the story because one
of the most interesting part of the
story the way this plays out is that
where you have a conversation between
Mark and his brother and the two of them
are talking and so on and he's kind of
teaching him the ropes of like when I
tell you to stay you stay the threats
out here are no joke this is not a kind
of time to mess around or goof off or
anything like that you could get
yourself killed facing off against some
of the people here things along those
lines that word basically reaches the
ears of Mark that the mer twins are
attacking this Silo right and when I say
word riches his ears I mean like he
walks into the room and his mom says
like look at
this and so of course he dons his
costume races off to go face off against
the mer twins who have basically
defeated the Guardians of the globe and
so Mark does what he can hand to step up
against them but then when his brother
comes in and and he's like where's Mark
at his mom's like oh he want to go do
this and then his brother takes off and
joins the joins the frey as well now
there's a huge difference here and
there's a huge moment here because
ultimately Mark does what he can to face
off against these guys but a nuclear
weapon is basically launched right the
whole idea of the mer twins is to
basically take over the computer systems
of the world but at the end of the day
like this nuclear missile is launched
which is really designed as a kind of uh
distraction to get Mark out of the scene
and then in turn allow them to complete
their goal but they're totally unaware
of his younger brother stepping in now
as soon as he shows up he kind of
punches one of them all twins in the
mouth right they don't really take him
seriously they throw him into a into a
wall the kid emerges from rubble and
then just kind of like flies right
through one of them and kills him this
freaks out the other one right because
there's this kind of Unwritten rule
among the superheroes like you don't
kill your villains right it's one of
these things where the villains are kind
of like I mean you know you know how it
is like we do crime you arrest us you
take us to jail and then we get out and
then we do crime again and it's one of
these things where where literally one
of the twins is like I give up I
Surrender like please just don't don't
hurt me and Omni kid's just like so
you're going to make it easy for me huh
and then just like punches his punches
his brains out through the top of his
head now Immortal emerges and sees all
this happening and then Omni kid is like
it was an accident right it was it was
an accident and this leads to Mark
returning and then Cecil arriving at the
same time and as soon as Mark sees Cecil
he immediately goes in for the hit right
it's just like I told you to stay away
from my family and that's when Cecil is
like no we were here to clean up your
brother's mess and realizing what it is
that his younger brother had done the
two of them fly into space this is one
of the coolest conversations that we see
because ultimately he tells his younger
brother he was like he's like you killed
those guys and his younger brother's
like yeah they were bad guys like they
killed people down there I kill them now
they can't kill anybody else you should
be happy now this is Sound Logic right
like they've killed people they've
demonstrated incorrigibility they will
always kill innocent people as long as
it allows them to to achieve their goal
and so the only logical way to save
lives is to kill those guys right
because the important thing about this
and the big takeaway from that is Mark
is sacrificing innocent lives to Main
maintain his own personal morality other
people's lives are not as important to
him as he is to himself and that's the
crazy thing it's one of the things about
superheroes nobody ever considers that
the the kind of almost narcissistic and
Psychopathic nature of what it means to
be hero I and my morality are what are
most important to me and therefore I
will sacrifice innocent lives in order
to maintain that The Stance of his son
is that doesn't make any sense right
like if our job is to save people and to
keep People Protected then we should
kill the bad guys especially if we know
that bad guys are going to routinely
kill people and that's one of the things
that he says you know when when Mark
kind of goes on this little bit of a
speech and he's like there are laws and
rules and we can't just take that kind
of responsibility for someone else's
life for for taking anybody's life we're
not infallible what if we're wrong and
we kill somebody innocent well then what
then and he says human life is a
precious thing the response of his
brother is no it's not and Mark's kind
of kind of shocked by that and his
brother's like Precious human life is
not precious not in general not everyone
people risk their lives every day they
kill each other if they don't think
their lives are important why should I
most of them are utterly insignificant
and Mark's response you sound like that
and then his brother's response here is
so why is that bad why is he so wrong
did anything he said make sense to you
even on a small level have you ever
thought that maybe our father was right
and that is a mindblowing moment from
from this from this kid is because at
the end of the day Nolan was right right
if Humanity really wanted to fix itself
it already would have it would have been
on the road to doing that but at the end
of the day people do terrible things to
each other and other people stand by and
watch it happen and so Humanity as far
as no one is concerned and as far as
this kid's concerned and in some level
as far as I'm concerned I wouldn't say
is a lost cause but is certainly on its
death now right and so at the end of the
day it's kind of like Humanity needs to
be made to be better even if they don't
want to be and if that means killing
criminals in order to save innocent
people then I will do what the average
person is unwilling to do I will do what
you are not willing to do it's kind of a
it's it's an amazing philosophy and it's
cool to see it actually said in a comic
book because it makes so much logical
sense it makes so much reasonable sense
there it's why I love the philosophy of
like superheroes doing superhero things
and so on and so forth because at the
end of the day if you're a superhero how
many innocent lives are you really
willing to sacrifice because you don't
like the idea of killing bad guys right
like how many how many innocent people
would you sacrifice 100 lives would you
sacrifice 500 lives well I mean is that
just the price you pay to maintain your
role as a superhero to keep that high
morality when do you draw the line right
that's that's the that's the crazy thing
about about superheroes that's what
makes it so interesting all right what's
going on guys this is Rob and we are
back with Invincible yes we are now this
is one of those stories where there's
not really a cohesive plot thread that
runs through the whole thing instead
it's just a series of things that are
kind of going on and Kirkman does that
occasionally right like there's usually
a singular plot threat in every single
story and that's usually what we focus
on but occasionally you get one of these
where it's just a bunch of things
happening at the same time one of the
things that we're going to deal with
here what we're going to focus on here
is basically what happened to omn man
after the events of Earth and everything
that went on with the other planet when
he was captured by the vites we know
that he's awaiting execution and that's
one of the things that we learned is
that whenever vites basically deviate
from their role or they kind of abandon
quote unquote the charter of the Vite
race that they're basically executed
right which is kind of a weird thing
given the little bit of information that
we'll get here in a little bit but
essentially he's just waiting on that
now of course we also had Alan the alien
who of course as you guys know has
telepathy who also got himself captured
so he could come across omn man because
word had reached his ears by way of his
conversations with Mark and then a few
other people that basically omn man had
defected from the the charter of the
vure basically indicating he could be an
ally for the Coalition of planets the
Coalition of Worlds I've heard you guys
you know kind of run it off
interchangeably honestly it is I'm sure
some super hardcore people will be like
actually it's the Coalition of of
planets and it's like but who really
cares though so here's the thing so what
ends up happening is a kind of
conversation or really a series of
conversations take place between Allen
and Nolan and this is an important thing
because the reality is all they have is
each other for reasons that aren't
really made relevant or made apparent to
Allen uh ultimately the vulture mites
haven't quite shown up yet instead one
of the things that goes on this is one
of the things that we've kind of talked
about before is that the vilter mites
actually conscript other races that
they've conquered to kind of work
alongside with them sort of beefing up
their numbers so they're really more
like field troops and different things
like that and in this instance these
guys have tried to like kill Allen and
it doesn't work right he's just too
durable for the weapons they have and so
ultimately it's just one of these things
where it's just kind of biting time and
in the conversations that Allan and
Nolan have they've actually kind of
develop friendships for each other right
where they're kind of talking about
loves they've lost relationships they've
been in making sacrifices for the
greater good all that kind of stuff and
ultimately a bond forms here a bond that
forms in in the sense that it's kind of
like hey like we're brothers and arms in
a lot of different ways we've both
sacrificed we've both lost we've both
gained and so finding that Common Ground
leads to what is basically a friendship
form between the two of them which is
kind of wild because because before they
really knew who the other was they were
enemies they were basically fighting
each other and so at the end of it all
you have the vulture mites who finally
show up on the scene and the intention
is to basically take out Nolan the funny
thing is that in that process while
Nolan was awaiting his execution and so
was alen the alien they had basically
formed a plan and in doing so Allen
breaks himself out of jail and during
that time battle Beast arrives as well
and so that's kind of a big thing
because a lot of you guys know battle
Beast is a hoss right this guy is an
absolute monster literally and
figuratively but battle Beast also lives
for the for the hunt he lives for the
conflict right he basically looks to
better himself through battle and
through war and so fighting alongside
Allen the alien they ultimately arrive
to where Nolan is going to be executed
and then essentially save him and that's
one of the things when like when he's
like okay so like it's vites right and
and battle Beast realizes that it's a
vmite his desire is to face him in
battle right because the vter mites are
like the most feared Race Across the
Universe and by defeating one would kind
of solidify his position as being being
the foremost and really one of the most
formidable beings in all of creation the
problem is there's not really a lot of
time for that I mean there is they can
kind of defeat these guys but the
biggest concern is that more more vites
are going to be coming and so basically
they kind of just jettison all these
these you know guys who are working for
the vites just send them flying out into
space they basically defeat the two vure
mites that are here and then Allen kind
of starts to go into a panic and saying
like we have to find you know I have to
find my my scanner it has all the
information I've gained and all that
kind of stuff and we have to do that
before the vulture mites get here and
the response of Nolan is they're not
coming there are no more vites that are
going to be coming and when the question
is asked why Nolan basically reveals the
best kept secret among the Vite race
which is while they are feared across
the universe as this kind of nigh
Unstoppable race less than 50 of them
left there's hardly any pure-blooded
vites left now that's something
important to keep in mind there's less
than 50 pure blood viltrumites there are
like Vite breeds right half breeds
whereas like vites who procreated with a
different member of A different race But
ultimately in terms of the pure blood
vites like Nolan there there's less than
50 and that's the reason why they don't
necessarily come flying in with absolute
Force because they don't really want to
risk their number right they don't
really want to risk the possibility of
of losing any more of those 50 than they
possibly have to and so ultimately what
you end up getting here is kind of
switching back to Earth you have
basically Mark and and Adam Eve who are
together and they're basically
banging and his younger brother walks in
on him and of course Mark takes off and
basically does the heroic thing or at
least responds to a call that he got
from Amber now when he gets there this
is one of those crazy things when he
gets there Amber is kind of like okay
well I mean here's the thing right like
the past few weeks have been really
really hard like my dad died and I've
been talking to Gary and I know it's a
little awkward having this conversation
with you instead of calling Gary and
then she basically reveals and and it's
it's kind of a weird thing she basically
reveals that like Gary's been beating
her right Gary's been beating on her and
it's one of these things where Gary came
off as a great guy so much so that she
actually dumped Mark for Gary And so
this kind of led to a crazy thing
because like Mark immediately freaks out
now Mark's not going to get back
together with Amber right it's just one
of those those things where it's like
I'm with Adam Eve now but at the end of
the day she is a friend and so Mark
basically responds by going and finding
Gary and he kind of helps Gary Come to
an understanding of his place in the
bigger picture by kind of saying hey
look man I know you like putting your
hands on girls so let me put my hands on
you and we'll see how much you enjoy
that right and that's one of those crazy
things cuz he basically tells her if you
ever hit her again I'm going to come
back I'm going to find you and I'm going
to kill you it's kind of a weird thing
because as soon as Mark gets back to
Amber and starts talking to her one of
the things that she done initially was
make excuses for Gary well it was just
one time thing he was just really upset
and that's a lot of the things that you
see when it comes to people who have
been through abusive situations like
that is they often times internalize why
they were abused in the first place well
it was my fault if I hadn't done that he
wouldn't have hit me if I hadn't done
that she wouldn't have attacked me
because guys get abused by women too
even though we don't like to talk about
that so it's one of these things when
Mark gets back there and Mark says okay
are you sure you want to stay with this
guy her response is well I mean we've
kind of been through a lot there was
there was a lot of craziness that was
happening but like don't worry about me
Mark everything's going to be fine right
famous last words but every like
everything is going to be fine you know
everything's going to be cool and Mark
ultimately leaves her and it's kind like
okay like this is what you want this is
what I will give you and so what he ends
up doing is of course traveling back to
Adam Eve and saying hey look here's what
was going on with Amber that Gary was
beating her so I beat the hell out of
Gary and I told him I'd kill him if he
ever did it again and then it's it's
it's kind of kind of interesting because
he thought she was going to take it the
wrong way ultimately she doesn't right
and she's just kind of like I mean you
know like I totally understand where
you're coming from I mean the guy was
beating up a friend of mine why would I
be upset about you going and tracking
down the guy and beating the crap out of
him following that Mark realizes that
he's basically being spied on now as the
reader we know who it is who's spying on
him it's not Cecil but we know who it
actually is that's doing this but Mark
believes that it is Cecil and so he
ultimately ends up you know traveling to
Cecil tracking him down interrogating
him a little bit cil's kind of like look
man we're not the ones spying on you but
I do need your help with something you
know now of course Mark is kind of like
I mean look man like I'm not looking to
help you dude like I don't trust you at
all and that kind of makes sense right I
mean that's the thing that we talked
about in the last video that sea kind of
came off as this guy who was like hey
man I'm looking out for you your dad did
some bad stuff but your family's going
to be taken care of you know not
necessarily like a father figure about
like an uncle you know who was a little
bit sus like that was kind of the thing
about about Cecil you know like you knew
there was something a little off about
him but you didn't really think it was
anything severe and then in the the
conflict that he had with Mark it was oh
no man like we've definitely got you
under lock and key like we're monitoring
you we're keeping an eye on your family
we don't really trust you I'm just kind
of putting off this air so you'll
continue to work with us by all
standards of measurement he destroyed
any measure of trust that existed
between himself and Mark but as far as
Cil went it was that's the price I'm
willing to pay to basically keep the
world safe from people like your father
potentially people like you or anybody
else out there who could be a credible
threat and so what you end up doing is
basically switching over to Gary Hampton
now Gary Hampton is a bit of a weird
situation of course we switch over to
him because that's the person that Cecil
basically needs help with Gary has a bit
of a lengthy history here and that's one
that we could potentially talk about if
you guys are interested in it but all
that really matters in this whole thing
is that Yu was at one point a
billionaire ultimately he ended up being
transformed into a werewolf he kind of
goes by the name of wolf man he was a
hero for a little while but for the most
part knowledge or at least public
knowledge of Gary Hampton the
billionaire being secretly a werewolf
was kind of kept hidden right nobody
really knew that eventually it became
public knowledge when his daughter
walked in on him with the dead body of
his wife and the presumption was he
killed his wife now there was a lot of
history going on there the fact that he
had kind of dove into his work before he
became a werewolf the fact that he kind
of drove his wife Away by simply just
ignoring her for the most part she went
to the of another man anybody who
understood the inner workings of their
family and the struggles that they'd
gone through the fact that he was under
an embezzlement investigation the fact
that you know he he' essentially lost
everything while the government sees his
accounts and froze everything there's
every reason to believe that Gary did
actually kill his wife right and so
that's why the response of Cecil in them
is that guy's definitely guilty the
other thing is there was a bit of a
backstory with a guy by the name of
Zechariah who you immediately knew with
sus ended up being a bad guy and then
ultimately you ended up having Gary
seeking out what's called The Elder
basically thisy guy who's kind of like
the Elder werewolf for lack of a better
word and kind of teaches Gary the ropes
and how everything works kind of enhance
his abilities expand on him and so on
and so forth again we can actually focus
on that if you guys care I don't imagine
a whole lot of you guys do a lot of you
guys are probably really more interested
in what's going on with like omn man and
and all that kind of stuff honestly
because it's the coolest thing but the
Elder is not really teaching Gary to be
a villain that's the important thing
he's actually teaching him to be a hero
he's like you are going to go through a
series of Trials and one of the first
trials you're going to go through is
basically protecting the innocent right
like keep innocent people safe from what
is essentially a credible threat and
that's when you basically have giant who
returned now giant is a character that
we haven't really talked about before
the long and short of it is that he was
a kid who was yanked into a different
dimension and then came back in his
current form and just much like a kid
kind of goes on these Rampages not fully
understanding what he's capable of he
was eventually put in a kind of
containment system and then managed to
escape hence where he's at right now and
Cecil and them were just trying to find
a way to recontain him again he was
certainly able to give Mark a run for
his money right like he was able to to
beat the crap out of Mark basically
and that's why Mark is none too keen on
tracking this kid back down again but he
kind of treats him like a kid right like
Authority right like a strong voice firm
hand that's the kind of thing that a lot
of kids need and that's what he tells
them right Mark basically knocks this
kid down quite readily and then it's
just like stay here right if youut if
you if you keep on messing around like
I'm going to beat the crap out of you I
don't want to do not get up right like I
don't want to hurt you anymore and so
ultimately the kid just sits there until
the authorities ared but this was the
mission that Gary Hampton himself had
actually been sent on which was
basically protecting innocent people
from this this giant now the reality is
Gary probably would not have been able
to do it on his own and I don't think he
was really expected to I think it was
really more a test of courage and
conviction is he willing to put his life
on the line to save innocent people and
so of course because of the fact that
Cecil and them are looking for him and
the belief out there is that he killed
his wife while he and Mark kind of talk
a little bit about how they teamed up
and you he basically helped Mark with uh
with seismic a little while back Mark's
like but I mean I got to I still got to
take you in dude bolts like he
immediately he immediately takes off
like literally like Mark's like I got to
take you in and he just bam he just
takes off he's like Oh no you're not
either he literally tries to run but the
funny thing is that Mark's operating on
the information given to him by Cecil
and then once Gary's able to make his
case Mark realizes there there's
something else going on here right
Gary's like look man I didn't kill my
wife I simply walked in on her I found
her dead and then my daughter saw me
with the body and then that's what
everybody's operating on right basically
circumstantial evidence now the argument
that Cecil initially made was look we
just want to bring him in so we can
interrogate him question him like that
but we know that whatever Cecil says
believe the opposite right so there's no
intention of like bringing him in
questioning him getting to the bottom of
the case and then freeing him if it's if
it's actually untrue Cil is not looking
to work as this guy's defense lawyer
he's in the business of like contain and
control and that's exactly what would
happen here that maybe he would get to
talk to his lawyer if Cecil feels like
letting him or most likely Cecil would
use him for his own ends right to create
his own kind of Suicide Squad thing
which is basically what the Guardians of
the globe are without the bombs in their
heads right that's essentially what
they've kind of been turned into into
and so he really kind of pleads the case
and tells him everything that's going on
and he was like like right now like this
guy that I was working with like he's a
mentor right he's training me guiding me
teaching me how to use my powers and he
says I thought I had that at a previous
point in time and it turned out I was
wrong I thought I had a mentor but he
was hiding things right like that guy
killed my wife like he's the one who did
it right that guy Z Zachariah like he's
the one who killed my wife and I walked
in on him doing it and then in turn it
was my daughter who walked in with me at
the body believing that I was the one
that did it like it's literally just
like a framing thing I mean he didn't
intentionally frame me but that's how it
all just kind of turned out that I'm not
actually the bad guy here but ultimately
because of the emotion that he puts
forward because of how he looks right
just the overall tone that he gives this
is Way Beyond some kind of sociopath
who's manipulating Mark into believing
that he's telling the truth instead it's
basically one of these things where it's
like this guy's actually telling the
truth and zechariah's out there and he
wants to get revenge on this guy like he
wants to kill the guy who killed his
wife and then after that you know who
knows maybe go back to being a hero but
it's a very understandable motivation
it's a very graspable motivation and so
ultimately Mark's like I believe you
right like I'm just going to take you
into Cecil we'll get everything cleared
up and then Cecil's guaranteed to let
you go right it kind of astounds me even
at this point mark is this naive right
it would just kind of be like I don't
know what happened Cecil he got away man
like I it's it's werewolf stuff man he
just he it was just some cloud and then
he used some powers and disappeared I I
don't know what to tell you but of
course he ends up bringing him in right
and that's kind of the funny thing is as
soon as he gets in here the most logical
situation happens when it's basically
like let this guy make his case right
let Gary Hampton make his case let him
talk and at the end of the day cil's
like there's nothing I can do here man
like there's there's nothing I can do
here right I mean you know it's just you
know it's out of my hands right now the
reality is there's a lot Cecil could do
here but Cil doesn't want to do anything
because Cecil has a particular goal he's
looking to achieve with with wolf man
which is he wants to use him for his own
inss and so ultimately because of the
fact they're meeting in the white room
that all these little you know robot
zombie guys come running right the the
reanim man come running up on them all
and we've seen this play out before
right this is one of those instances
where it's kind of like okay like
kirkman's kind of repeating himself a
little bit and that doesn't happen a
whole lot but it kind of does sometimes
and of course these Rihanna men are deal
are dealt with quite readily but the
problem is they ultimately need an out
right they need a way out because
they're just hopelessly outnumbered and
while the Ranna man don't necessarily
exhaust Mark and and wolf man do right
they can get tired now if this was omn
man no it wouldn't be a contest right he
would he would sweep through them quick
fast and in a hurry he kind of swath
through all of them quick fast in a
hurry and like that would be it but Mark
is not omn man so they basically end up
finding themselves an out they literally
break out of the out of the Pentagon
building and then while they are kind of
tracked down a little bit they're
ultimately located by the Guardians of
the globe right so literally Mark
Invincible versus the Guardians of the
globe and when I say versus I say that
very Loosely because this fight is no
fight at all the reality is the fight
between Immortal and Mark has been
coming for quite some time right I mean
like this fight's been coming on for a
while because theyve both got
frustrations to work out right like IM
Immortal doesn't like Mark he thinks
he's too Reckless he thinks he's too
young to lead anything Mark doesn't like
Immortal because the guy's a dick right
so like it's one of these things where
like they've been looking to conflict
with each other for quite some time and
so it's like Mark literally tells them
he's like look guys I don't want to hurt
you like I'm tired of holding back
against you guys and that's the reality
is Mark's been holding back against them
and it's one of those things where like
no one really understood how how much he
was holding back right it's almost like
when Dr Octopus became superior
Spider-Man right and like knocked the
jaw off the Scorpion and then came to
the realization holy cow Peter Parker's
been pulling his punches all this time
that's basically what's going on here
right like Mark's never really gone
balls to the wall full boore on these
guys and he does right he snatches up
the immortal with an instant and just
like pummels everybody else using the
body of the immortal and then throws the
immortal out into the air right that's
it this fight lasts seconds right I mean
it's not a lengthy battle and then
immediately grabs Wolf Man and just says
like we're out of here right and they
basically just take off now he drops him
drops him back off where where the
mentor has him or at least takes him to
his family for a little bit and you know
kind of talks to the family Butler for a
minute not a whole lot going on here
it's just one of these things where it's
kind of this this recognition by a third
party that they know Gary didn't do it
and so it's kind of verifying that
Gary's actually telling the truth both
for Mark and for us as the reader as
well as giving a little bit of of
followup to some of the previous plot
threads that we've seen over the course
of the Invincible story but ultimately
it's kind of like like I'm going to find
Zechariah right like that's my thing
like I'm going to take this guy out I'm
going to destroy this guy the other part
of this and this is something that that
is a little frustrating here is that the
daughter of Gary is showing a lot of
anger and a lot of rage and she and and
ultimately like she's being given a lot
of space but at the same time what she
needs is somebody to give her a more
guiding hand right she needs her father
but the biggest fear is because of all
this anger and because of all this rage
that she could go on becoming something
terrible the other part of that is
because she was aaed because she was
bitten by what was initially a vampire
as opposed to as opposed to Wolfman who
is a werewolf the concern is she's going
to become a vampire so then you
basically have her as a villain right so
again kind of an interesting little
little thread here interesting little
plot thread But ultimately uh Gary's
kind of dropped back off in the Woods by
by Mark they sort of call it a day
they're basically friends you know
allies at this point and this is one of
those instances when kirkman's basically
building up the roster for the purpose
of giving us allies for a mark much
later on down the road who could all
basically help him the other part of
this is that you actually end up
switching over to a couple different
things the first is monster girl robot
finished working on the ability to keep
her from getting younger and because of
the fact that every time she turns into
her monster and then she goes back into
her human form she ages a little bit
less this is all basically predicated on
the idea that much like Bruce Banner
turning into the Incredible Hulk unlike
that circumstance when Banner goes back
to his normal self when she does it
basically puts herselves together in the
wrong order which makes her younger
right that's why she keeps getting
younger and so looking at it from a
scientific standpoint the only real
answer here is not that robot can age
her back up to where she's supposed to
be that seems to be impossible instead
he can keep her from getting younger and
so all this really means is whenever
she's wearing this belt or as she always
wears this belt she turns into her
monster then she goes back to her
younger self she stays that same age she
doesn't actually get younger anymore now
seemingly this almost kind of puts off
an era of potential immortality but it's
one of those things that we'll kind of
have to look at much later on down the
line the other part of that is that with
Mark basically being monitored the
person who's watching him is angstrom
Levy which again we known for quite some
time what we didn't know he was doing
was basically operating behind the
scenes that what he's actually done is
gone to alternate realities and grabbed
different alternate reality versions of
Mark that basically there's somewh he
became like a like essentially a Vite
that conquered the Earth he follow in
his Father's Footsteps but like all
these different iterations of his
character and in effect Mark is going to
have to have to fight an army of
alternate reality versions of
himself what's going on guys this is Rob
and we are back with Invincible yes we
are we are back with our weekly video on
Invincible of course it always goes on
patreon a week ahead of time and then we
release it on YouTube later but what we
end up doing here is we pick up
initially a few months ago if you guys
recall when Mark fought angstrom Levy
when they were fighting in that kind of
alternate reality and Mark had
presumably beat him to death right he
killed angstrom and then just left him
to die what we end up learning here is
that instead a kind of portal was open
and langstrom was pulled through and
despite the fact that his face was just
pumm to Mush I mean his head was just
pummeled to Absolute mush he still
survived just by sheer force of will
this guy is nothing if not dedicated to
destroying Mark you cannot look at me
with a straight face and tell me that a
man who looks like that and survive
just having the desire to kill Mark is
not a man of just absolute fortitude and
dedication right now his henchmen that
kind of bring him back here are not
really as henchmen per se and we'll find
out a little more about them here in a
little bit instead what we end up doing
is picking up seemingly in the immediate
aftermath of the last video that we did
which basically kicks off on day one and
this is the invasion of all the
alternate reality Mars not all but like
20 alternate reality versions of
invincible all who have been summoned
here by angstrom Levy for the purpose of
destroying mark right literally just
like not only destroying him but just
breaking him down piece by piece these
guys Crush through everything and when I
say everything I mean everything right
like they're attacking every major city
Paris France they're attacking the
krumin and Russia right the head of the
Russian government strangely enough one
of these guys meets spawn which is weird
you only see a for short second right
you only see a for short second for one
panel but Mark fights spawn now here's
the thing you are probably not going to
see this in the in the Amazon Series
right you're probably not going to see
that on because as far as I'm aware when
it comes to the to the Amazon series
Amazon only has the rights to Invincible
a little bit of an explanation here for
those of you guys just quick super
simple explanation nothing super drawn
out here Image Comics skybound all those
companies they are not like Marvel and
DC Marvel and DC they have a shared
Universe Marvel's X-Men cross over with
the Avengers who cross over with the
Fantastic 4 and they team up in very big
huge books and different things like
that DC Comics has the Justice League
and they've got the team Titans and all
that kind of stuff and they cross over
in different books right Batman Superman
so on and so forth when it comes to
Independent Publishers they don't
necessarily have that and the reason why
is because Marvel for example if you're
writing for them they have control over
the character so you're like I want to
write the X-Men and Marvel's like okay
cool but you can only write them within
the certain limits of as we described
them right so you can't necessarily have
the X-Men become like a space fairing
team like Guardians of the Galaxy and
they just stay there I mean maybe you
can if Marvel gives you permission when
it comes to things like this skybound
and and image and so on they're a
publishing house and that's all they do
the Creative stories themselves are 100%
up to the writers they can do whatever
they want with them and then they
contract with a company like Sky Bounder
image and then all they do is just put
their Comics out there to the public so
that's why you can potentially see
something like this in the comics where
you have like Invincible crossing over
with spawn but you don't see it all the
time you don't see it quite readily but
because of the fact that Amazon likely
only owns the rights to invincible and
they don't own the rights to Todd
McFarland spawn you're probably never
going to see this well you're probably
never going to see this in the Amazon
series unless Todd McFarland allows it
to happen but it's a cool thing here
because with all these different
versions of Mark literally just running
around cutting a swath through through
the entirety of the
world and attacking all these versions
Mark actually ends up coming across a
version of himself now here's the funny
thing about this at the initial
indication here we don't really get a
lot in terms of their Origins all we
really get are just small little drops
and tidbits and things along those lines
but Mark facing off against this
alternate version of himself is kind of
nuts right because he sees this version
of Mark as kind of a pale reflection of
himself right these guys are all
exceedingly violent they are in effect
versions of Mark that became villains
and they've all been brought here
because they're capable of doing
villainous things now what you also have
while that's popping off you've got
Mark's mom who's watching the news
you've got Mark's friends who are
watching the news and they're like we
all thought it was invincible but now
there's something like 20 of them so
they all seem to be alternate versions
of invincible even the the members of
like the teen team and the Guardians of
the globe thought that Mark was a bad
guy thought he was the one doing all
this and it's one of those things where
it's it's easy to play off of right
because when you look at like what what
omn man did and Mark's the son of omn
man is it really that hard to believe
that Mark just snapped one day and then
just lost his mind and started tearing
up the whole world I mean nobody knew
that omn man was a villain until he was
right like nobody knew that was the case
it's not as though it was slowly
building up to it and he was committing
a series of robberies or he killed the
Guardians of the globe in front of the
world he did it in secret did it in
private right and with the exception of
people like Cecil or individuals who
could who could dig into it right like
detective demon that kind of a thing
there weren't really a whole lot of
people who actually knew what was going
on but here Mark's ripping it all up
after Omni did it probably within a year
or so ago and so it's kind of nuts now
you've also got kid omn man who's kind
of doing the same thing facing off
against these alternate reality versions
of Mark but again we don't get a whole
lot of explanation here but what you do
switch over to is the Pentagon and the
Pentagon some of these guys are able to
take out one of these alternate reality
versions of Mark and then when the
question when when C's like okay like
get people on the horn and his little
robot assistant guy asks like who do we
get right he literally turns into Gary
Oldman he's like
everyone that's literally what it turns
into right the guardian of the globe the
whole nine yards every single superhero
team that can be called is brought in to
face off against all these alternate
reality versions of invincible and
that's literally where Cecil's telling
him like look guys here's the deal right
omn man was one thing he was a Hos right
this guy there's nothing we really could
have done to have stopped him and at the
end of the day if anything if we if we
did find some way to defeat him quote
unquote it would just be buying time
with Mark we kind of stand a chance
against him because he's not necessarily
on the same level as his father 20
versions of Mark I don't know what to
tell you right it's just we have to do
whatever we can to stop this as fast as
we possibly can and so you you have like
some pretty no holds bar stuff Cil tells
them all bets are off right like all the
limits the the restrictions don't kill
unless you have to do whatever you have
to do to take these guys down kill them
it doesn't matter and so all these
different superheroes some of which
we've seen some of which we haven't seen
are all literally just killing these
alternate reality versions of mark
everywhere they can and at the end of
the day it doesn't matter one of these
guys right just one Mark to give you
guys perspective here just one alternate
reality version of Mark was enough to
kill the entire Guardians of the globe
now one of the bigger moments here comes
from Rex Spode as you guys know Rex is
kind of a dick right like seemingly he's
selfish he only really cares about
himself but here's a funny thing Rex has
it where it counts right that's the big
difference at the end of the day when it
comes down to it he's the guy you want
on your side and the way this plays out
is that where these different versions
of Mark are kind of going nuts and
they're killing all you know the this
version of Mark is killing the Guardians
of the globe that Darkwing actually
steps in and whisks one of them away to
the shadow verse to basically and then
kind of sacrifices himself in the
process to take out that version of Mark
but the damage is done right I mean this
guy's been pummeling the Guardians of
the globe not only that he absolutely
crushed monster girl and there's still a
Mark here and that's the crazy thing
because at that point it's kind of like
okay like let's do what we can to try to
take this guy out monster girl seems to
be completely out of commission she's
not dead but she's totally out of
commission you end up having robot who
grabs her and manages to get her away
but only at the behest of Rex Rex Spode
Rex spode's like get out of here you
know leave this guy to me right I'll
take care of this guy and so what ends
up happening is reod when the question
is kind of asked like how could you
possibly beat me right like I could just
pop your head off your shoulders I took
out your entire team I could literally
kill you right now go find the other
three who flew away and then kill them
he's like you've got absolutely nothing
that you can detonate you've got no
weapons your wrist launcher is totally
drained out you have nothing that you
can do here he's like what what are you
possibly going to charge and explode and
rode says my skeleton and just Deton
himself and in doing so takes out that
version of Mark in the process Rex Spode
kills himself in order to save like the
rest of the team from just that one guy
right now you end up having Cecil who
shows up to the actual Mark right the
real Mark the main Mark and says like we
need you here man but Adam Eve has been
like seriously injured so much so that
she's in like the ICU right hooked up to
like a a mask and everything sitting in
the hospital and Mark's like no I'm not
going anywhere I'm staying here with
Adam eeve right she needs me here you
have the entirety of the world's
superheroes at your disp osal you can do
this without me and ultimately C's like
man I really hope so but at the end of
the day it really isn't enough there are
a lot of these marks that have been
taken out but then you get to day three
in day three you have eight marks left
and that's it there's really nothing
else like everybody's basically been
conquered like the world has just been
completely and totally taken out
angstrom Levy's his whole plot his
scheme came to fruition and so he
basically shows back up to where the
rest of the marks are and he says okay
so here's the idea right this world in
Ruins this invincible reputation is
totally destroyed people will always
hate and fear him and that was the goal
of what he was shooting for it's not
enough to defeat Invincible that he has
to kind of make him he has to
essentially ostracize him from society
he has to put him in a place where he
can never operate as a superhero in the
world again no one will ever trust him
the government will always watch him and
if at all possible they'll in imprison
him right they'll incarcerate him
whatever the case is they'll never let
him go back to the life that he had
before and he says there's only one
thing left I want to physically deform
this guy I want to disfigure this guy I
want him to know the pain pain that I
feel and so he tells all the other marks
find him and bring him to me and they're
like no no we're not going to do
that they literally say no and the
reason why is because the extent of the
bargain that was made between angstrom
Levy and these alternate reality
versions of Mark is that these versions
here the ones that had like killed their
mom right or the ones who had sided with
omn man or even the ones who had killed
omn man and taken his place like these
different versions of Mark that are here
the deal that was made between them and
angstrom Levy was once they basically
laid waste to this World left this place
in shambles that he would help them
expand their Empires into other
dimensions so seemingly they've all
conquered their worlds right they've all
conquered Earth whether in the name of
the vure Mite Empire or in their own
name they've conquered all their Earths
maybe even the universe itself and
they're looking to expand out expand
their sphere of influence into other
realities and so denying this is like no
no no like we're we're just going to
like we'll just leave right like send us
back and allow us to achieve our goal or
we're going to kill you and so
ultimately he ends up sending them in to
other dimensions now here's the thing
when they get moved into this this
alternate reality they're all in the
same place right like they're they're
all locked away in the same alternate
reality which is a terrible decision
because now they're all pissed off at
him right so it's not enough to put them
in the same place to where they could
presumably get out now you're going to
have them all coming after you following
that you end up having the actual Mark
who leaves and comes directly at
angstrom Levy right and this guy is
coming at him with a Vengeance like
before it was oh my God I can't believe
I killed him now there's a desire to
right now there's a desire among Mark
kill this guy right not only Mark but
his younger brother and seemingly
everybody else to take this guy out do
him in right just just kill this guy
initially his younger brother's like
look at what he did around look look at
what he did to the world like kill him
right look at what he did to everything
like he's like he's like this guy right
here right this is an example of what
happens when you stop yourself from
killing someone and look at what he did
right like if this guy was a was a
person who could have been redeemed he
would have been redeemed but you gave
him an opportunity to live you gave him
a choice either go back to being having
some semblance of a regular life and
stop being a villain or go back to being
a villain right do your own your own
criminal thing and he's like you gave
him an option here men like that cannot
be allowed to live criminals cannot be
allowed to live if given the choice
between being a good guy or being a bad
guy they will always be a bad guy why
because it's what they know stop being a
milk sock right stop being weak at the
knees if you'd killed him none of this
would have happened in the first place
and that's a legitimate argument right
that's a credible argument the proof is
in the pudding this all happened because
Mark allowed him to live the world has
basically been torn to shambles millions
and millions of of people have died
because of a poor decision on behalf of
Mark and that's the aspect of being a
superhero that we don't like to talk
about there comes a time when those
folks just got to die and for angstrom
Levy it was a long time ago but because
of Mark's poor decision-making he
basically he set the stage and he
effectively allowed angstrom Levy to do
everything that he's done here right and
so it's one of those things where Mark's
like you know what you're right like
you're absolutely right like he
literally tells us right brother you're
100% right I'm killing this guy right
now in Levy ends up opening a portal and
teleporting away back to his base of
operations of course Mark grabs his arm
his arm gets cut off in the process and
then in turn when he shows up to his
henchmen he's like I need you guys to
get me back to normal you know like like
we need his blood you guys have to help
me like we got to go take out Mark and
the response they make is no promises
were made angstrom Levy you gave us
assurances we had a deal and you failed
you do not get a second chance you do
not give us orders you work for us now
and so then you switch to day four
what's left of the world the world in
complete and total shambles
here okay so after leaving you guys on
the clii of Cliff hangers left you guys
hanging like Sylvester Stallone uh I
figured I would go ahead and wrap up
this story AR yes now technically this
is the aftermath of the Invincible War
which I feel like I should change the
title of the last video that we did CU
technically it was called Invincible War
but this really just kind of gives us a
few little tidbits and then like a
massive fight right so kind of wrapping
up from some of the stuff that we saw
right the whole conflict with
invincibles kind of rampaging across the
world and stuff like that there's a few
things that go on for example if you
guys remember Russ Livingston the
astronaut that came back from Mars with
a little aliens attached to him he's
still there right and he was still
living in that apartment the whole place
was trashed and a couple of firemen come
in to sort of clean the place out and of
course they get ins snared and they help
him find a new place against their will
but they do it anyway Immortal who was
basically killed of course is brought
back as you would expect with with the
immortal himself Mark is offered a
position to kind of lead the the
Guardians of the globe Mark turns it
down he's like he's injured my L's on in
it I have no desire to be a part of any
of that or or any of that kind of stuff
and so Mark ends up going out to
basically deal with cleanup Duty right
to help remove a lot of the rubble and
to help people out stuff like that
here's kind of an interesting thing
right I don't know how many of you guys
know this um but one of the things that
happens when they have like major
incidents like this right huge buildings
collapse things like that you can't just
go in with like an augur right or like a
back ho and just start digging up rubel
because it could very well be that a 5T
long 2x4 is the only thing keeping all
that stuff intact and if you pull that
out it'll all just come crashing down
and any survivors that might be there
are killed right so you have to be super
careful in terms of how you do it that's
why the process takes so long so you
wouldn't normally see a person doing
what Mark's doing here which is
basically just grabbing giant chunks of
debris and just throwing them out of the
way you wouldn't really see that process
but in the midst of Mark doing all this
cleanup there's a couple things to know
one there's an exceedingly high level of
guilt here and a lot of this stems from
the fact that he let angstrom Levy live
and angstrom Levy living is what led to
all this in the first place when
angstrom Levy just basically went around
to all those different realities grabbed
all those versions of invincible brought
them here and then had them all
basically go on a campaign to conquer
the world and to smear the the name of
Mark in the hopes that that of course
Antion would help them conquer their own
Dimensions right or find New Dimensions
to conquer rather uh and so Mark's
feeling a lot of regret here and where
you would expect this to be a time when
he could deal with all this regret and
all this all this remorse suddenly he's
met by the arrival of a Vite who shows
up here and says I am your replacement
if you guys recall that discussion that
he had with an as he said like there's
going to be a Vite who will come here it
could be 6 months it could be 6 years
who knows but they will come here and
they will be appointed to replace you to
basically assess everything you've done
and if you have not conquered this world
in the name of the vmite Empire or
you're not on your way to doing so
they'll kill you and they'll take your
place and that's basically what this guy
is right he's like I'm here to take this
place over by the by the Empire at this
point Mark's not having it man Mark's
like no look I am in no position to
listen to this man like I am this is not
a good time for you to come here with
your little preaches about how you're
you're here to to fix my mistakes and
refusing to conquer this world and like
this guy's like it doesn't really matter
right like my name is Conquest I have
never failed to assimilate a chosen
Planet no matter how strong it is you
can oppose me if you want to but just
know that if you do you're going to die
right and Mark Mark comes back with this
amazing line right he's just like ever
since all this popped off right like
this world that I care about all the
people on it like theyve they've been
ripped a pieces multiple times right
first it was my dad and it was various
villains and then it's then like it's
this all these marks from all alterate
realities that came here and all that
kind of stuff what I feel right now is
anger right I feel guilt and I feel
shame and the only thing that I've
thought about since all this is popped
off the only thing that I've wanted to
do was hit something as hard as I can
thank you for coming here Conquest you
now have a purpose and like a fight
breaks out between these guys now let me
tell you something man this fight is
brutal I mean it is it is intense and
and if I'm being honest with you guys I
think it's more intense than the fight
between Mark and his dad right like it's
it was nuts right this this fight was a
amazing now as soon as this breaks out
right Cecil's like are you serious man
like of all the times this could have
happened it's got to happen now right
like in the middle of all of this it's
got to happen now so here's the crazy
thing his scientific guy right the guy
who was making like the the Rihanna Man
and all that kind of stuff Sinclair
apparently what they've done is they've
taken the bodies of the invincibles who
were killed and they're reanimating them
they're turning them into soldiers right
now it's taking a long time to do but
ceil man this guy's always up to
something man when we first started a
Miss well I told you guys Cecil man this
guy's not to be trusted right like this
guy's got problems like he's he's a bad
guy right he's got issues now going back
to Mark and and Conquest CU that's
honestly all you guys really care about
here going back to Mark and Conquest
this fight is nuts right because Mark's
kind of punching him here and there and
and kind of getting the upper hand on
him a little bit or seeming to do that
and at the end he's kind of like okay
look like it's it's one of these things
where it's almost like this guy's kind
of goating him on as they fight he's
like you know that's a that's a good
punch right it's cute but the important
thing here is Mark's like okay like he's
doing everything he can against that guy
kind of fighting but one thing to know
Mark's continuing to hold back Mark is
still still operating with this
ridiculous assumption that Heroes
shouldn't kill people unless they
absolutely have to right it's the last
resort of a superhero like there there
like there's a time when it's just like
okay look this just needs to happen
right like there's no holding back
there's no you know well you know I got
to pull my punches I got to make sure I
do the right thing and take the high
ground because you know that's what
Heroes do and like no no no no there
comes a time when it's just like you're
a bad guy time to die and like that's it
end of the end of the road right done
there's no slippery slope argument here
all you have to do is just create a code
of ethics for yourself which may include
killing people and create parameters
when whereby it is acceptable to kill
people right just because you're a
superhero says you know what there are
people you know I kill people sometimes
doesn't mean you kill everyone all the
time those are two stally different
things right and one does not lead to
the other they don't have to because
you're a sentient functioning human
being so here's the crazy thing right
like while this whole great big huge
fight's going on between Mark and and
Conquest his mom of course is why
watchingg the whole thing unfold but so
is Oliver and Oliver basically bolts off
right to to go hang out with Mark now
the crazy thing is despite all this
going on Mark and conquests are still
too fast for Oliver but he's doing what
he can now this is the biggest issue
that Oliver has right Mark's biggest
problem is he doesn't kill anybody even
when he needs to and even when it's the
best choice to make Oliver's problem is
he's Reckless that's Oliver's problem
he'll just jump right into a conflict
without giving it any real thought or
any real measure as to what it is that
he should be doing or if he should even
be here in the first place now Mark
tries to stop Conquest for a second and
tries to reason with him for a second
but again the failing of Mark the desire
to talk the desire to reason the desire
to use words and so Oliver steps in and
that's kind of the thing right as soon
as Oliver jumps in like Conquest like
who who the heck are you you know and
he's like well it doesn't matter you
know don't worry about that Oliver tells
him his rest smells like feet which is
probably true and so so Mark's like okay
right like Mark sends Oliver out of
there says you got to get out of here
you can't stay here and that's when
Conquest kind of chimes in and that's
the funny thing about this right that's
the interesting thing about this if you
guys go back and like you watch the
scene on Amazon when Mark fights his dad
or you read about it in the comics his
father is teaching him to fight as a
Vite while they fight right he's he's
basically giving him lessons he's
teaching him what it means to be
somebody who can basically face against
all comers and that's the whole that
that's the whole philosophy that's what
it means to really be a superhero is
sometimes you just got to kill and
that's the lesson that that Conquest is
teaching Mark now he's not teaching it
out of altruism right he's not here to
be a mentor he's here to kill the guy
right like he's here to kill mark but
it's an inadvertent lesson that's being
taught to him right Mark tells Oliver no
go get out of here the response to
Conquest is you idiot you need all the
help that you can get lesson being
taught here you can't always win on your
own and sometimes you really need to ask
for help in these times when you're
facing such an insurmountable threat
that you just can't defeat it by
yourself right the other part of this is
he ask him like where's your Vite heart
you know until I see it beating in my
hand I won't believe that you have it
show me your power show me your rage
constantly pushing Mark constantly
pushing Mark and that's been kind of the
secret behind mark this entire time Mark
holds back because he's trying to be the
good guy he's trying to be the good
thing he has not figured out yet that
there are some points you just you just
got to do the guy in and fighting back
against Conquest as best he can when he
goes in for a punch Conquest catches his
fist and says if this is all the
strength that you possess this is not
going to end well for you so if you're
serious about this fight then fight like
you're serious but if you're not serious
about this fight let me know now put
your guard down and I'll just I'll take
you out right I'll kill you right here
and now and then as soon as I'm done
I'll kill everybody else right like my
goal here is to prep this world for the
arrival of the vure Mind Empire and I
will achieve my goal whether you're
alive or not and so you switch over to
Eve for a second right now I told you
guys I told you guys in the early days
when we were doing the Invincible run
Eve would become incredibly important
and she would become astronomically
powerful right she would become hugely
powerful so much so she would be the
most powerful person throughout the
entire roster of the Invincible Comics
this comes when Eve wakes up right it
doesn't come in this exact moment but it
starts when Eve wakes up now she ends up
seeing the TV Mark's basically facing
off against some crazy guy out there her
mom makes a statement while Mark is
fighting against his father you know and
she's like okay he's like okay he's
fighting against somebody out there
maybe it's not his dad I have no idea
maybe it is who knows but you kind of
get this little bit of a back and forth
right where E's like okay she basically
ends up you know having the doctor get a
hold of Cecil so Cecil can teleport her
directly to where Mark is fighting
because obviously she won't be able to
get there fast enough or can't get there
as fast as she would like to be her
bones are broken right I mean like her
her leg leg's broken you know she got
all kinds of injuries she doesn't care
right so from there you switch back over
to Mark right and again Conquest is just
kind of tearing into him and just kind
of like like really just goating him
along the way like this this doesn't
really I mean as much as as much as it
seems to be an even fight and in some
way it is it's also completely uneven
right I mean one like Conquest looks
older than Nolan which means he seems to
have lived a lot longer than Nolan has
Nolan has been around for a few thousand
years so Conquest seems to have been
around longer than that but he even goes
as far as to say like I've met your
father right like I never spent a whole
lot of time with him but like I met him
right he showed so much promise and now
he's dead right I heard his execution
finally went off without a hitch you
know and that's that's really sad
because I would love to have seen the
look on your father's face when I told
him I came to the world that used to be
his and I killed his son right inner
Oliver Oliver comes flying in just just
comes swooping in right says this guy
flying and then he's then like the guy's
right back on his feet again right and
the whole time Mark Mark being an idiot
is like no Oliver you can't be here
Oliver you got to go you can't stay
Oliver you know you got to you got to go
you got to go be safe and ultimately
like Oliver gets picked up by by
Conquest he starts to rip him in half
mark responds and starts pummeling this
guy the damn breaks Mark's had enough
right like Markus Markus sick and tired
of all this guy's nonsense but even then
like even him fighting he's still not
able to really put the put the marks
into this guy to really Pummel and beat
this guy down the way that he needs to
enter Adam Eve now when Adam Eve shows
up here man it is man is man it's a
sight to behold right it's is one of the
craziest things so Adam Eve shows up
here she's like you're not omn man and
he's like yeah bad news for you mark
steps in and tells Adam Eve you got to
get out of here right like Conquest
breaks Mark's leg goes after Adam Eve
like she creates a force field around
him he shatters the force field he's
like girl your problems are just
beginning right punches this girl in the
face boom impales her through the
stomach that's the end of Adam Eve and
it's is like wow like he just killed
Adam Eve holy cow right like he just
killed this girl Mark just like what you
know and that's that's this is it right
this is this is this is the snap this is
it right here right this is the snap
this is the crazy thing about this right
here's here's the crazy thing about this
so Mark goes to comforter the damn
breaks right Mark's just like nope done
like like we're not we're not playing
we're not playing this game because he
starts to basically like like make fun
of it he's like so she's finally dead
damn it took her long enough she must
have been a really great girl as she
came came all the way here just to die
in front of you right you know that
that's crazy he's like God you know her
blood does taste delicious you know like
like literally just goating this guy
taunting him right and Mark's like
that's it I'm done like I don't care how
strong you are I don't care how fast you
are I've been to the Future and you
don't live to see tomorrow like you do
not live to see the future Mark
completely snaps right like any any
chance this guy had against Mark is gone
these guys go flying towards each other
mark shatters his robotic hand so this
guy is down one hand and Mark just
starts ping this and he's literally
doing everything he can right he bites
this guy when I say bite I mean he takes
a chunk out of it right like takes a
huge chunk out of him now while all
that's going on Eve starts powering up
right just all this light energy just
starts powering up out of nowhere and
then literally it's just this huge
explosion of a of like a force of energy
while Mark's just beating the crap out
of conquest and then in this moment when
Eve kind of flashes out that she gets
Mark's attention for a split second and
then you have Conquest who gets the
upper hand on Mark and then Eve
completely reforms her body blasts
blasts Conquest with all this energy
incinerates his skin on his body Eve
passes out Mark takes the opportunity
and just starts just starts smashing
this guy right like just headbutting him
into Oblivion to the point that this
guy's face is just absolutely mush right
just just crushing this guy and he's
like done right like that's it like like
I'm done you know like Mark just snaps
you know at that point he gets over to
where Eve's at and Eve Eve is like am I
naked and he's like yeah you're you're
kind of a little bit naked and then Mark
passes out and Eve kind of passes out
but nonetheless of course Mark wakes up
later in the hospital Eve's at his side
and she's kind of like oh man you were
so brave you know like you fought that
guy now of course there is the funeral
for Rex Spode and this is kind of
interesting right after Mark's
recovering and and kind of getting back
one of the things that does happen is he
does mute with Cecil and he's like show
me the body of this guy right like Cecil
shows him the body and he's like okay I
just needed to know he was dead right
after everything that happened with
angstrom Levy he needed to know this guy
was actually dead right because he left
angstrom Levy for dead only for angram
Levy to actually be alive and start
unleashing holy hell with all these
marks and everything and so when you get
to this kind of funeral between or
really with with Rex Spode there's a lot
that kind of goes on there right like
you've got this whole thing with Eve
where she's having a very difficult time
with it not necessarily because of the
fact that she's deeply in love with Rex
a lot of this is because of the fact
that he was her first right I mean
that's the thing there's a kind of
emotional bond that forms with someone
when they're your first she never got to
say goodbye and see and and knowing that
he died because he sacrificed his life
to save others around him was something
that she never thought that he would
ever do right she always thought that he
would always be a jerk and so there's a
little bit of of remorse and regret here
you know because she she asked Mark
she's like you know can I say that I
loved him you know is it is it weird if
I say that and Mark Mark being a man of
confidence is like no I mean I wouldn't
be mad about that right you know if
you're like an insecure guy you be like
no I don't want to hear you say that
because I'm afraid that you might you
know reanimate his corpse and day and
you know but but he's like yeah I mean
it makes perfect sense the guy was your
first like you guys spend a lot of time
together I mean there was a bond there
that you and he had that you and I just
won't have right because of the the the
things the the parts of yourselves that
you shared in a way that you'd never
done it before and so he's kind of like
you know it's totally understandable
that you feel the way that you feel it's
totally understandable that you're
crushed like that and so what you end up
doing is you end up jumping to the the
block which as you guys know is largely
the prison that's kind of ran by Cecil
and of course this is out in some
defense Outpost you know out out in the
Mojave Desert and you've got Cecil there
and what you have there is the head of
conquest and His Infinite Wisdom what
Cecil has done here is he showed Mark a
fake body that was not actually Conquest
the body that Cecil showed Mark that was
not actually him and instead what's
happened is he's put Conquest in a 400
ton block of solid tempered steel and
that Conquest is not actually dead like
most vulture mites he's wildly durable
and of course his healing factor is
kicking in and his body is basically
healing the intention of Cecil is that
when he snaps back right when he comes
back that Cecil is going to basically
interrogate Conquest so Conquest will
tell him everything he wants to know
about the Vite Empire of course we will
come back to that later on down the line
but this kind of ends when you have Mark
having a conversation with Oliver and
this is cool because as the two of them
are talking that Oliver is kind of
asking about how Eve's doing and so on
and how Mom's doing and and and
basically Mark's kind of ging you know
filling a man you know all that kind of
stuff and then Mark expresses this deep
frustration of the fact that he thought
all this was over right he thought that
like this was all said and done that he
could finally have some measure of Peace
in his life and of course the vilter
might just keep on coming and so when
Oliver apologizes and he says look I'm
sorry about everything that's happened
the response of Mark is no I'm the one
who should be apologizing to you right
the past few weeks I've been training
you I think I've learned more than you
have right I've scolded you I've yelled
at you thought I knew better I thought
you were misguided and naive but I was
wrong you were right the whole time but
I never learned my lesson he says
someone tries to hurt my family someone
I love if there's another villain out
there putting lives in danger who's just
going to keep coming at me until they
finally succeed I won't hesitate to kill
them Mark has finally grown up Mark has
left this kind of wide-eyed childhood
navity behind and he's accepted the
world as it exists and has except to the
fact that you can't always win with
rainbows and hearts and and love and
shiny pretty things and a desire to
understand other people's feelings the
world doesn't work that way that the
world can be harsh and the world can be
brutal and it can be cruel it's not
always like that but there are times
when it is and people who follow this
philosophy that like kindness and
happiness and understanding feelings is
the way to make it in the world they
don't last right they they they just
they cannot make it in those hard times
and so mark understanding that
philosophy and Mark understanding there
are times when I'm going to have to go
to the Limit and there are times when
I'm going to have to kill people that's
him growing up and accepting the way the
world is it's one of the coolest
Revelations of the entirety of the story
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with invincible and this is
technically the Prelude to the Vite War
right how the war kind of starts ramping
up things like that so what we're going
to do here is we're largely going to
skip over what Mark is doing with the
exception of a couple different things
and we're mostly going to focus on
what's happening with omn man Allen the
alien the Coalition of Worlds all that
kind of stuff right so the first thing
we get here is basically the origin of
the vites as it truly exists as opposed
to the kind of little tidbits of
information that we got over the course
of those early issues and so one of the
first things that's basically hit on
here is that when it comes to the Vite
race that initially they were just a
wildly powerful race that occupied a
world and that was basically it but
along the way because they were so
violent and because they were looking to
become the most powerful race in
existence or at least more beyond what
they already were what they started
doing was calling the weakest of their
race right as they say a team is only a
strong as its weakest member and so
because there were weak individuals here
they cast them out or destroyed them
well they really just destroyed them
they didn't even cast them out at all
but they just eradicated them completely
and then in turn they started focusing
on building their race up and kind of
allowing the strongest individuals to
rule uh and that was basically it right
so there was really no weakness among
the Vite race and so what you ended up
having along the way was that they while
they were just
overwhelming just this overwhelming
force that suddenly their enemies
created a virus now this is the funny
thing about that we're actually going to
learn more about this here in a here in
a little bit but a virus basically came
into existence called The Scourge virus
that basically swept across the entirety
of the vmite race and only two things
happened either those individuals who
were infected some of them succumbed to
the virus and basically died of it or
for others they experienced weakness
right they kind of lost their
invulnerability and so in doing so
threats that would normally be something
they could easily overwhelm they were
destroyed by and so the result is that
over the course of this period of time
while it ravaged their race about
99.9% of all vites were completely
destroyed the irony about this and the
crazy thing is despite all of that the
Vite Empire endured and we'll actually
find out why because thrag or Freddy
Mercury as you guys like to call him was
the guy who basically pull it off now
one of the crazy things about this this
is what's so nuts about the vmite Empire
what they did with the bodies of those
who died they actually turned them into
a ring around their own world and so
following that a couple of things
happened the first is that the vites
basically used the reputation as a means
to instill fear Across the Universe if
people knew there were only 50 vilter
mites left at that point they would just
be like throw everything at them right
just be a war of attrition and
eventually they would just wear them
down right it might take a long long
time to do and countless people would
die but at the end of the day if the the
universe wanted to get rid of the vites
that would be a sacrifice they would
have to be willing to make and so using
their reputation to basically kind of go
forward and say we're like we're a Super
Mighty race and then having one member
of the vites show up to a different
planet and then conquer it in the name
of the vmite Empire just the name of the
Empire itself instilled enough fear that
most races basically bent to it at least
most of those races that were confronted
bent the KNE to the vmite Empire those
who didn't were basically eradicated or
at least forced into subservience the
other thing is the vites actually
started experimenting with cross
breeding which is to say breeding with
other races that were out there and this
is the reason why Earth is so important
because what Nolan says is that humans
are basically perfectly compatible with
vites and that procreating with a human
would basically stand the best chance of
bringing vites back up to where they
were before right kind of increasing
their ranks and returning them back to
quote unquote The Glory Days of the
Empire and that's the one secret about
why it is that Nolan was truly on Earth
that he never told Mark that the planet
was going to be turned into a breeding
Camp right they were literally going to
continue their campaign of Conquering
the universe and while doing that
essentially have humans procreate with v
and then produce children it's pretty
twisted and it's pretty sadistic and
screwed up but at the end of the day
that was the whole purpose of the Empire
now again Nolan's turned against the
Vite so that's the reason why he's
really spilling the beans to to Allen
the alien because he's trying to provide
as much information as possible that can
be used to bring down the builtrite
rates and so the results of this is he's
like I need to talk to the guy who runs
a coalition of Worlds now from there you
basically pick up with with Allan the
alien arriving at home to his girl and
then like as soon as they they kind of
you know they kind of start doing a
little little of the damn thing and then
like Nolan shows up
and she immediately freaks out and
starts firing on him with a giant cannon
that she keeps under the couch whenever
her husband's away but once it all
settles down you basically have Nolan
who meets with with Allan now one of the
things to know is that Nolan is
basically wearing a costume here and the
whole reason for that is because no
one's supposed to know he's there if
people just knew that Nolan Nolan you
know that a vilter might was on the
planet they would freak and it's one of
the things that kind of keep in mind
here the leader of the Coalition of
Worlds we know he's a vure m nobody else
does well I guess Allen the alien does
but like almost nobody else does right
because the the disdain for the viles is
so extreme they would oust him now of
course this information is revealed to
Nolan and Nolan says fine if that's true
I want you to pull the tck right I want
you to do this two lock pull in front of
me and show that it's true basically
means pulling his beard out and of
course you know he's kind of you know
Allan's like dude he did it man he's a
filterite it's good chill don't make
this poor sap pull his beard out again
and so the result of this is that Nolan
and Allen are basically given a task
which is a really cool concept here the
Coalition of Worlds is really by all
standards of measurement at least in
comparison to the power and the strength
of the vmite Empire running on a Sho
string budget right I mean they have a
lot of of sources that are there but
when it comes to just raw power and
strength they're not on the same level
as the vure mites right like Allen is
like the only well at least was the only
member of the Coalition of Worlds that
was on the same level as the vure mites
and that took almost forever to get to
that point right it took a long time for
him to get to that point and so
basically what they've been sent on here
is a mission to travel to Cosmos and to
find various people out there that can
help them and and really kind of enlist
in the aid of the Coalition of world so
they can basically destroy the vites
right it's literally just building up
their resources building up their forces
is really all this is now one of the
things that happens here is you
basically have Nolan who leads Allen to
a guy by the name of the Space Racer and
there's a gun of the Space Racer laying
here this is a really cool concept by
Robert Kirkman the way this works is
that the Space Racer and Nolan fought
previously and Nolan defeated him and
then essentially killed him the problem
with this is that the gun cannot be
touched there's a relationship between
the Space Racer and the gun and that if
Nolan were to pick it up that basically
it would leave his leave his control and
go immediately to the Space Racer and
then basically resurrect it more so than
that the only person who can fire the
gun is the Space Racer so it's
exceedingly unique to him and that's why
it was just left here now the idea is
that because it's been so long there's
not really any major concern to worry
about and the gun is what they were
after in the first place the problem is
that as soon as Nolan touches it the gun
takes off to a pile of reubel and
basically resurrects the Space Racer now
it's kind of a funny thing because this
gun basically fires indestructible
bullets right like whatever it is that
this gun shoots will die it's just it's
just one of those things and so
obviously you want to use it when it
comes to the vites the problem with this
is that the gun ends up firing off and
literally blowing a hole in an asteroid
which sets off a chain reaction and just
has the asteroid Bel all of them start
crashing into each other so of course
they end up escaping they basically bail
out of there and then Space Racer
follows them back to the Coalition of
Worlds once they make a convincing
enough case that you know Space Racer
should believe in them right because the
initial reaction of the Space Racer is
to kill Nolan right like that's like his
first response is to like kill this guy
and they're like look man well like I'm
I'm sorry that we fought before I'm
sorry I did all the stuff that I did
before I didn't realize how screwed up I
was how wrong I was at this moment right
now I'm here to basically make things
right that's what I want to do here so
come back to the Coalition of Worlds I'm
trying to do things right team up with
us and we'll take out the rest of the
vites and so from there it's just
following from one location to the next
now one of the funny things that happens
is after this mission that you have
Nolan who's basically crashing in Allen
the alien's house for a few months and
like Allen the alien and his wife are
just like banging right I mean and and
from what it seems like like when they
do the damn thing they do the damn thing
right like I mean it's
it's it's all noisy and stuff Allan's
just like like keeping his ears covered
as best he can and Allan's like dude are
we are we're not keeping you up are he's
like
no it's one of those funny moments I
really hope they keep that in the show
like I'm I'm so hoping they bring that
in the show but the next stop is
basically showing up on a on a kind of
Frozen World here this place that
basically houses these well really
aliens called the Ragnar now these are a
big deal right the way that Nolan
explains it like they are vicious and
they have to be careful and when the
vmes discovered that race of monsters
they sent a few teams to try to destroy
them and basically the monsters
destroyed the vites right and in fact
Conquest was one of those not really
destroyed but like you know that's
that's how he lost his arm in the first
place and but the whole thing behind
this is these things are capable of
killing vites the problem is that a
Cannon's fired off and when that happens
like the whole thing melts right like
literally this whole entire Place melts
and because of that uh all these things
start thawing out right and so
ultimately the mission scrub right
they're like we got to get out of here
because if they stay they're probably
going to die right so while the things
are still alive and they're still on
that world it's really Kirkman just kind
of being like okay like we can use those
for a future point in time and in fact
that's what the leader does right like
the leaderly Coalition that's what he
does he's like okay look so you know the
mission is not a total loss we know
where they are and so maybe we can just
like pick a whole bunch of them up and
then just like drop them off in front of
the vites and let him be a distraction
I'm not entirely sure but from there
again it's just kind of following along
all these different things right the
clais plant is poisonous to Vite so they
grab that they end up going to the home
world of battle Beast to try to find him
to recruit him to the cause of the Vite
EMP Empire it's just visiting all these
different locations and all these
different places and so what you end up
doing is once it's all kind of done and
they've grabbed whatever allies they
could based on this Mission you have
this moment where Nolan is brought into
a kind of room by the leader and has
basically shown the reality of what went
on that the leader was the first vure
might to really defect away from the
vure Mite Empire more so than that the
scourge virus was not created by some
enemy of the vites I mean I guess it was
but it was basically created by this guy
right like using his own his own
genealogy right his own genetic
signature he basically created The
Scourge virus and what he's been doing
all this time was actually amplifying it
improving it it's kind of a last ditch
effort and saying like if this is the
this is what it really comes down to
we'll use this to annihilate what's left
of the uh of the the vites themselves
now kind of jumping back to Earth here
for a second not really doing a whole
lot here but kind of jumping back to
Earth for a second a couple things we
know at the end of The Last Story that
Conquest had been captured by Cecil and
then was being held at like this great
big huge thing this is just one of those
examples of Cecil being an idiot right
like you know what like a 400 t chunk of
metal sure that'll keep a guy who's
powerful enough to fly through space
uned hold his breath for weeks at a time
you know and is one of the most powerful
beings in the history of the universe
like sure that'll hold him oh no wait a
minute no it
won't and so this guy literally just
breaks out of the Mojave facility and
just flies back to the flies like
literally flies out of space and goes
back to the to the vure might Empire
there is the whole idea of like The seet
Invasion if you guys remember that the
whole idea of like those little squid
looking things that kind of happens a
little bit and it's basically defeated
it's a it's a minor plot point if I'm
being honest I think Kirkman wrapped it
up here to make way for the Vite War um
there's not a whole lot that goes on
there right it's just a bit of a
conflict and people are ins snared and
so on but there is a massive development
that goes on here right Mark spending
time with Adam Eve and as you guys know
they've they've been touching naughty
bits and Eve is just freaking out
because she's in the bathroom right
she's like leave me alone right as soon
as Mark knocks on the door she's like
leave me alone he's like okay and then
you find out she took a pregnancy test
and Eve is prer but like it's it's kind
of cool right I mean these are these are
a couple of things that are sort of
going on on here again sort of skimming
over what's happening on Earth so we can
get back to the rest of the stuff uh but
nonetheless with regard to Conquest once
he gets back to essentially the base of
operations of the vites he comes into
contact with thrag now thrag is the guy
who runs the show of the Vite race of
course you guys like calling him Freddy
Mercury from that one video that we did
and I'm wholly on board with that
because if ever there were a guy who
looked like Freddy Mercury it's
basically this guy and I'd love to
believe he listens to Bohemian rap city
I guarantee there's going to be Freddy
Mercury memes in the show as soon as
thrag is introduced I guarantee that's
going to happen people are going to be
like Freddy Mercury so that's where he
went right like like people are going to
start coming out with all these crazy
conspiracies and whatnot but the whole
thing behind thrag is this guy is
powerful and as the leader of the Vite
race you would kind of expect him to be
right that's one of the things about the
Vite race that we talked about is it's
not necessarily based on a a kind of
line of royalty it is to a degree but
it's really more akin to like the
Spartan Empire right the strongest rules
that particular group right rules that
race and if a situation were to arise
where like you have a guy who who runs
the uh the vure Empire and somebody else
is stronger and they rise to prominence
and top with that guy that's the nature
of things right the survival of the
fittest and Only the strongest deserve
the lead that's the entire philosophy
and so you basically have have like
Conquest who begs for his life right
which just seeing how it was that things
went down between him and Mark is an
indication of how powerful thrag is but
like begging for his life really
apologizing for his carelessness and
saying look like you know I like please
spare me uh you know at the end of the
day like all I want to do is serve in
the in the glory of the vwi Empire that
kind of a thing right ingratiating
himself so on and so forth which is kind
of a sight to see for a guy that's so
HonorBound and has been around for so
long and so incredibly powerful and so
basically Conquest is tached by thrag to
intercept Nolan and Allen the alien and
to kill them right so like do not like
like you literally says leave none alive
intercept that team destroy them and
that'll be it if you fail me you die
right that's just it's it's kind of
crazy right it's just it's nuts it's a
pretty intimidating moment between these
guys and so you do get a kind of brief
moment where Nolan and and alen the
alien show up on the doorstep of uh of
Mark and basically say like you're
needed right like you have to join me
now in reality Mark takes a moment away
and just kind of talks to Eve about this
whole thing because he doesn't know
exactly what to do right he doesn't
really know exactly what to what to
approach on this when when Eve asks him
like are you scared his response is yes
but not for what might happen to me or
even the outcome of the war not mostly
at least he says after everything that's
happened everything I've done how I've
changed vure my blood courses through
these veins I'm worried about what this
war will bring out of me and what it
could make me become that's the fear of
Mark the fear of Mark here is not dying
in the war with his dad you know
fighting in the Vite War it's not facing
off against some enemy and being just
absolutely pummeled and wrecked it's
that it'll turn him into a very dark and
evil person he'll end up becoming like
his father or at least the way his
father was what's going on guys this is
Rob and we are back with Invincible yes
we are the beginning of the vure might
War part one I guess officially the vure
might War the last video was more of a
Prelude than anything else but this is
how it all starts probably the single
greatest story arc in the entirety of
the Invincible run so one of the first
things we do here is we basically pick
up with Allan the alien and Nolan omn
man yes and they are looking for a guy
by the name of tech jacket now tech
jacket is kind of a cool concept here in
the Invincible comics and it's one of
the things where Kirkman kind of does
this slow build and that's one of the
things I hope you guys are kind of
noticing over the course of the
Invincible run that there are a lot of
similarities between like DC Comic and
Marvel Comics and Invincible but of
course it's on a much smaller scale
right now I will say that I think that
what's going on here with regards to the
kind of space fairing escapades in so
far as the action you see is a lot
bigger than DC right and if it's not
Green Lantern you never really see
anything about space in DC Comics but
with Marvel you see stuff in space all
the time thanks to Dan abet in 2006 and
Annihilation it became an even bigger
thing after that up to that point it was
just small little things here and there
but the cool thing here is that tech
jacket is basically there with his dad
and it's one of those little situations
where you kind of have omn man and
you've got Allan who are just kind of
like I mean I don't really know exactly
where this guy is but supposedly this is
his house he kind of vanished at some
point along the line but like I don't
know how powerful this guy is but all we
really know is that this is one of the
guys that they're recruiting for the
Coalition of Worlds right remember
that's their mission that we picked up
with in the last video was basically
them traveling from world to World which
included even Earth and looking for
people that could help them fight
against the vites and that's really all
they can do right is just find other
people that can help them overcome the V
and kind of call it a day you do get
this really interesting moment where
they're talking to an older guy and they
ask him like are you looking for the
Thompson kid because like they he's
probably in a space station that's where
his family took off to and they're kind
of like you're not really freaked out by
the fact that Allan's got like one eye
and and like I'm in this weird little
get up and the guys like I mean I've
seen stranger but usually bad guys don't
knock it's a pretty sound line of logic
to be honest it works man and so of
course they end up traveling to this
this kind of space station where you
have tech jacket and you have his dad
who both reside now of course when Allan
and Nolan show up the fact that they're
not bashing the place in smashing it to
Pieces obviously illustrates the fact
that they're there essentially as good
guys but tech jacket is a is is an
interesting character because we'll talk
about him in a minute instead what we
end up doing here is switching back over
to the home of Mark and and Debbie and
and all that kind of stuff and all
they're all just really kind of hanging
out right all just sort of doing their
thing and and talking and whatnot but
Mark's brother again he's still pretty
young but one of the things to remember
is he ages at a more rapid Pace than
people normally do and that's why he's
aging so fast here that's why in the
last video that we did the last couple
videos he was maybe like 8 or 9 years
old and now it looks like he's 15
because of that you know this is where
he's just kind of at that youthful age
where he's just really trying to figure
himself out for him it's more difficult
and this is something that's kind of
interesting right you know Sidetrack
this story for a second let's talk about
real life right the real life struggle
of a teenager is you are experiencing an
existential crisis that's all it is who
are you where are you going what are you
about what is the meaning of it all
right what's your purpose in this world
and in all honesty sure it starts in
your teenage years guys that never ends
like if you guys kind of approach this
from the perspective of like if I don't
have myself totally figured out by the
time I'm 30 I've somehow failed in life
well that's a terrible philosophy like
wait until you get to 30 years old you
know what's going to happen if you don't
have yourself figured out the Sun is
going to rise and the day will go on and
everything will be okay I didn't become
a YouTuber until I was 30 so I'm 37
years old now so God I've been doing
this for like seven years Jesus time
flies man but it's just one of those
things right that the nature of what it
means to be a teenager is to just kind
of panic and believe that you're
supposed to have it all figured out
you're supposed to have the answers to
everything there a lot of undue pressure
Society puts on you guys but at the end
of the day while Society starts to put
that on you you guys maintain it on
yourself and that's where you really
have to break free of all that but for
the for Mark's younger brother the whole
thing here is he wants to go and he
wants to fight in the Vite War he wants
to go and do that thing but ultimately a
lot of this frustration comes from the
fact that while Marcus talked to his dad
since his dad has been on Earth Nolan
has not come to see his other son right
he hasn't come to see him at all and
that's kind of a big crushing thing
thing right because it's one thing when
you're a little kid and you're like okay
like we got to Whiskey away and your
brother and you're you're you know not
really your biological mom but I guess
kind of like a strange mom more or less
is going to take care of you uh and then
never having heard from your father and
then when he does come back he talks to
your other brother and doesn't talk to
you right like that's got to be crushing
it's got to be a crushing experience but
he's not really approaching this from
from a place of feeling devastated he's
approaching it from a place of feeling
like but why though right it's really
more confusion than and and kind of
concern than anything else now if this
goes on long enough then it will turn
into sadness and it will turn into anger
because at this point it's kind of like
why wouldn't he want to talk to me given
enough time it's God why doesn't he why
doesn't he want to talk to me man and
then it's like why won't he talk to me
you know and it's just it kind of it it
turns into rage right and that's the
last thing this kid needs but ultimately
Mark's whole stance here is he's worried
about coming around here because at the
end of the day he doesn't know how
things are going to unfold he doesn't
know if he's ready to see Mom yet and he
doesn't know if he's ready to tell her
about all this and so we might be able
to arrange a meaning of sorts but at the
moment that's why he hasn't come around
here and at that moment DeBry walks in
and she's like what are you guys talking
about like what do you want to what do
you not want to tell me about and who is
it that's not ready to see me and then
just words off the side of the screen me
but I've since changed my mind Nolan has
come back home Nolan has come to see his
wife and I know you guys knew it was
coming I know you guys knew it was only
a matter of time before it was coming
now here's the thing The Exchange is
incredibly short this is kind of this is
writing Genius of of Robert Kirkman
right you read comic books long enough
one of the things you learn to
appreciate is the Salvo this whole
concept of like Nolan and Debbie are
talking again but only for a moment
because then what it does is it gives
you this desire to like see them
Converse right because we they haven't
talked since like Nolan left Earth since
everything popped off she learned the
truth about what was going on when when
the whole footage and everything was
released to social media like she
learned about all that stuff and and she
hasn't seen or heard from him since so
there's a lot of pent up anger and a lot
of pent up irritation there the first
thing he does is apologize and
rightfully so he literally married her
under false pretenses right he was a guy
who was sent to Earth to conquer it now
ultimately he ended up falling in love
with her and everything changed and
that's what he said he's like my time
here has changed me all those years I
spent with you raising Mark our life
together I thought it was an act I
thought I was pretending to be something
that I wasn't but I was wrong I was
changing becoming the person that you
knew what we shaped together was real
when I fought Mark I learned the truth I
was forcing myself to carry out my
mission that was an act that it was the
it was the the whole thing being turned
on its head that in reality the person
he was pretending to be is the person he
became and that's what's so interesting
right that's kind of the the gift of
Humanity that Robert Kirkman sort of
hits on here that despite some of the
Bleak moments that you see in Invincible
that it really kind of hits this idea
that from the perspective of somebody
like Nolan Humanity has this sort of
grandness about it right this sort of
Innocence that the rest of the universe
simply just doesn't have but at the end
of the day while he apologizes and he's
like I've grown to love you she just
interrupts him and stops him and says I
don't I don't think I can ever really
believe any of that noan and how could I
possibly believe any of that stuff and
at that moment he's like okay fine I
understand he says I'm sorry and he
ultimately leaves now from there you
switch over to tech jacket basically
talking to Allen the alien and the
reason why you haven't really seen tech
jacket is is as it's explained his job
is to basically monitor extraterrestrial
threats from beyond the stars right so
that's why you you kind of see him at
like great big huge events but you don't
really see him in day-to-day stuff it's
pretty smart to just kind of a stroke of
the pen and that's why you don't really
see him all that often but it is kind of
a cool thing right he's not a
traditional superhero but he is
certainly somebody capable of handling
like threats beyond the planet earth
right so he's definitely somebody the
Coalition wants to have on their side
now at that moment we switch over to
Nolan talking to his son now for Oliver
it's a little bit awkward man not going
to lie it's a little bit strange because
he's never really had a conversation
like this with his dad because he was so
young when he was taken away it's one of
these things where he's never really had
a true conversation with his father the
funny thing about this is Nolan kind of
approaches it as if it's just kind of
another day I mean he does you do kind
of get the significance that Nolan
hasn't seen a son in a long long time
but it's one of these things where it's
like let's just kind of pick up where we
left off and the reality is that Oliver
is excited for that that in a lot of
instances and I've experienced that too
when he had a parent kind of bail that
it's one of these things where it's like
but you can't pick up where you left off
right like where you left off was years
ago right where where we are now is
completely different but for Oliver the
desire to understand and to meet with
his father is so intense it doesn't
matter to him how long it's been his
father's back now and his father wants
to talk to him right and and that's kind
of the the cool thing here is it would
have been very easy for Nolan to say
okay like we'll have time together son
but for now I need to go take off and I
need to fight this threat much like what
you saw him doing with Mark pretty
consistently instead it's one of these
things where parents basically fix
mistakes that they made when they had
their first kids when it comes to
ancillary kids right second kids third
kids fourth kids so on and so forth you
know for for Oliver like his father
extends on the invitation and says you
know what why don't you come with us
right why don't you come with us on this
trip and then I can learn to understand
you better and like that's exactly what
Oliver wanted to hear because what it
puts off is my dad wants to spend time
with me from there you switch over to a
pretty tender moment between uh Adam Eve
and Mark right because remember Eve knew
this was coming she knew it was only
going to be a matter of time before the
vure might were officially kicked off
and markk had to go and so when Mark
shows up all he says is it's time and
that's all that needs to be said right
so of course they they share the night
together and he's like I don't know when
I'm going to be coming back or if I'm
even going to be coming back and of
course Eve doesn't want to hear that but
that's the reality of the situation
right this vter war that Mark is going
to fight in he may not come back he may
not survive we've seen how he's faced
off against other members of the vure
might race and it didn't go very well
right now we're talking about him Waging
War against the entire Empire right it's
going to be big it's it's a massive
thing and so in the face of that while
she is really trying to kind of blow it
off and saying no you know no no no no
that's never going to happen Mark's
really kind of holding his ground and
really facing reality here and saying
but that's something that you need to
accept the people here that we're going
to be fighting are a lot more powerful
than I am I don't know if I'm powerful
enough to defeat these guys I don't know
for sure that I'm going to survive this
but at the end of the day that's what
needs to happen right you need to
understand that and so ultimately Eve
Cuts him off and then just says like I
don't want to focus on that for right
now I just want to focus on us right if
if you're going to have to leave soon
then let these moments that we have
together be these just amazing moments
so that if you end up dying this is what
I can recall our last time together
being the downside of this of course is
that as Mark starts to fall asleep Eve
starts to ball because she's facing the
fact that she might lose Mark right that
Mark might die which is really a
testament to how much she loves him
right Eve adores that guy she she's head
over heels for him and so from there you
basically switch over to to Mark and
Oliver and and Nolan who are all just
kind of hanging out which is pretty cool
to see like the father and Sun team just
kind of working together like yeah we're
going to fight a race of Superman and we
might die but it's going to be cool like
I'm I I think that's awesome I think
that's pretty pretty cool but of course
the ship they have is also a very a ship
full of incompetent people but the
reality and the reason why they need
this ship because a lot of you guys are
probably asking if they can hold their
breath for a really long time why don't
they just fly there because the journey
is very very long and that it would take
longer for really for them to fly there
and they may not be able to hold their
breath long enough they might be able to
come across a couple planets here and
there but the reality is the universe is
a big place and the amount of knowledge
it would take for a person to know
exactly where they need to stop and to
be able to chart that effectively based
on their abilities is quite large right
the amount of time it would be kind of
insane and so it's actually easier for
them to basically just kind of Stow
aboard a ship or to use a ship that was
given to them by the Coalition and just
kind of go forward from there the
problem is that in the middle of all
this while they're basically flying it's
Wham right it's like a red alert and
everything starts popping off right and
then like like literally like some
targets coming in like super fast right
like as fast like I've never seen
anything this fast before break for
impact like the ship just explodes right
just gets smashed to Pieces the bridge
of the ship initiates this automatic
sequence right where it just like
detaches from the rest of the ship
itself so the bridge basically kind of
goes flying through space but they're
like what in the hell just happened and
it's like I don't know man but like
whatever it was it hit us and the ship
just basically broke apart now Mark's
dad is back there right Nolan's back
there and the fear is that Nolan's died
the reality is that as soon as Mark gets
out there and starts looking around
you've got conquest and you got a couple
other vilter mites with him and the
vmite war has officially begun but the
real question you have have to ask here
is that where Mark is getting ready to
fight this guy what happens to Conquest
when Nolan gets his hands on cuz I'm
going to tell you right now what Mark
did is nothing compared to what this
poor bastard's about to go
through I told you guys Invincible gets
stupidly good I told you guys it gets
amazing once you get to the Vite War
anybody who's right Invincible will tell
you that once you get to the vure might
War everything changes and the show just
becomes insanely awesome right Vite War
part two so in the last last video we
had this whole situation where Mark and
and his dad and everybody they had all
basically left earth right for the
purpose of meeting up with the coition
of Worlds and essentially preparing for
the the start of the Vite war and that's
one of the funny things right is that we
almost kind of Imagine War starting with
like somebody walks onto a field and
blows a whistle and the war begins right
instead it usually just starts with
something popping off right Arch Duke
ferdinand's driver takes a wrong turn
down the wrong road prin Up's waiting
for him his failed assassination attempt
turns into a successful assassination
attempt and World War I begins it's
always something like that right it's
always some kind of situation along
those lines and this again is where it
all starts to kick off that you've got
Mark you've got his brother Oliver and
then you've got a galarian now here's a
funny thing the galarian is basically
the Invincible stand in for the galorian
space kns from Marvel Comics those you
guys who don't know what they are you
ever heard of a character named ROM the
space Knight it's fine if you didn't ROM
hasn't been relevant in 20 years but
that's basically what it is right just
people who in effect at least in Marvel
Comics basically had their minds
Consciousness transferred into a robotic
body and then they serve as like you
know soldiers more or less protecting
the universe as best they can and
usually failing in the process so this
is essentially a rag tag bunch and
Conquest doesn't take these guys the
slightest bit serious the only one he
really seems to have any concern about
here is basically mark because he and
Mark fought before and Mark kind of
started to get the upper hand or at
least demonstrated the fact that he is
pretty capable when it comes to facing
against Conquest the biggest issue here
is that when it comes to these guys
right these these vilter mites that
whenever they sustain an injury when
they heal they're stronger than they
were when they first sustain the injury
in the first place right they just kind
of grow stronger as time goes on now
again all that kind of has to do with
age they don't really progress at the
same rate as somebody like Allen the
alien does right like he gets a lot
stronger a lot faster than vites do
hence the reason why he caught up with
them in terms of strength so incredibly
quickly but vites do get stronger as
they're injured and as they recover and
as they grow older with age and so Mark
is kind of a credible threat here but
not enough for them to really Panic
instead it's one of these things where
literally Conquest whole stance is I'm
going to save you for last instead what
I'm going to do is I'm going to kill
everybody else here and then I'm going
to kill you I want you to watch as I
kill everybody that you know and care
about here in this particular location
and then once I'm done with you then I'm
going to go back to Earth and then I'm
going to take care of earth right it's a
Kill Order on Mark that's basically what
it is that the Vite Empire is not taking
any chances and it makes perfect sense
right that one of the things that was
solidified in the previous videos that
we talked about is that there is a Kind
of Perfect connection between the human
race and vites and that because of that
there is almost this ideology that when
a child is born as a product of a Vite
and a human that they're actually
stronger than vites or possess the
potential to become stronger than a Vite
at a much faster rate and so it's one of
these things where it's like just get
rid of the world right get rid of Earth
I mean ideally we would turn it into a
planet where we would basically turn
into a breeding ground but assuming we
can do that just nullify it knock it out
of the way and then we'll continue
conscripting whatever races exist Across
the Universe and keep our Empire alive
that way right it's getting rid of any
major and incredible threats that exist
there the funny thing about this is that
this is payback time for Mark as well as
for Nolan and the reason why is of
course Nolan and Conquest have met
previously but as soon as Nolan shows up
Conquest immediately gets the upper hand
on Nolan and kind of just just like
headbutts the heck out of him and
basically knocks him unconscious for for
a brief moment and then Mark steps back
in again and that's kind of the funny
thing here is even though you've got two
other vulture mites going you know in
this this major conflict youve really
got it coming down to Mark and Nolan
Mark and his dad versus conquest and and
like Mark's pulling out all the stops on
this guy but at the moment the the kind
of conflict these guys offer Allen the
alien along along with this this
basically a space Knight more or less
They Don't Really offer a whole lot
right I mean there's not a whole lot
they can do I mean Allen can do a lot
more than like than than pretty much
anybody else almost including Mark but
it's three on three at the moment and
really two of them are normally facing
off or really facing off against one of
the vure mes so the numbers are heavily
stacked against Allen in them and so
face off as they might and do as they
can one of the big questions that Mark
has while he's fighting Conquest is how
did you get free and that right there is
a limitation of Mark that's the
important thing to understand here and
again going back to the to the early
story arcs right the early stories we
did when Nolan was still on earth when
Nolan fought Mark teaching him how to
fight as they were fighting and that
that kind of climactic battle between
the two Mark struggles with distractions
the reality is that in this moment right
now it doesn't matter how Conquest got
out it doesn't matter how Conquest Got
Away what matters is stopping him now if
stopping him allows him to live long
enough to spill the beans on how he
survived that's cool but at the moment
he's an immediate threat right a clear
and present danger to everybody here and
the people on Earth so the only thing to
do is to put this guy down but
ultimately Mark's distractions get the
better of him to a degree and that
ultimately you end up having Conquest
who kind of spills the beans a bit and
says like you know I have no idea how I
lived right obviously you didn't beat me
to death and I just kind of woke up
Underground on your planet's surface in
some giant containment unit by somebody
who was foolish enough to think they
could hold me right right off the bat
Mark realizes that it was Cil right he's
like okay so Cil kept this guy alive
that's kind of the crazy thing is
because he's like would I see him again
and then Conquest kind of chimes in and
says why would you be so foolish to
think that you would you'd be able to
see anybody else again but once you have
Mark basically you know holding his own
against Conquest Nolan deviates and then
starts facing off against the other
other vure mines the numbers are even
then they start to sway into the favor
of Nolan and Mark and Allen the alien
and so on and it's a cool thing here
because as that happens the question
that that's really posed here to these
vulture Minds is why would you only why
would you face off against us with only
three of you right like I Allen the
alien and stronger than you guys guys
you know just barely but I'm stronger
than you guys and we've got Nolan and
we've got Mark and we've got Oliver
right like we've we've got the upper
hand on you guys like what would make
you guys believe you could you could
somehow come out on top here in the
middle of all that here come one of the
conscripted races and that's really the
meat and potatoes of what makes the
vmite Empire so incredibly strong here
is that it's not just the fact that
there's 50 vites left and there're super
powerful and each of them were easily
capable of Conquering the world instead
it's that they can script other races to
do bidding for them and that's what
really allows them to maintain such a
strong hold over the universe that in
the fact that nobody knows there's only
50 of them left right the rest of the
universe found that out they would
Marshall all their forces and it would
literally be everybody against the vure
Mite but instead using a combination of
allowing the universe to believe that
the vure might race is this massive race
of people who live on this world that it
allows them to kind of conquer worlds
and enforce races into their service and
then go forward accordingly and that's
what you get here right you know energy
beams firing down and all kinds of crazy
stuff going going on and so on but in
the middle of all that Oliver as the
younger member right the the youngest
person here hasn't quite mastered the
ability to hold his breath as long as
everybody else and so he starts to
suffocate and so he's given an
instruction in just saying go right just
take off to that world down there and uh
and and just like grab a breath for
yourself catch your breath come back
everything will be cool and then
Conquest chases after him this is when
Mark becomes one of the most brutal
versions of himself right when Mark just
completely lets go because he knows
definitively that if Conquest catch is
up to Oliver he's going to kill him
right I mean this it's just remorseless
murder that's exactly what it's going to
be right so Oliver flying down to this
world trying to catch his breath
Conquest chasing after him Mark chasing
after conquest and like leaving
everybody behind right and so ultimately
of course Oliver gets back down to this
world catches his breath and then before
Conquest can get to him Mark gets to
Conquest right and that's the crazy
thing that's that's what's so wild is
because Mark knocks the wind out of him
and is like oh wow you know so like you
were coming to this planet so you could
breathe weren't you with the wind
knocked out of him he immediately starts
to choke him right like the the air has
been knocked out of his lungs so we
can't even breathe at the moment right
so Mar just starts choking him and
starts holding on for dear life right
like you end up having like Conquest who
tries to fly out of the world it's not
doing him any good he's doing everything
he can to get mark off of him and it's
it's crazy because while all that's
going on Nolan's like where's Mark
where's Oliver where's Conquest where
are they all at and like everybody's
like we don't know and so Nolan
immediately like abandons everything
right with just Reckless abandon goes
directly after Mark goes down to that
that planet surface trying to find his
the whole time Mark's got his arms like
his hands just around Conquest neck and
this is the nature of what it means to
be a Vite right the whole time this is
happening to have this level of
fortitude this level of desire to truly
just eliminate a person while Mark is
holding on for dear life Conquest is
just crushing this guy right just puming
him as best as he possibly can cracking
Ribs Right the whole nine yards I mean
Mark is just is is just being tattered
but the whole time the entire time he
doesn't let go right he says like I'm
not letting go like I'm never going to
let go holding on to him like strangling
this guy for dear life literally it even
gets to the point where Conquest punches
a hole through Mark right like rips a
hole through him his bones are retruded
out of his back right like he's like I
mean you're talking about like compound
fractures right like rib bones are
protruding through his back and Mark
won't let go just keeps strangling and
strangling and holding on to the guy as
long as he possibly can even to the
point that like Conquest reaches into to
like this gaping being wound in Mark's
stomach and pulls his guts out right
like rips his guts right out like Mark
doesn't let go and ultimately Conquest
is killed and this is what it means to
be a vter mind to have this level of
strength this level of durability notice
this is what it took for Mark to kill
the guy he couldn't beat him to death
right he couldn't like Pummel this guy
to death he couldn't punch his head off
his shoulders he couldn't smash his
skull in right I mean I guess you could
have done that before but the guy healed
so obviously it wasn't enough what he
did before didn't work he had to just
cut this guy's oxygen supply right just
cut this guy's ability to breathe and
Mark guts strewn all over the place
Nolan shows up Oliver shows up and the
only thing Mark can do is just yell for
help what's going on guys this is Rob
and we are back with Invincible yes we
are we are continuing the vure might war
and I I left you guys on one heck of a
cliffhanger last week uh but this
basically picks up in the aftermath of
that right so Mark just in complete and
total shambles Conquest is dead Nolan
and Oliver are currently on the planet
then of course you've got tech jacket
and you've got Allen who are just kind
of out there doing their thing so by and
large this kind of group of Five Guys
right this group of just Powerhouse
characters is just really kind of left
in shambles and so the result of this is
that when you end up having you know end
up transitioning to Tesa which again is
the home of the Coalition of planets
this kind of band something akin to like
the rebel alliance or what have you from
Star Wars who are basically working
together to try to take out the the
vites that you have the news that's
given to the head of the Coalition of
planets right and he immediately freaks
out now the funny thing about this is
thus again is a Vite so that's one thing
to bear in mind it's something that
almost nobody knows and rightfully so
right I mean How likely would you be to
follow a guy who's leading a war against
a race only to find out he's a member of
that race that it would be something of
a huge amount of distrust that's there
because it's like well how do we know
he's actually working against the vure
mites as opposed to for us it's a very
dangerous game that he's playing here
the other big thing about this is that
when he's given the news that presumably
or at least it's it's perceived to be
that no and Oliver and Invincible are
dead albeit in reality they're simply
just missing in action because there's
no real way of knowing what happened to
them what their fate is it terrifies the
hell out of thus because the reality is
they're the Lynch pin right they're the
Lynch pin to the success of this thing
it's one thing to unite a whole bunch of
people against a particular cause but if
at the end of the day there's there's
not really much they have in the way of
arms and Armament then it would be like
when the Ethiopians were fighting the
Germans during World War II right Spears
and arrows versus tanks you're not
really going to be able to do much and
that was really what's going on here
without their Heavy Hitters they can
fight as best they can but the vites are
nothing to scoff at and one Vite is more
than enough to handle a huge amount of
these forces let alone an entire Army of
vites not to mention anything of all the
forces they have conscripted to their
service now the reality of this is tech
jacket and Allen are actually stowing
away the vmite ship right they're
stowing aboard this ship basically the
way that Han Solo and them stowed aboard
a star destroy right you guys remember
that from Star Wars and literally
techjet like I saw this in a movie Once
so it works right it does its job but
you kind of switch over to uh to Nolan
and to Oliver basically dealing with
Mark now one of the funny things about
this is that uh you basically have Nolan
who buries conquest and the immediate
response of Oliver is this is ridiculous
right like you have no idea the kind of
things this guy's done this guy does not
deserve a funeral but the reality of
this is that the lifetime of Conquest
seems to have Spann thousands of years
and so the reality is that the things
that he's done in the time that Oliver
has known him basically T to out to a
couple minutes within our lifespan it's
an exceedingly short amount of time here
not only that Nolan really kind of hits
this idea that when it comes to the
vites the one thing that really seems to
reign supreme is Duty and honor and so
even though Conquest was by our
standards of villain in terms of how he
operated within the confines of the Vite
Empire he was a great warrior and so
it's one of these things where Nolan
kind of looks at that and says even if
he did some shady stuff he still
deserves A Warrior's funeral because he
was a great and honorable fighter even
if only in so far as how he operated
within the confines of the vmite Empire
now this is huge because it's not Nolan
defecting back to the vites and saying
yeah I mean I've kind of re I've seen
the light and the vites are the way to
go and then kills Oliver and then kills
Mark and Lees right that's not really
what we're talking about here we're
talking about one of these things where
despite the fact that Nolan has has
basically turned against the vmite
empire there are such things as Duty and
honor that are Universal that are
universally recognized as being great
things regardless of what side you're
fighting on and so it's also kind of
this concept it's not really given to us
it's not really stated specifically but
Conquest was raised within the
ideologies of the Vite Empire imagine
what he would have been capable of if he
had turned in the same capacity Nolan
had or if he had been raised by a
different race but still had the same
powers and had a different set of values
right good and evil right and wrong is
all really relative those Concepts
simply exist in relation to how we
function as an organized Society but you
end up having them kind of switching
over really traveling back to Mark to
keep an eye on him and of course they
don't really leave him they just kind of
stay with him but it's going to be a
long and arduous process because what
Nolan says is that Mark's going to take
months to recover now again vites can
heal but because Mark is such a young
vomite presumably with hundreds if not
thousands of years ahead of him assuming
the human side of his physiology doesn't
kick in and basically cause like a rapid
aging process relative to the age of
viltrumites then this is basically him
as a baby recovering from an injury
whereas somebody like Conquest recovered
much much faster because he's much much
older right now you would think as time
goes on the healing Factor would kind of
drop off but at the end of the day it's
one of these things where it kind of
seems to be the middle ground right that
you know as in in given Conquest age he
was kind of in the prime of his life so
to speak so his healing Factor was kind
of at its peak right we can sort of
argue that kind of present that scenario
but regardless of course it's one of
these things where Nolan also looks at
this situation where it's basically a
chance for him to get to know his son
Oliver better and so from there you
basically switch over to a scout ship
right that's part of the Coalition of
planets that kind of stumbles across
that previous battle that we saw between
battle beast and a couple other forces
only to find that battle Beast has
actually survived the experience right
he's Frozen in space but he's basically
surv red the other part of this is you
have thus who meets up with these aliens
now I've kind of left these guys out
just because of the fact that you know I
feel I felt like it was a little too
much to throwing in there in the
previous videos but these guys are kind
of like the intelligence Hub right
they're the nervous system more or less
of the Coalition of planets essentially
the ability for the coalition to unify
and to operate on multiple fronts goes
through these guys right like they they
have almost complete and total knowledge
of the operational procedures of the
Coalition of planets they become very
important here and the reason why is
because the information they give is
that at the end of the day they don't
know exactly where it is that Nolan and
and all these guys are at Allen the
alien tech jacket uh Mark Oliver they
don't have any information on where
those guys are but what they do know is
that the vure mites have basically like
they really initiated the first strike
the vites are responding and the war is
already begun and so the response of
Thaddius is okay fine like if what you
guys are waiting for is to to give the
final word to basically initiate the
initial assault then I give it right and
so officially the Coalition of planets
has now struck against the Vite Empire
and the war just kind of continues on
the reality is it already started but
this is really kind of like the
fullscale conflict taking place right so
initially with Mark and all them we were
talking about like the invasion of
Poland right now we're talking about
England and France declaring war against
Germany that's where we're at now right
like we're really at like okay like the
meat and potatoes of this have really
started and there is no going back here
and so what you get are these really
interesting ju to positions between
Oliver and Nolan and the Coalition of
planets right that Oliver and Nolan
don't know the the whole conflict is
really grow grown to the size that it
has where the Coalition of planets has
officially launched its strike against
vmite and the two factions are now in a
full-blown War they don't know that
right like they're totally unaware of
that and in reality they probably don't
care not because the war efforts
unimportant but because tending to Mark
is more important and so it's kind of
this this funny thing because it's only
been a couple of weeks and you end up
having like this weird looking alien
thing that's killed by Nolan and and
Oliver's you know he's he's like you
know it's aren aren't you like starving
and and Oliver's like no like I mean I I
am but I'm not hungry enough to eat that
thing and Nolan's like okay we'll see
what's up and then like you immediately
switch to Oliver just crushing this
right like parental knowledge right like
kids being proud or kids being foolish
and it's like okay I mean I've been
where you are before that's not going to
happen right like you're starving and I
promise you're probably going to eat
this and he does and then he ask for
seconds right he's like is there
anymore now the other part of this is
that Allen the alien basically has a
kind of tracking device that emits a
highfrequency signal that's planted
inside of his body that can only really
be detected or seems to only be detected
by the Coalition of planets most likely
because the vites don't know it's there
so they don't know the frequency to
hijack in order to basically deactivate
it interrupt it basically make it look
like he's somewhere that he's not but
because of the fact that the Coalition
can track it down you basically have the
Coalition of Worlds that responds with a
a kind of Battalion of sorts that comes
descending onto this vilter ship for the
purpose of rescuing Allen the alien and
tech jacket right so they get these guys
they basically start bringing them back
and then you kind of switch back over to
Oliver and Nolan right and this is a
really really cool moment here because
you have this situation where Oliver
asks him the question he's like you know
the like he's like my mom not my real
mom right the the you know insect
looking mom but like my actual Earth Mom
right Debbie you know like do you really
think you were in love with her and it's
a really interesting question that this
is asked because one of the great things
about Oliver is he's not experienced in
the same way that Mark is right he still
very much sees the world to the eyes of
a child and from the mouth of babes
comes truth and that's really one of the
things where he's just kind of asking
these questions because for him they're
legitimately curious and interesting
questions and the response of Nolan is I
know I do and it's this really
interesting scenario where he presents
this kind of discussion to her and talks
about how he was healing in the vmite
prison you know in order and and it
basically made him realize yes he really
does care about Debbie and it's kind of
funny because he says that like the
vites themselves they do have affection
but they don't care for each other in
the same way that humans do right he
says our lives are so long that over
time we grow distant it's hard to form a
bond with someone over that much time
and he says you'll never find one of us
who will admit it but we live very
lonely solitary lies especially with
their numbers so depleted living on
Earth changed me seeing humans grow so
close to each other caring so deeply for
their loved ones in the short amount of
time allotted for them it was special
something to be admired now that's a
very important thing to understand when
it comes to the vure mes and the reason
why is because it's the true statement
that that you know Nolan makes here they
live such long lives but more so than
that they're so frequently separated
from each other unless you're talking
about some situation where they come
together to face off against some cause
or you need like three or four who are
going to defeat some enemy or something
like that by and large the Vite Empire
does not really operate in giant numbers
right because they don't have big
numbers they're like there's less than
100 of them left right so you basically
have them traveling from world to world
for the purpose of conquering it and it
might be one of these things where they
kind of hang out but the reality is any
real relationship between one villager
mind and another is more or less like
two ships passing in the night more so
than that with this kind of being the
life of Nolan for thousands of years the
sudden change of arriving on earth and
the sudden change of being there and
kind of monitoring this place and then
having to kind of sneak in and live a
quote unquote human life essentially
introduced him to aspects of what it
meant to live that he'd never really
experienced before experiencing all
those things completely and totally
changed him because what it did is it
introduced the idea that there is such a
thing as caring about something more
than you care about yourself and that's
really what he says he says like I never
looked at Life as a chore he says over
time I fell into the role of human
husband human father so much so that
when Mark God his powers it was a great
burden more than anything he said I had
to go back to being a vulture Mite I had
to do what I was put there to do whether
I wanted to or not I spent a lot of time
alone then considering if I could ignore
my duty continue living the LIE I'd
enjoyed so much with the woman I'd grown
to love he just wanted to kind of enjoy
his life and that's why you never really
saw Nolan doing things like destroying
the Guardians of the globe at a much
earlier point in time because in reality
the life that he was living was the life
that he wanted because it was new and it
was fresh but more so than that it was
meaningful and then suddenly Mark comes
along Mark has powers and it's like okay
so now I have to like he was basically
reminded of what he was supposed to do
and then he went back to being a vure
mine but didn't want to right he didn't
want to but at the end of the day the
idea was if he doesn't conquer the world
the Vite Empire will come there and they
will take it right one way or another
the Earth is going to be conquered but
then suddenly when he's separated from
it all and he realizes how much he loved
his wife he realizes how much his son
meant to him then basically it turns
into then who cares about the vmite
Empire right like I will take that risk
I will turn against them and we will do
the best we can and so again kind of
getting this sort of Jos this back and
forth you have have this really cool
thing where you have Oliver talking with
Nolan the two of them conversing the two
of them sort of learning more about each
other but even this realization that's
given to Oliver be on behalf of Nolan
which is that the truth is that a a kind
of merger between a vilter Mite and
different races can actually produce a
more powerful Offspring than simply just
vites by themselves right that hybrid
physiology can potentially create an
incredibly powerful Offspring now the
reality of this is Mark is really the
more powerful out of them right because
Mark is a blend between a human and a
Vite and as we were previously told the
compatibility between vure mites and
humans is Big right so much so that it's
almost perfect and so kind of these two
the these two guys talking back and
forth and really kind of enjoying the
sort of Simplicity of this life that
they have even if it's only minor right
just basically eating living talking
making sure March's protected is an
extreme justos to Allen the alien and
the Coalition of planets fighting these
vites fleeing for their lives fighting
again over and over and over again right
peace versus War that's really what
you're seeing here and it's kind of
interesting to see this thing because
you also have Nolan who's basically
giving all of her fighting lessons who's
teaching him you know the the level of
strength that he truly has how powerful
he can become helping him grow that
strength in a lot of ways doing the
things that he didn't quite do for Mark
and that's the nature of what it means
to be apparent it's not as though Nolan
hated Mark it's not as though he
despised him it's simply just that as a
parent when you have your first kid
you're going to screw up consistently
it's only when you get your second kid
that you basically correct the mistakes
you made with your first kid but then
you end up making whole new mistakes and
so there there really is no such thing
as a parent is a time that comes when
you simply have a child and you make no
mistakes and you raise them perfectly
but for Nolan he's basically making up
for a lot of the a lot of the things he
didn't do with Mark and he's basically
doing that with Oliver which is cool
because he's kind of continuing to learn
and to kind of experience this whole
thing and so again cheering his son on
rooting his son on it's also kind of
switching over to thus and this
Revelation that one battle Beast has
agreed to join their ranks right so
battle Beast is fighting alongside the
ranks of the Coalition of planets which
is awesome because this guy's powerful
enough to take out vites the other part
of this is that for some reason they
can't quite seem to gain a foothold in
the way that they want to that while the
vites aren't necessarily able to counter
every single move they make it seems
like the vites have an inside man and
we've known about that for quite some
time that even thus himself said there's
a spy in the Coalition of Worlds that's
feeding information to the vmite Empire
we don't know who this person is we
don't know why they're doing it but
basically it seems as though the vites
always know what's going on and that's
why they should be gaining a much
stronger foothold in this W than they
are it's three steps forward and two
steps back sure it's a one-step net gain
but at the end of the day from daus's
perspective it should be two or three
right they should be making far more
advances and a much bigger stride in
this war than there currently are so the
ultimate or the only real thing for him
to do is because of the fact they're
missing Nolan and they're missing
invincible and they're missing Oliver
right the only real thing they can do
because they're missing these Heavy
Hitters is to basically split up tech
jacket and uh and Allen the alien
because while they are able to work
effectively together they might be
equally effective but even possibly even
more effective by being separated and so
because of that it's you kind of switch
over to Mark and Mark just kind of
waking up and ultimately Nolan's like
okay cool it won't be long now we have
about another month or so before all
this starts to you know before Mark
basically fully recovers so again we're
talking about like two or three months
before you know between the time that
Mark was like severely injured to the
point that Mark starts to wake up and
Mark can basically recover and get back
into the conflict again now under any
normal circumstance there are Advanced
ways of healing a person right there's
Advanced ways of pulling that off the
problem is Mark's in a highly vulnerable
state so one they can't fly to the
Coalition of Worlds because it's simply
too far away and two even if they could
the likelihood of them being attacked by
the vites along the way is very very
high and so because of that that's why
their best bet was to Simply stay put so
in truth the recovery time of Mark could
have been cut down to a couple weeks or
possibly even days given the nature of
the circumstance that they're in they
got to let him recover naturally now the
funny thing is that there's another
reason why Nolan's doing this right why
he's having Mark recover the hard way as
opposed to the easy way and we'll find
out what that is later on on down the
line but what you end up doing here is
switching over to the home world of the
vilter mites to of course as you guys
call him Freddy
Mercury you guys love calling the leader
of the vites Freddy Mercury you guys are
so sure that's the name of this guy and
honestly we just need to go with it
right like Freddy Mercury I can
guarantee when this when this guy's
revealed in the show they're going to
call him Freddy Mercury right they're
going to be like yeah man thrag is
definitely Freddy Mercury like it's
going to be Freddy Mercury memes all
over the
place and I am so looking forward to it
but we end up finding out that the
information that's being fed to the Vite
Empire is actually coming from one of
the aliens that's basically part of the
coalitional planet's nervous system
right the entire unification the entire
organized military front passes through
them and so because of that they're in
the best position to pass information to
thrag this is what's basically crippling
the war effort of the Coalition of
planets this guy is just dumping
information all the time and so what
ends up happening is we basically have
this this kind of back and forth between
these guys and thrag goes as far as to
say you've been feeding us information
for for years but it's not enough we're
still losing planets to the Coalition
this is unacceptable we will strike the
Coalition headquarters on Testa you will
shut down their defenses at the time
being at the time that's being
transmitted to you respond and the
answer to this guy is it will be done
right and that's when the other guy's
like what are you talking about he's
like yeah we're basically going to set
the stage for the for the vure mites to
conquer the Coalition of
planets what's going on guys this is Rob
and we are back with Invincible yes we
are and and I told you guys once you get
like full swing into the Vite War things
pop off and that's exactly what happens
here right it all starts to go nuts so
one of the things that happens here
really kind of in the beginning is
you've basically got Fus who calls
together really the heads of the
Coalition of planets right because one
of the things keep in mind he is kind of
the defacto leader but like a lot of the
other races that are part of the
Coalition have their own Empires it's
really more speaking to the other heads
right so in effect it's like if thus was
the head of the United Nations right and
that he's talking to the leaders of the
other other Empires the leaders of the
other worlds or nations that are out
there and just kind of like okay so like
here's where we stand at the moment and
this is kind of a big Revelation right
because the information he gives them
here is that the weapons and the arms
and Armament that they're using are
things that have been Tracked Down
duplicated so on and so forth that can
basically defeat the Vil termites the
problem with this is that the lynchpin
in their plan right Mark and Nolan and
Oliver that they're Mia they're missing
an action they don't know where they are
and that in reality the entire battle
hinges on them being there so while he
doesn't go so far as to say so long as
they're not here we're fighting a losing
battle that's kind of what said right
that's just kind of the message that's
communicated we'll fight valiantly we'll
fight to The Bitter End we'll never
Retreat right that kind of a thing but
in the middle of all this there's kind
of a rumble off in the distance and then
literally bam right like the vites
arrive on Tesa now that's one of the
things to keep in mind remember there's
a spy in the ranks of the Coalition of
planets who's been feeding information
to the vites and has basically set the
stage for them to invade Tesa and
essentially take out the coalition of
Worlds at their home but before we get
into that we end up switching back over
to to Nolan and Oliver and all them
right and again one of the things that
had gone on here was Nolan and Oliver
had had very much a kind of bonding
moment between the two where they had
talked about you know growing up and
they had talked about life for Oliver on
Earth and things like that and one of
the funny things here is because of his
split Heritage a lot of the things that
we as humans would deem to be beautiful
or unattractive he doesn't really see
things the same way as an example uh his
mother had taken him right Debbie had
taken him to a uh to a restaurant where
he had he saw a lobster in a tank and he
had he of course ate the lobster but he
also found the lobster to be beautiful
right in the in literally like physical
Beauty he found it to be attractive and
so that's when uh when Nolan's like hey
like I know some girls on teser that I
can introduce you to and it's like
really man I mean he's a little young
isn't he you know I don't know maybe
he's around 17 or 18 years old but
whatever it is his dad's trying to get
him laid so
ultimately ultimately in the middle of
their discussions there's some kind of
rummaging and movement around over at
their base camp and when they get there
they find Mark has basically woken up
now here's a funny thing about this of
course Mark is basically told you killed
Conquest right like you're the one who
destroyed conquest and it's kind of a
funny thing because Mark talks about how
Even In This Moment now despite having
done it it's still weird to him because
in his mind Conquest was so incredibly
strong right I mean Conquest was
probably the the single most formidable
fighter in the Vite Empire shy of thrag
and so the fact that Mark was able to
overpower him and ultimately kill him
kind of takes Mark by surprise to the
point that he actually doesn't really
believe that he was able to pull it off
but the response that his father gives
him is here's something that you have to
understand one you're a lot stronger
than you think you are living on Earth
the benefit to that is you learn to
understand compassion and all that kind
of stuff the downside to that is you've
consistently held yourself back but when
you were fighting against Conquest you
had adrenaline you had rage you were
more invested in the fight than he was
and that's one of the things that no one
kind of hits on is that it wasn't just
Conquest In This Moment Conquest entire
life has been that way right that he
basically acts like a spectator in
pretty much all of his own fights
because he's so incredibly strong
because he's so much further Beyond
anybody that he's basically fighting
when he ran up against Mark he just kind
of did business as usual and it cost him
his life the biggest problem here though
is that Mark's promise that he made to
himself is you know I wasn't going to
kill anymore right I didn't want to do
that anymore but the response of Nolan
is This Is War man this is not the time
for you to kind of adhere yourself to
These Foolish naive ideologies of we can
all live in peace and Harmony and all we
have to do is sit down and talk to them
and everything will be okay no it
doesn't work that way there are times
when you are going to face an enemy
regardless of what form it takes in your
life where you are not going to be able
to reason with them you're not going to
be able to rationalize with them you're
not going to be able to talk to them and
get them to understand the only thing
you can do is eliminate them right
that's the only thing that you can do
the naive perception that every problem
in this world can be solved with talking
it out that's not true right that was
never true and so what we end up doing
is switching back over to to Freddy
Mercury right to thrag and one of the
things that kind of happens here is a
little bit amusing to himself not a
whole lot but it does give us some
insight and motivation into why he's
doing what he's doing the reality is
that his motivation as far as the vure
mites go their war against the
coalitional planets is twofold the first
part is because the coalitional planet
stands in direct opposition to the vites
themselves right it's not as though it's
one of these things where it's kind of a
Live and Let Live situation the desire
of the coalitional planets is to
eliminate the vites to get rid of their
influence from the universe because the
motivation of the vites is to conquer
everything in existence really more the
Galaxy than the universe but their goal
is to conquer everything the other
motivation for the vites themselves and
really for thrat on a personal level is
that prior to him becoming the region it
was Lord Argo we talked about that
previously when we covered the history
of of the Vite race and Lord alal was
killed by the mechan of Thaddius and so
because of that it's really more of a
personal Vendetta to take out thus and
the coition of planets now of course
switching back to thus and all them as
soon as everything pops off thus
realizes one of the Intel guys was the
spy and he initially goes after the
wrong one and then actually goes after
the right one but it doesn't make any
difference because suddenly all the vter
mites basically start arriving on the
scene now you do get Allen the alien
right you get tech jacket you get these
guys who show up and they're able to
offer some measure of resistance and
kind of help the Coalition of planets
but again the entire conflict is really
almost a Fool's errand without Nolan and
Mark and Oliver just because of the
sheer level of power they possess it's
literally one of those things where just
the level of power they have is what
turns the tide and so their arrival
signals the Turning of the tide here
right because as soon as they show up
everything begins to shift right it all
begins to change like literally Mark and
Oliver go flying through the command
ship of the the vites which also
contains thrag right so that thing you
know basically starts to crash down to
the surface they end up pushing it out
into space and then thrag takes off
right now you would expect thrag to
basically jump out right to come out
here and say okay no no no no that's not
going to happen and and to to get
engaged in this conflict here but once
thrag gets involved in the fight here's
the thing to understand thrag never
fights unless he absolutely has to
because he's got the rest of the vilter
mites to fight for but when he does WBY
TI the poor soul that has to face off
against thrag cuz this guy is an
absolute monster that you basically end
up having the vulture mites who just
take off right they're just they're gone
right as soon as thrag leaves they leave
with him of course the spies basically
executed by his his partner more or less
but before he dies he's kind of like you
know like this like we're all like
everybody's screwed right like this all
you guys it's all screwed you guys
didn't win here right I mean you guys
have not had a victory here that's not
what's going on here right the idea of
the vites was if this campaign went
South they would reather at their in
their home planet right they would
reather on their home World they would
Mar all their forces so every single
Vite scattered around all of creation
will be recalled and then they'll launch
a final assault right they'll they'll
launch like this massive attack and
that's a big thing because what you end
up having is again fat is calling
together what is essentially the uh the
Coalition of Worlds and he kind of
declares the vmite war is over but not
really right it's not really all that
over but in some ways it is the reason
why is that with the vites basically all
being recalled and then going back to
their home world all the various races
out there that have been conquered by
the vites are effectively liberated and
a lot of this is really more of an
ideological perspective because they see
that with the Coalition of Worlds being
successful in driving the vites back
from Tesa and forcing them back into
their home world that they're basically
stronger than the than the vmite race
right so in that way it seems like they
don't really have much to fear and so
that's why a lot of those forces that
fought on the side of the vites are now
turn coding they're leaving the the Vite
cause even though it was only one done
under subserviant and now they're
joining the Coalition of planets and
going forward accordingly the problem
with this is most of those guys if they
took them to Vil termite they would get
slaughtered right they would get
absolutely crushed and so the response
of fadus is we need basically a
hard-hitting crew right the heaviest
hitters we have we need you guys and so
ultimately Allen the alien mark Nolan
tech jacket uh battle Beast Space Racer
Oliver they all basically end up making
their way toward vrum and then literally
going after this world now once they
arrive there of course immediately
there's a a bit of a a conflict there
between Thula one of the female vilter
mites uh and then in turn she of of
course warns the rest of the vure mites
that basically you know these guys are
coming here and that's when like
Thaddius and that's when all the other
vure mites basically leave the world and
then immediately start coming towards
these guys now what you have here is
this kind of ragtag bunch right the
smaller number of guys despite their
heavy-hitting capabilities the first
thing they recognize is they're too
outnumbered here they can't fight they
can't win this war in a traditional
sense right they can't win this this
kind of final battle in the traditional
way tech jacket does show up with like a
lot of these monsters that are strong
enough to to kill vter and it does help
to turn the tide a little bit but at the
end of the day thrag is here and because
thr's here that's enough to turn the
tide that's enough to literally ensure
that the vites will basically win that's
the crazy thing is because you have like
these crazy displays of power a lot of
these vites are just taken out left and
right right Allen the alien is literally
punching his hand through like one of
their guts and it's coming up through
his mouth and you have all these crazy
things he punches the head off of
another one and thus all all just buff
as hell right looking like an old man
who's been lifting weights for 60 years
like he's basically you know facing
faing off against these guys and then
Oliver ends up facing off against thrag
and that's the crazy thing about it is
because when when Mark initially
launches an attack not knowing who thrag
is and basically hits him in the gut and
not much happens he kind of gets swatted
away Oliver steps in and this fight is 2
seconds long literally thrag grabs his
arm rips it off and punches him across
space and that's the end of Oliver just
like that done I mean it's it's that
fast and people are just like wow you
know like it's it's almost crazy to see
it happen Mark goes in for the attack
and and literally with every ounce of
strength and rage all this all this
power that it took for him to defeat
Conquest that's what he's got here and
all he gives thrag is a bloody nose
that's it right that's all thrag gets
here now the big declaration is that
thrag says that even Conquest feared him
and then Mark makes a statement and
saying well I killed conquest and the
funny thing is none of the other vites
knew what happened to Conquest they
didn't know what happened to him
learning that Mark had killed him was a
pretty big thing because they're like
how in the hell did this guy kill
Conquest like that's crazy like that's
that's that's kind of nuts but at the
end of the day they can't really do much
here right so the only real thing that
the Coalition of Worlds can do is based
on a plan that thus had thought up right
and it's it's desperate and it's a last
ditch effort here but it's the only way
to essentially ensure their victory in
this conflict that Thaddius calls Space
Racer to himself remember he's got a
weapon that can destroy virtually
anything it hits right so he says come
with me so ultimately like Space Racer
fires off his gun at the VTR home world
at the same time that happens Thaddius
Nolan Mark they all basically just go
racing to the core now Allen the alien
and tech jacket are supposed to be there
but they kind of get distracted a little
bit in the conflict so it's ultimately
just thadius and Mark and and Nolan who
go racing to this world but it's enough
they basically punch a hole through one
side of the world and come out the other
and literally obliterate the vilam home
World they destroy the whole thing they
obliterate the whole thing so now the
Vite race has nowhere to go this is this
while I wouldn't say this is a a defeat
that solidifies the victory because all
they have to do is just go to another
world that has oxygen and they'll
basically be fine it's a colossal moral
blow because all that history right all
that all all that entire the entire
existence of their race is now gone
right it's all basically gone and any
vites that may have been on that world
at the time have been destroyed with it
especially those who were caught in the
blast uh when the planet exploded itself
so it's reduced their number by a pretty
good clip now ultimately thrag is is
seemingly the only one left awake here
right the only one that's that's
basically conscious here and so
essentially thrag along with maybe like
four other guys kind of seem to be the
only ones left here and so you end up
having thus you got Allen you got Nolan
who are just kind of like okay it's over
it's done right like you will surrender
and like that will be it you have no
Empire you have no home you have
absolutely nothing left and the response
of thrag is you're ridiculous if you
think I'm going to surrender he
literally races up on this guy and just
rips off the head of Thaddius in one
shot I mean that's it right thus gone
like his head's just ripped off in an
instant when that happens everybody
freaks Allen the alien Nolan the whole n
yards they freak they're like holy oh
like holy [__] man like this is it like
I mean how are we supposed to fight
against somebody like that and like he
destroys the head of thus like battle
Beast is taken out in the process and
then in turn uh thrag is just like it's
on right you guys really you guys you
called down the Thunder well now you got
it right you guys wanted thrag you
wanted me to get involved in this now
I'm involved in this you had my
curiosity now you have my attention the
question you have to ask yourself is
when you get the attention of Freddy
Mercury the leader of the Vite race the
most powerful and strongest person in
creation right now what happens when
that attention gets turned to you and
let me tell you guys something what
we're going to cover in the next video
cuz I'm leaving you'all on the
Cliffhanger like hell what happens in
the next video is insane it's absolutely
insane man let me let man I'm just I'm
saying it right now these guys never had
a chance that's that's it that's that's
all I'm going to leave you guys on they
never had a chance any any chance they
thought they had was an illusion it was
smoking mirrors right when this guy gets
done not even in hell will you see a
massacre like what you're going to see
in this next video all right what's
going on guys this is Rob and we are
back again with Invincible a little late
on our upload today but I kind of had a
lot going on this morning so I didn't
get it recorded on time but here is the
thing in the last video we basically
ended with as you guys love calling him
Freddy Mercury but technically his name
is
thrag the Emperor of the Vite Empire but
this guy was getting ready to take on
Nolan and Mark right omn man and Mark
and the reason why is because they were
basically part of the whole faction that
destroyed his world right that the
Coalition of of planets had essentially
obliterated the Vite World in an effort
to basically end the reign of the vites
now a lot of this was because with no
home planet to go back to anybody that
was there on that world at the time was
gone right they were completely in
totally destroyed and so now they're
basically homeless is in the vastness of
the universe not only that it was a
moral blow because they were able to
destroy the Vite Empire this really
drove a lot of the races out there that
were previously conscripted by the uh by
the Vite to actually turn against the
vites and join the cause of the
Coalition of Planet so it was as much a
a moral Victory as it was a real Battle
Victory but again it was only a small
conflict in this Vite War because
following that thrag is pissed now Nolan
does know about thrag right but he's not
he's not dumbing anything from Mark
right Mark immediately goes in to attack
thrag and he's like you killed my
brother he goes to punch him in the head
and nothing happens like literally
doesn't draw blood thrag doesn't even
say ouch right it's nothing he
immediately grabs Mark and literally
just starts pummeling this guy smashes
the sides of his head this fight was
over before it even started right I mean
this kid has no earthly chance like no
possible chance against somebody like
thrag now at that point Nolan steps in
but even then Nolan is a half measure
here it's a crazy thing because like as
they're fighting at the end of the day
like like thr's like okay so you really
sided with thus right you you are aware
that thus was the one who killed who
basically set the vure empire into a
state of disarray and that's one of the
things that we talked about before
remember when it came to the power or
the the role the vure mites played
initially they were a huge expansive
conquering race but the scourge virus
was developed by Thaddius using his own
DNA as a means to destroy the Vite race
because in the mind of thus they were
they were horrible right their place
their their role in the the universe and
all of creation was bad and they needed
to be destroyed and so the result of
this is that it's because of the actions
of thrag that Lord argal died in the
first place the entire Empire had been
sent into disarray any possible Heir
taking over the throne after Lord argal
was basically gone and so thrag was
essentially just kind of put in this
place instead as the Regent but at the
end of the day the response of Nolan
based on everything he's experienced
right having been on Earth facing off
against Mark going on to become a hero
different things like that because the
Saul basically changed him and turned
him into a good guy the response he has
here is our race deserves to die because
of the things that we've done and
because of how we've harm people we
don't deserve to live here right we
don't deserve to exist our actions are
horrible the things we've done have been
Terri terrible so like our race deserves
to die and for that he's immediately
attacked by thrag because it's taken is
what isn't effect heresy right now in
the middle of this great big huge battle
where where omn man is just getting
absolutely thrashed in comes battle
Beast right now as you guys know battle
Beast only really cares about the lust
of the battle right the lust of the
conflict he just wants to attack whoever
right anybody he considers to be a
worthy adversary is somebody he will
take on that's battle Beast right he
lives for the conflict he's like a
Spartan right from the days on Earth or
maybe even somebody worse than the
Spartans he just lives to fight the
funny thing about this is literally this
fight is like 2 seconds long if that he
attacks thrag thrag spins his head on
his on his neck and then throws him away
and that's the end of battle Beast right
like at the moment like like battle
Beast is basically taken out by thrag
like that and that's a crazy thing
because when you look at Battle Beast as
a character he overpowered Mark right
even omn man would struggle with with
battle Beast because of how powerful he
was but thrag just overpowers him in an
instant now the other part of this is
Allen the alien and Space Racer right
these two guys are still here from the
Coalition of Worlds but at the the end
of the day they have to kind of bail out
of here right because you still have
some vure mites that are alive around
there and the reality is even though
they're still capable they're
overpowered right so if they were to
stay and they were to fight they would
die and so ultimately it's kind of like
okay let's let's get out of here they
ask the question what do we do about
Nolan and Mark and the response of Space
Racer is we got to leave them man like
we got to leave them here like like they
can hold their own but if we stay here
we're going to die right we have to get
back to the Coalition we have to let
them know that the thus has been killed
right the leader of the Coalition of of
planet is dead we have to find some way
to reorganize things because this war is
far from over right so switch back over
to thrag right to Freddy Mercury and to
Nolan and Mark right this guy is still
crushing him and that's the funny thing
is Mark asked his dad he asked Nolan
like how do we beat this guy and the
response of Nolan is we can't we cannot
defeat thrag like it's one of those rare
instances when Nolan is like there's no
way for us to win right the nature of
Nolan is like he always finds a way to
win right he keeps fighting and fighting
and fighting doing whatever it is that
he has to do but he's like there's no
way for us to overpower this guy right
like in order for brag to be made region
of the Vite Empire he's been trained
from birth right he's been made the
strongest out of all of us and he's been
educated in every manner of physical
combat simply put there's no conceivable
way for us to beat this guy by ourselves
this man was literally designed to to
conquer the Vite race if it came to it
right to take out his own people he was
designed for that right he was trained
for that this guy is a oneman army he's
more than enough to take out the two of
us and so ultimately like you kind of
have omn man who tells Mark like look no
matter what's happened over the course
of my life it's important that you know
I've always loved you he's basically
saying is goodbyes right he tells Mark
get out of here right he ends up like
telling Mark to get out of here as fast
as he possibly can and Mark does he does
exactly as instructed he races off now
Mark's not doing this because he's a
coward Mark's doing this because he
trusts his father if his father says we
cannot defeat this man on our own you
need to leave then Mark leaves knowing
that his father might die in the ensuing
conflict now the other part of this I'm
going to be honest Mark's probably kind
of crap in his pants a little bit just a
smidge right but at the end of the day
thrag still manages to get his hands on
him and then just starts pummeling this
guy now Nolan shows up right omn man
comes racing back but this is a
testament to the speed of of thrag here
right Nolan comes racing up right cuz
remember there's no sound in space you
can't hear anything so Nolan comes
racing up on thrag and thrag just senses
it out of the corner of his eye and
immediately like turns around just in
time and impales omn man right just
punches a hole in his stomach now he
goes to kill him and this is an
important thing he goes to kill them and
then he stops he doesn't kill mark and
he doesn't kill Nolan the funny thing is
he could have he could have killed both
of them and and something to know here
he's doing all this without breaking a
sweat he's not drawing any like they're
not drawing any blood on him right
they're not like they're not injuring
this guy right like he's just
overpowering them in the most extreme
way ever when the other vure might show
up and they say why are you sparing them
the response of thrag is we need them
right there are so precious few of us V
mites left we need them we need people
to to basically function as part of the
Vite Empire now the initial response
here is no right we need vites but we
need those who are loyal the response to
thrag is no it doesn't matter right like
if we are going to survive all of this
we need vites but we need them more than
anybody else which is really kind of
thragg saying like they're the more most
powerful of the vites that exists right
more powerful than anybody else here
there is a kind of subtlety and there is
something else going on behind the
scenes as to why that's the case and in
fact you know well we'll kind of cross
that bridge when we get to it but
ultimately Nolan and Mark are saved by a
coalition ship which basically brings
them on board you know takes them back
to Testa the Coalition of Worlds all
that kind of stuff and a few things have
happened right a couple weeks have
passed since they've been picked up and
and Mark is just now waking up of course
again Nolan recovers faster than Mark
does but something to notice here Mark's
recovering at a much faster rate than he
previously used to but a couple things
happened one because thus was killed
Allan the alien took his place as the
leader of the Coalition of Worlds the
second thing that's going on here is
that once he takes mark to meet with
Nolan you actually end up finding out
that Oliver is basically being brought
back now it is kind of a plot device
here if we're being honest with
ourselves Oliver basically should have
been dead right I mean he he doesn't
have the ability to breathe in space as
long as anybody else does his arm was
ripped off he was rendered unconscious
but the response is given here by Nolan
is well you know the Vite brain can
survive without oxygen longer than
pretty much any other brain out there so
he was he was you know he' survived by
the skin of his teeth I mean if we're
being honest with ourselves this is
Robert Kirkman just kind of rolling with
it and just saying like you know insert
excuse here for why Oliver continues to
survive but of course a kind of
prosthetic arm is being built for him or
being attached to him and then skin will
be grafted over it so he will be able to
feel the difference but nobody else will
see the difference right the other thing
that's going on here is that of course
Oliver is healing but a big part of
what's happening is that the planet the
the Coalition of planets is hunting for
the Vite race but they don't understand
what's going on right they don't really
understand what's happening here and the
reason why is when the question is asked
by Mark like what do you mean like like
they're not they're not doing anything
right because Allen the aliens like
they're not attacking right like they're
doing absolutely nothing like we can't
find them at all we don't know where
they are right they're not here anywhere
in this galaxy we can't find them
anywhere in existence we don't know
what's happening right we've been
searching and searching and we can't
find them anywhere we don't know if
they're laying low we don't know exactly
what's going on nothing that we're
seeing makes any sense at all and then
it Dawns on Mark oh my God and when the
question is like what are you talking
about he's like okay so thrag left us
alive for a reason he could have killed
us but he left us alive for a reason but
they didn't just give up and go into
hiding that's not what vites do vites
don't just give up they don't hide they
don't run from the threat they've always
got a goal so he's like if he could have
destroyed us and he didn't then what if
the goal here is to destroy what's
closest to us and that's when everybody
starts to realize what's going on and
Mark speaks up and says you can't find
them in this galaxy Allan because
they're not in this galaxy they're in
the Milky Way galaxy guys they're going
to
Earth I am a terrible person I'm a
horrible human being
I left you guys on an insane Cliffhanger
the last time we did this I really did I
I am not
sorry sorry not sorry Rob
core because I'm gonna do it again so
here's the thing guys here's the thing
so in the last video we basically ended
with the Vite War essentially kind of
done for the most part like the the
vites themselves had just basically been
crushed right I mean these guys have
just been crushed in the worst way and
then in turn we then had like the vites
taking off right basically fleeing and
then taking off to earth right Mark was
the one to figure out that's what was
going to happen now at this point we
pick up with Earth right the Pentagon
and literally like thrag the leader of
the vmite Empire had and really him and
the other vites have basically conquered
everything right like they killed
everyone like they killed everybody I
mean you got Cecil begging for his life
right saying like we can coexist
everything will be fine right thrag pops
his head like a grape I mean just B
right his head just pops right off his
shoulders and and I mean like like the
immortal the whole nine yard right like
duplicate Adam Eve they're all dead
right every single one of them just
killed and then Mark wakes up right and
it's not even really a dream sequence so
much as just Mark's imagination on
what's happening on Earth Mark's
absolutely horrified about what's
happening there because the vites as
we've seen these guys take no prisoners
man like when the vites have it for you
they're they're coming man these guys
are coming for you and that's just the
way it is and and the reality is Mark
and Nolan are really the two most
powerful beings on Earth and they
couldn't even put a dent in thrag what
possible hope could any of these other
characters have right Adam Eve duplicate
whatever I mean arguably Adam Eve is the
most powerful being in the entirety of
the Invincible universe but she hasn't
reached the full totality of what she
can do she can alter matter on the
molecular structure but one it still
takes a pretty large toll on her so it
really exhausts her and two she can only
really do it on relatively small scales
right we haven't seen her do it on
gigantic scales facing off against huge
numbers of enemies she hasn't really
reached that point Point yet especially
enemies as powerful as the vites and
this is kind of the common theme among
basically everybody in the Coalition of
Worlds at least all the major players
Mark's struggling in the worst way right
because his imagination just goes
towards the death and destruction of
everybody that he knows Nolan while he
doesn't necessarily seem to be letting
it on he's struggling in the exact same
way but in his mind he has to be there
for his son because who else is going to
be right I mean there's nobody else here
his like Mark's mom Debbie she's not
here right Oliver is probably waking up
right there's not a whole lot that they
can do here and so literally Nolan just
kind of has to tell Mark like you got to
calm down you got to relax now a lot of
this is coming from a place where
Nolan's dealt with this time and time
again right either it was on Earth for
the fear of the vites coming there it
was on the other world that he went to
where the vites literally did show up
but Nolan's entire life has been mired
in death and destruction so while I
wouldn't necessarily say this is
business as usual what I will say is
it's not new to him right so he kind of
knows how to cope with these things but
even for Nolan to a degree this is New
Territory but when he was on Earth he
met Debbie he fell in love he had a son
so even then he still has a lot to lose
but his experience is what really shines
through here his uh his wisdom right
really kind of comes through in these
instances the same thing happens with
Allen the alien right where like his
wife's like well the Mover aren't going
to be here for 20 minutes you know so
like we can knock boots if you're
interested Allan the alien is struggling
as well right I mean it's the same thing
everybody's struggling because everybody
has kind of come to care about each
other in a way right when you're
involved in a major conflict like this
and I've never served in the military so
I can't speak to that but I have to
imagine that in that kind of a situation
when your life is on the line right you
look to the person next to you and you
know you they they have your back
there's a kind of camaraderie and a sort
of Brotherhood that forms there among
these people and that's what's happened
here right these guys have fought and
some of them have almost died there are
members of their group that they've
become friends with who have died right
and so in the Revelation that their
lives were on the line any one of them
can perish and they have to look to the
person next to them as a person that
will do what they can to keep them alive
in the same way that they'll do what
they can to keep the other person alive
a camaraderie forms there right a family
relationship ship Dynamic forms there
and that's why Allan the aliens not just
like yeah man that sucked for Earth good
thing I don't live there right we're
just kind of like yeah man this is
terrible I'm really really worried about
what'll happen if Mark and Nolan get
back to their home world and find it's
been completely obliterated right so
again just kind of these struggles these
things that they're enduring that
they're kind of going going through and
Mark can't really seem to help himself
now again one part of this is just Youth
and inexperience the other part of this
is because Mark has people he cares
about so his imagination just kind of
deviating to the worst possible
situation is something that he just
can't help and so ultimately a voice
kind of comes on right the pilots who
you know what have you and say like
we'll be arriving in Earth's orbit
shortly take your positions Mark
immediately leaves right because he can
survive in the vacuum of space by
holding his breath and he'll he'll
arrive on Earth long before his breath
runs out this guy beines it towards his
planet right just bolts towards Earth
and when he gets there he's expecting to
see death destruction the end of all
things when he arrives there
everything's fine there's no death
there's no destruction the Guardians of
the globe are not SC scattered to the
Four Winds right there is it's not like
that instead he's just kind of like okay
cool they're not here they're not here
right because one of the things that
Nolan kept telling Mark is there's no
way that we know for sure they're
heading to Earth there's a good chance
they are not going to lie to you son but
we don't know exactly if that's really
what's happening as Mark's making his
way through there he's like no cool
everything's fine they're not here
they're not here we don't have to worry
about things enter thrag right this
guy's like no we are very much here we
very much are here on your world right
your your suspicion that we were coming
to Earth is 100% accurate and Mark
immediately lashes out right in
emotional state immediately lashes out
and attacks thrag Nolan tries to hold
him back like look no no no no that's
not going to happen son right cuz Mark's
like I killed Conquest I'll find a way
to kill you let me tell you something
Mark like killing Conquest that's cool
and everything and it's nice this guy's
on a whole different level right this
this is this this guy is on a whole
different level right I mean Mark
defeating Conquest whatever man Conquest
was afraid of this guy if that gives you
any indication of of Freddy Mercury's
power right this guy is is nothing to be
nothing to be messed with right and then
so ultimately what what Freddy Mercury
actually does is he stops Mark right
instead of killing him because we know
that he doesn't want to kill mark and he
doesn't want to kill Nolan it's one of
the things that we saw at the end of the
last video that they need them he like
throws them to the side and says look
you know if you believe you can kill me
that's fine and by some chance you
happen to injure me just know I'm not
here alone the rest of my Army is here
as well and they'll destroy this world
and that's when he says like I am here
because I want to talk right if you want
to fight we can fight and I promise it
will not end well for you right this
fight will be over before it even starts
I was going easy on you earlier I can I
can tear you limb from limb in a matter
of seconds so either we can talk or we
can fight which one is it and ultimately
they're kind of like all right cool
let's talk now this is one of the most
interesting developments in any comic
book story that I think I've ever read
right remember the vites have been built
as this race right just like a race of
Supermen basically that are evil right
Conquering the universe that kind of a
thing what Freddy Mercury says is
there's only only 37 of us left that's
it when those 37 of us are gone our race
is extinct that's it like 37 members of
the vites are what separate us from
continued survival to Extinction and so
he says like you know at the end of the
day like I could destroy this world
right now and it would be a fair and
just response to what you did right
destroying the Vite world he says but I
don't want that if this war continues on
this is not a war that we can survive
right sure we'll lay waste to Earth and
everybody on Earth will die but so will
our race and in real the glory of the
Vite Empire is far more significant than
some small little mud ball on a
Backwater solar system right like we
don't care about that like what we care
about is continuing to survive so he
says like you took our world from us
we're going to take your world from you
and the response of Mark and Nolan and
really Mark himself is more like total
disgust like wait so what are you going
to are you going to like allow Humanity
to evacuate are you going to ask us to
literally pack up and leave our planet
so we can and try to find another one
that we can live on so you can have this
one that's that's not going to happen
right and ultimately like like Freddy
Mercury is like we're already here right
and we don't want to leave but just
something that you need to understand
here you couldn't make us leave if you
wanted to try with all your mind there's
nothing you could do to make us leave
here he's like so here's what I propose
we will live among your people right we
look just like humans they will never
notice the difference between us and
anybody else right unless we perform
some insane feet of strength or fly or
whatever it is but he's like we will
stay hidden we'll get regular jobs and
we will live in secret among everybody
on this world and no one will know that
we are here here's what I ask we'll
blend in we will intermingle and we will
interbreed we will have children with
humanity and when the time is right then
we'll conquer your
world so it's basically let's put this
war on hold for right now so we can
muster our forces and kill you later
right now the whole response here is
like the whole response of Mark is like
what you know and ultimately like like
the response of of thrag or of Freddy
Mercury is like it's the only way to
survive right we will restore our ranks
over the course course of thousands of
years he says human DNA has been proven
to make near-perfect hybrids the closest
thing we have to Pure blooded vites our
children and our children's children
will join our ranks their children will
have children and our ranks will swell
with the infusion of human DNA you will
allow us time to restore our numbers to
rebuild our Empire though the two of you
were responsible for the destruction of
our home world you will provide us with
our ultimate salvation the two of you
represent the future of our people what
we will become what we must become in
order to survive this is how things must
be and he says I will have your answer
now please do not make me destroy what
would be our last hope for survival this
is a big deal because it's basically
like it's All or Nothing folks if you
say yes then we'll destroy you at a
future point in time you can do what you
can to try to make more powerful people
and maybe somebody later on down the
line and your genetic structure will be
more capable but like we're going to
either we're going to stay here and
rebuild our ranks or we're going to wipe
out this whole world and we'll die in
the process and that's fine right we'll
take that death if it means destroying
all of you in the process right so
ultimately like the the whole response
of Mark is wait so you're proposing
you're what you're telling me Freddy
Mercury is you want to be able to live
on our world so you can become stronger
and you want you want me to agree like
how can I possibly agree to that and
he's like tomorrow's not today right
today is not tomorrow worry about that
tomorrow right worry about that later
what you have right now Mark is a choice
to make the choice that you can make is
to allow us to live here and to agree to
my terms we'll be in secret but we'll
swell our ranks and we'll destroy you at
a future point in time or we'll destroy
you all right now which one is it going
to be and so ultimately like noan like
Mark freaks out Mark's like this is the
most ridiculous thing ever and then
Nolan's like no right and Mark like this
is one of those times you're going to
have to say yes this is one of those
times when you're not going to want to
but you're going to have to and where
Mark is so emotional and Mark is so torn
up and it's like no like I don't want to
have anything to do with that he thinks
back to what the world will look like if
the vites have free reign because 37
vites against two one of which is a
human hybrid and hasn't reached his full
potential yet the other one has been
alive for thousands of years and is
still nowhere near close to powerful
enough to take out one Emperor let alone
anybody in his Royal Guard uh the the
only thing that Mark can do here is say
yes and that's what Mark does Mark
agrees to the terms of Freddy Mercury
and says yes fine you guys can stay here
on our world you can interbreed
intermingle whatever it is that you need
to do Mark ultimately acquiesces to the
emperor of the vmite Empire what's going
on guys this is Rob and we are back with
Invincible this is the aftermath to the
Vite War I imagine because it's the
aftermath not a whole lot of people will
watch this video and woti them because
this story is amazing okay so here's the
thing as we covered in the last video a
bargain was struck between Freddy
Mercury the vmite forces and Mark and
Nolan right and basically Freddy Mercury
and them said we'll stay here we'll
intermingle right we'll procreate with
your race and then once we're back to
our at least glor whatever it is then
things will commence from there right
it's kind of left open-ended as to
whether or not they'll actually end up
going to war with each other and for
those of you guys who have read ahead
please don't spoil the important thing
here is Mark actually meets back up with
his mom and of course he's got Nolan
with him and this is kind of a big deal
because this is the first time in any
real measure of time that Nolan and his
former wife have actually kind of gotten
back together or at least seen each
other for a prolonged amount of time
they saw each other for moments
previously but not for a lengthy period
of time now of course as soon as deor
sees Mark she's like where's Oliver
right she immediately starts freaking
out of course that's when she's told
Oliver is recovering he's alive right
he's on tetria he'll be taken care of
and that's when Nolan asks her who's
Paul because one of the things to keep
in mind is remember after Nolan had left
Mark's mom didn't necessarily bounce
around but she did find herself
attracted and in a relationship with a
guy named Paul and so with the two of
them kind of talking and and really
becoming close it was a little difficult
for Mark to to come to terms with but
you know eventually he did and he's
actually told by his mom you need to go
see Eve right she's not doing very well
and it's really one of those things
where it's like one you need to go talk
to your girl but two mom and dad need
some alone
time that's kind of what that is and so
what you end up getting is is really
this kind of just yelling this sort of
going on now in reality for Deborah
she's got a lot of emotion built up
right a lot of pain and a lot of anger
built up from everything that had
happened she doesn't let it all out here
in the moment instead Nolan's kind of
like okay so like you took another mate
and the you know her response here is it
wasn't a mate right it's not somebody
that I married and even if I did why
would you be pissed you were banging
everything all over space right how many
like aliens were you procreating with
like literally Mark showed up here with
another son that belonged to you saying
that like we have to raise him right so
like who are you to get mad at me about
this kind of thing and Nolan's response
is well I'm not upset I'm just kind of
disappointed now for her part Deborah's
right here right Nolan's got no reason
to be mad right he's got no reason to
even be upset now in the middle of all
that Cil comes barging in right the last
person that needs to be here Cil comes
barging in here right immediately starts
unloading on Nolan out of a out of a bit
of a panic and then realizes oh yeah
that's right this guy's reformed right
so the funny thing about this is for all
the Pomp and Circumstance about Cecil as
much as he kind of Buffs himself up and
makes himself up to be a big deal no
like the he he's almost kind of
panicking and is kind of glad the war is
not coming the reality is Humanity would
have been woefully unprepared even with
Cecil creating all these Invincible you
know powered beings right using all
those alternate reality versions of
invincible and kind of like reforming
them uh to to you know turn them into
basically henchmen like robotic henchmen
even then it wouldn't matter right I
mean like they would still get
obliterated especially at the hands of
the forces of all the other vure mites
but with the war being over Cil was kind
of like okay cool now at that point you
pick up with Mark right the one thing
you guys want to see you pick up with
Mark he flies over there he ends up
coming across Adam Eve he was like Hey
like it's me like the war's over I'm
back everything's okay baby everything's
cool we can all get back to normal she's
like no no no no don't come any closer
right he's like why and then you see
Adam Eve Adam Eve she hates the way she
looks right like Adam Eve what happened
to you girl I'll tell you what happened
Adam Eve got thick that's what happened
man Adam Eve got thick but nonetheless
right like like at the end of the day
she feels hideous right she sees
yourself as exceedingly unattractive and
hideous Mark doesn't care man he's just
happy to see his girl and I totally
understand right like I'd be the same
way I'd be like man girl I ain't seen
you in like 10 months right like I don't
I don't much care and it's kind of crazy
because Adam Eve's been like she's been
Holding On by a thread right and that's
one of the things to keep in mind is
that Adam Adam Eve was just crazy in
love with Mark right like head over
heels in love with this guy and she
understood why he had to leave like the
the the whole situation between Adam Eve
and Mark like juxtaposes the whole
situation with Nolan and Deborah in
almost a perfect way right that where
Nolan bailed out Mark had to go right
Mark didn't want to go but he had to go
right and he almost kind of went with
her understanding and really did leave
with her understanding why he had to
leave in the first place but nonetheless
for her it's been extremely difficult
right she recently got her powers back
which is kind of a cool thing but for
the most part the emotional and and
mental anguish of of knowing that Mark
could die at any point while he's out
there in this war was just a little too
much for her to handle because at the
end of the day she thought Mark was dead
right and that's kind of the big the big
issue that goes on here is Mark told her
explicitly I don't know how long I'm
going to be gone for I I could be gone
for weeks I could be gone for months I
could be gone for years right and and
she you know he left with her knowing
that and she allowed him to leave
knowing that right I guess tried to make
peace with it as best as she possibly
could but she didn't know right I mean
he was on like the other side of the
universe there was no way for her to
know and the reality is Her Imagination
ran away with it right Her Imagination
ran away with the idea that Mark's dead
she never heard a single thing from him
for for Nolan and Debbie what you
actually get here is this interesting
scenario where Debbie's highly
conflicted and the reason for this is
because because as she's sitting down
talking to Nolan she says the truth is
after seeing you again things with Paul
just felt wrong not that I believe a
word of what you said that you have
feelings for me that you regret what
you've done there's no way to come back
from that and the response of Nolan here
is and yet after seeing me you could no
longer stand to be with another man and
he says I wish that there was some way
to make you aware of just how much I've
missed you and the crazy thing is Debbie
kind of wants to forgive him but she
can't bring herself to right that's the
conflict coming in that's the conflict
coming in right when she looks at her
husband she doesn't see the no one that
she was in love with and had Mark with
and they were going to live happily ever
after when she sees her husband she sees
a man that almost destroyed the world F
you know and almost killed her son in
the process and then left she sees a
villain right she sees just a villain
more so than that a villain that
betrayed her betrayed her son and
betrayed everything they stood for a man
that seemingly every word he said to her
was a lie and a lot of that's because
for Nolan he didn't realize that he
actually cared about deie until she was
gone until he left in that moment when
he left when he was talking to Mark you
guys remember that whole discussion
whether you saw the show whether you saw
the the the whether you read the comic
you guys saw that discussion he looked
down on Humanity Humanity was lower than
him lower than he was he even saw his
you know saw his wife Debbie as
something a candle Like A Primitive ape
right something that was just kind of
entertaining right not really something
to to to laugh at but like Humanity was
so primitive in relation to the vites
they live for thousands of years she'll
die after 80 and so it's one of those
things where you're kind of like you
know you you see that that she had kind
of experienced all of that right even
when like the whole video was leaked to
the public right when she saw all of
that she felt betrayed in the most
egregious way because now she knows how
he actually saw her and then here he is
now saying I missed you I loved you baby
take me back and how do you come back
from that right how do you believe that
and she even says that right Nolan says
I can never take back what I did to you
I understand that all I can say is that
I was misguided lost there were so many
emotions conflicting thoughts I had
thousands of years of beliefs to
overcome you have to try and understand
the response she says is no I don't have
to understand a damn thing you ruined my
life don't you understand that you
ruined everything and she says I wish
everything could go back to the way that
it was before and the response of Nolan
is things will never go back but I'll
never lie to you again but that's the
issue right that's that's the issue here
there are things that happen in a
relationship things that you will do
things that you will say maybe not
because you intend to maybe because you
intend to but your relationship will
cross a line that it cannot come back
from things will never ever ever be the
same no matter how long things go on for
the rest of your life right Nolan could
just continue on with Deborah until the
end of her life right because he'll
outlive her and she will never look at
him the way she did before everything
popped off in the beginning of the story
right she'll never see him the same way
she'll never hold his hand the same way
she'll never kiss him the same way
she'll never make love to him the same
way it'll never ever be the same as it
used to be it's just the way those
things are and so following that you
pick back up with Mark right when he
gets back over to Eve's place and she's
trying on her costume and she's like
does this make my butt look bigger and
Mark's like damn
son that thick that thick thick right I
mean she she looks good as hell he's
like man I'm sweetheart you don't need
to lose that way and right Mark's Mark's
feeling it
son he's absolutely feeling it but you
kind of get this this bit of a
discussion going on right and things
kind of return a little bit to normal in
so far as you have Eve Who's over
talking to Mark's mom and they're kind
of know getting together and and and
things are kind of getting back to
normal a little bit and in fact they
kind of you know make some funny jokes
about Mark and you know when he was
younger and and some of those little
embarrassing moments and things along
those lines but there's really a lot of
of you know familiarity and there's a
lot of comfort uh with things going back
to normal and one of the things that
happens is that Mark and Adam Eve
actually end up going to visit the home
of immortal and duplicate right only to
find out that like they've been
procreating like rabbits right they
actually got a couple of kids going on
and they're like man you know now Eve
immediately does doesn't really take to
the idea of the kids being there right
she's just kind of like huh you know she
seems a little off about those kids and
so of course you know you have like Mark
who thinks they're absolutely adorable
you know and and and like Immortals just
like yeah man the kids like they they
eat they like to eat early right like I
hope you don't mind like we've already
made dinner and Mark's like know it's
cool man it's like they're all kind of
hanging out and they're they're they're
eating and they're having a good time
right talking about the idea of having
twins and and so on and so forth and
it's kind of interesting right just kind
of a bit of a discussion and and just
general conversation there now there
does come a point when duplicates giving
the the twins a bath and Eve is there
but she doesn't want to be there right
she's she seems just so so uncomfortable
right this discussion that they used to
have when they used to talk about the
idea of like you know Eve and Mark
having kids and settling down buying a
house you know that kind of typical
nuclear family right Midwestern American
kind of thing and it's it's one of those
things where she's where Eve just
doesn't really seem to want to have
anything to do with it anymore over the
course of these last 10 months there was
just like an extreme shift in the way
that Eve saw her life playing out with
Mark versus the way she sees it now but
the funny thing is it doesn't really
have much to do with Mark right instead
you know when Eve is asked by duplicate
are you okay she's like no I'm not I am
not okay and she races out of the room
right she basically hands the kids back
over to duplicate and takes off once she
gets outside Mark's like okay what's
going on right Kate said that you were
crying and that you know you're upset
like what's what's going on and where
she initially tries to kind of of brush
it off right wipe her eyes clean herself
up and say I'm fine I just needed some
air mark knows her better than that and
Mark's like you know no like what's
going on right like what's happening you
know is this something that Kate said
like what's going on and and Eve stops
and says no you just need to listen what
she reveals is she had an abortion right
and like the whole like for in her mind
the whole reason behind that is she was
basically pregnant at the time that Mark
left right Mark got Eve pregnant and she
couldn't she couldn't go through with a
kid right she couldn't do it alone she
couldn't raise a kid by herself she
couldn't try to navigate these Waters by
herself knowing her husband was probably
dead out there somewhere that the the
belief that her husband died had this
massive impact on her and she aborted
her child in the process and so at that
point she's not really able to handle
the situation right it's why she ran
away from the idea of kids you know when
when uh when she was holding duplicates
kids because it reminds her of the life
that she gave up right it reminds her of
something she sacrificed here and so
where Mark Comforts her as best as he
can at the end of the day it's crushing
for him too right because he could could
have potentially had a child here and
now he doesn't have one and then you get
probably one of the most [__] moments
of the whole story where duplicates like
I give him another week tops right like
I love but she just can't keep a man
happy she's got way too many issues
right it's a [__] thing to say to be
honest but at the end of the day she I
guess she doesn't say it where Eve and
Mark in hearer because if she did I
imagine Eve probably would have just
beat the hell out of her at the end of
the day the two of them you know just
kind of cry together and this really
seems to be given the the future
depiction that we saw of Eve and and
mark the idea that like they just never
really seem to get together that almost
seems like a guaranteed future right one
way or another it just doesn't work out
between the two of them whether it's
because Mark just never really tells
tells her how she feels and so she
spends all this time pining over him
never moves on and finds anybody else
and ends up miserable or if it's because
of the fact that something like this
happens that drives a wedge because the
reality is when it comes to a decision
like that that can drive a wedge between
two people right the loss of a child
whether it's through abortion or through
like an early death from an accident
whatever the case is that can kill
relationships and so the result of that
is it seems like Mark and Eve are kind
of at an impass and whether or not
they'll get together well we'll just
have to wait and find out but with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this to an end thank you for watching
and I will catch you all later
peace